Good morning.
Seeing that the board members are now present, Brooks, will you please call the roll to establish
a quorum?
Good morning.
President Darlin-Hammond.
Here.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Here.
Member Olken.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Here.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member Porter.
Here.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Here.
Everyone's present.
All right.
I hereby call the November 2022 meeting of the State Board of Education to order at
8.36 a.m., and I'd like to commence by saluting the flag.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez, will you please lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance?
Sure.
Please rise for the Pledge.
Put your right hand over your heart.
Ready, begin.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic for
which it stands, one nation, under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you very much.
I'm going to start with our general announcements.
There are five items on the agenda that have addenda.
Item 12, Attachment 5, which is the CASP and LPAC test results.
Item 4, Attachment 3, which is the overview of the Children and Youth Behavioral Health
Initiative.
Item 2, the addendum is the 2023-24 State Board of Education Student Member, recommendation
of three finalists.
Item 3, the addendum is the reports from the 2022 Student Advisory Board on Education.
And item 1, the addendum is the 2022 State Board of Education Screening Committee recommendations
regarding appointments to the Advisory Commission on Charter School, California Practitioners
Advisory Group, and the Instructional Quality Commission.
The proposed waiver consent items today are W1 through W6.
And the proposed regular consent items are items 5 through 9.
There's one public hearing on the agenda.
Item 10, which is the appeal from an action of the Orange County Committee on School District
Organization to approve a petition to transfer territory from the Orange County Unified School
District to the Tustin Unified School District.
There are some changes in the agenda.
We will reopen item 1, State Board Priorities, later this afternoon to take action on the
preliminary report of actions and the draft September 2022 meeting minutes, the State
Board of Education Screening Committee recommendations for appointments to various SBE advisory
committees, and to report on our liaison assignments.
In terms of public input, members of the public wishing to call in for public comment
should view the live stream of the meeting to know at what time public comment will occur
for each item.
Public comment may be provided by dialing the phone number, entering a participant access
code, and then following each of the operator's prompts.
Upon dialing in, callers will be added to a caller queue.
The operator will notify callers when it is their turn to provide public comment.
We will also ask callers to please turn down the speaker volume of their computers if they
are following the live webcast to avoid the echoing effect.
Public comment is limited to one minute for each speaker.
Item 11 is the general public comment item, during which members of the public may provide
comment on matters that are not specifically listed in the Board's agenda.
Board members, please mute your microphones when not speaking, keep your cameras on at
all times except during the scheduled breaks to ensure that we maintain a quorum throughout
today's virtual meeting.
And for each item on the agenda, there will be an opportunity for the Board members to
raise their Zoom hand if they would like to ask a question or make a comment.
So item one is our State Board projects and priorities item.
And I will now turn it over to the State Superintendent to provide his report.
State Superintendent?
We want to shift back to the boardroom.
Is the State Superintendent there?
He is.
We're just repositioning the cameras.
Okay.
That was an interesting effect.
Felt a little like Star Wars.
Good morning, Madam President and members of the Board.
And to staff and to all who are following today.
I'd like to start by congratulating our 29 California Blue Ribbon schools who are being
recognized in Washington, D.C. as we speak.
These schools have been recognized for their efforts in the past.
These schools have been recognized for their efforts in closing the achievement gap for
historically underserved students.
I'm pleased to share with you that California has more Blue Ribbon schools than any state
in our nation.
It was an honor to meet with many representatives from the Blue Ribbon schools this week to talk
with them about the efforts that they have implemented to help achieve these great
accomplishments and to partner with them on ways that they can help other schools in our
state going forward.
As you all know, in the month of October, we released the test scores for California
students, and despite some bright spots, we saw that in California and in the nation,
many students experienced declines in math and reading.
I don't have to put it in context for you what our students have been through all across
the country that has contributed to these declines, but we know that we can support our
students in overcoming these opportunities, and I'm also pleased to share with you some
important resources that have been provided to do so.
As we speak, we are allocating some $7.9 billion to California schools in a discretionary block
grant that is focused on learning recovery.
This means that schools will have resources to promote learning acceleration, to provide
counseling and other supports for our students.
In addition to this block grant, California is providing our schools with more than $4
billion to support expanded learning opportunities, to lengthen the school day, to lengthen the
school year, to provide support to our students during all parts of the day to support their
recovery, and I would also point to what's now $4 billion in community schools resources
to support health, mental health, and other needs that our students have as they heal
and recover and ultimately thrive going forward.
You'll hear more about community schools today, and you'll hear about our technical
assistance programs.
You'll also hear from Dr. Galli from the Department of Health and Human Services who
will talk about our partnership as it relates to the Children's Behavioral Health Initiative.
We've started a learning acceleration webinar series to provide best practices and technical
assistance to our schools.
I want to thank Dr. Darling-Hammond for participating in that first webinar and our partners at
CCEE who shared their learning acceleration blueprint and thank school leaders from Berkeley
Unified School District and from Lodi Unified School District who shared the various programs
that they are providing to support our students.
As we think about learning recovery, I'd like to also remind you that California is
making a historic investment to school districts for reading coaches and specialists who will
help our educators to strengthen their ability to teach reading to our youngest children.
This is an exciting investment of more than $250 million that is paired with an investment
in funding for professional development to support educators as it relates to supporting
reading.
I'm also excited that this grant funding gives us a way to work with a cohort of 125
school districts to support them in reading but also to engage them in math and other
subjects where we can support students.
And if we can help those 125 school districts imagine what we can do for helping to move
things in the right direction for California.
Our webinar series will continue in just a few weeks.
We'll be providing school districts with direct information about how the learning recovery
block grant will work and some of the intended allocations and how they can use those dollars.
We're also going to be providing a webinar for school districts on dealing with the opioid
crisis.
Many of you have followed in the news that sadly we've seen a steep rise in incidents
related to fentanyl.
Many children ingesting fentanyl often not knowing that they are and that this has had
deadly consequences.
We've convened partners in health, in public health, in prevention, in education programs,
in law enforcement and others to help translate for school districts what it is that they
need to do to prevent loss of life due to fentanyl.
We will be putting on a webinar for districts to help them leverage all the resources that
exist for education, for prevention, for substance abuse, intervention and of course
intervention for someone who is overdosing from fentanyl.
California is making NARCAM available to California schools and just a few days ago
I sent a letter to every single school district in our state imploring them to take up this
very important cause, to work with us and the Department of Public Health in having
available NARCAM and in utilizing every single resource for education, for prevention, for
substance abuse, intervention and to use the federal dollars that are also provided that
can be used for substance abuse, prevention and education.
And finally I want to highlight a webinar that we will be putting on in just a few weeks
that we call Educator Wellness.
We recognize how difficult the work of our teachers and classified staff and administrators
and school board members and others continues to be and we will be convening a conversation
about wellness for educators throughout the state.
We see this as a critical part of our work to help retain our workforce.
I'm grateful to Dr. Darling-Hammond, to the governor, to the legislature, to the Commission
on Teacher Credentialing for work that we did last year, to the state board and others
on work that we did last year to find ways to retain teachers, many teachers who are
new teachers, teachers who are completing some of their requirements, but we know that
we have to take stock in the hard work that educators do every day and have been doing
certainly during the pandemic and how we can support them.
We look forward to being joined by our surgeon general who will help us to lift up the ways
that school districts can help our educator workforce and support them.
This builds on our work that we're doing to support recruitment and retention and so
we hope that you will join us for these webinars and look forward to the publicity of these
events announcing the dates and the content that will be provided.
This concludes my formal remarks.
I'd like to just take a few minutes to acknowledge some great staff who have provided incredible
service to the students of California and who have announced their retirement.
With your permission, Dr. Darling-Hammond, I'd like to recognize Judy Sias for her 11 years
of incredible service to the state board of education, to the state of California.
Yeah, that deserves a hand clap.
Judy has demonstrated a kind of unwitting knowledge of everything that is EDCO,
almost like an encyclopedic knowledge and has been an incredible leader in our work.
I don't know if Judy's in the room, but the lawyers have just told me that Judy is in fact in the room.
This just in and we'd like to have a moment to recognize Judy and thank you and embarrass you
and appreciate you for your incredible service.
We have some gifts for you and some certificates for you and I know you don't want to,
but perhaps you'd like to have a few words while we do this.
Let's please welcome Judy as she comes.
Congratulations.
Hello.
I always said when you hear from a lawyer, there's probably not a good sign as to how the meeting is going,
but maybe in this case it's okay.
So I wrote down what I wanted to say.
So I wanted to thank everyone for your kind wishes.
It's been a real honor to be appointed to work for the state board
and I've been very lucky to be part of a team that's been doing such amazing work over the years for the kids of California.
I'd like to thank the SBE executive directors that I've worked with, Super, Karen Staff Walters, and Brooks Allen.
They've all been very supportive and amazing colleagues.
I'd also like to thank Superintendents Thurmond and Torlakson, each and every board member,
and especially Presidents Linda Darling Hammond and Mike Curse for their leadership.
It's been a real privilege to work with such titans in the field of education.
I'd also like to recognize the small but mighty SBE team, my colleagues at CDE as well as the Department of Finance and the governor's office.
I've learned a lot from everyone.
And I want to say a special thank you to Amy Holloway, who is my partner over at CDE.
I could not have done this job without her support and friendship.
So those of you who work with us at the state board, you know that we spend an inordinate amount of time planning these meetings.
We study the schedule and we study the agenda and estimate how long each item might take.
So even though it's only nine o'clock, I'm sure we're behind schedule already or very close to it.
So I'm going to and President Darling Hammond is looking at the clock worrying about keeping things on track.
I will stop talking and spare you a long speech.
And thank you very much for everything.
I know that what you just shared was privileged, but we are privileged to have heard from you.
And I know that board members will want to acknowledge you directly, Judy, for your incredible service.
I'd like to also acknowledge another great attorney who's also retiring, Amy Holloway, our general counsel at the California Department of Education.
After 26 amazing years to the state of California, beginning her legal journey and state service at the FPPC,
defending and interpreting so many lawsuits that have come in and helping to guide our work across many issued areas,
but also in partnership with many, many state agencies, the State Board of Education and of course, just every state agency that you can imagine.
We will miss you and want to also congratulate for incredible service.
Amy Holloway, please welcome her as she comes.
Good morning.
I don't know that I'm going to get through this without crying and the echo.
Superintendent Thurman, chief deputy, Mary Nicely, board president, Linda Darling Hammond and board members.
Maybe for the last time, I'm general counsel Amy Bisson Holloway with the Department of Education.
Lisa, one of my colleagues here in the room has already started crying, so that's going to be hard.
But I want to thank all of you for this opportunity.
I especially want to thank the superintendent and the chief deputy for the opportunity to serve in this position in your administration.
It's been very meaningful and a great way to end my career with the state.
I also need to thank my family.
They are just such an important part of my life.
My mom and dad were both high school math teachers.
And I realized in thinking about this this morning that they taught my sisters and I that math was about aptitude and hard work, not about gender.
We didn't know we were learning that message as we did, but as we were being raised, but we did.
All three of us have degrees in science based fields and have become good thinkers and I think good people because of their compassion and love our whole lives.
I have two sisters, Ellen and Trish, who were role models to me my entire life, even when they were torturing me because I was the middle child and it was fun.
My husband, John Holloway, who's a third grade teacher, and he may be watching this with his class.
So Thomas Edison Elementary School Language Institute.
Go Tigers.
He's been my life partner and a support system.
It was never my job to do the laundry or to pick up kids.
We did that together and so that both of us could achieve our dreams and work hard.
My daughters, Kylie and Emily, who think I'm a hero just because I have a passion for education and for public service.
They are just wonderful people and I'm lucky to have them in my life.
I have a family here at CDE.
I've been here for 21 years and I'm grateful to all of you for giving me opportunities to lead.
I've learned something from all of you every day and Judy said it much better than I about our relationships with outside folks from the legislature, Department of Finance, Governor's office, office.
I want to thank those advocacy groups that we've worked with and professionals in the field.
Even when we didn't agree, our commitment to the children of California brought us to good resolutions and disputes and regulations and guidance to the field.
I want to especially thank my staff in the legal division.
They are just wonderful, hardworking, smart, passionate folks.
It's such a strong team.
You will be fine without me and you probably won't even miss me in a couple months, but take a couple months to miss me.
That would be good.
I also want to recognize the legal and audits divisions and the charter schools divisions that are under my branch for their hard work and commitment to the children of California.
They're just a wonderful staff and I've been very fortunate to lead and work with them.
And lastly, I want to thank my mentors and personal support groups, Marsha Bedwell, Eileen Gray, Todd Smith and Judy Sias.
I would not have made it at this job, been successful, would not have failed and been able to pick myself back up without their support and kindness and intelligence and good thinking.
So I'm sure I've forgotten things, but thank you all very much.
I have really enjoyed this opportunity.
Thank you, Amy.
And thank you for being a great leader for our department and for legal audits and the charter divisions and for the plug for mathematics.
Thank you.
I'd like to also recognize another attorney who's provided 20 years of service and has played a critical role on many matters related to charter schools, instructional materials, nutrition services and has developed expertise in these areas over many, many years.
And that is Todd Smith, who is also retiring after 20 years of service and has served as our chief counsel to the department.
Todd, thank you for your incredible leadership in the department.
Thank you for your sense of humor and your thoughtfulness.
And congratulations on your announced retirement and you will be remiss.
And if you'd come forward, we'd like to also recognize you.
Well, good morning.
State Superintendent President Darlingham and board members.
I've been practicing law for about 30 years.
The first 10 years I was in the private sector and didn't find that all for all that fulfilling.
So I looked around at the people in my life and the person who had the career that I admired most and the person who I admired most was my mom, who was a long time public teacher.
30 years ended her career in FLAO City Unified after 30 years of teaching there.
So, you know, I realized teaching wasn't really a rational decision at that point, watching how hard she worked.
So I decided to come here to CDE and to hopefully help teachers like her and students in the state of California.
That was a great decision.
And working here has been just a wonderful experience, especially working with amazing attorneys like Amy and Judy and another attorney who's retiring.
I'm sure we'll be mentioned soon, Liz Stein.
Also, all the attorneys in the legal office.
It's been just a great experience.
It's been a pleasure representing the state superintendent, the board, the CDE.
Thank you so much for acknowledging my service here today.
I'm truly honored.
Thank you.
I thank you and congratulations to Liz who can't be here today.
And I'm going to turn this over to you, Madam President, in case you and the board members want to have some remarks for those who are retiring.
But if we could have one more round of applause for Judy and Amy and Todd.
Congratulations.
Thank you so much, Superintendent Thurman.
And we would also like to thank Amy Holloway and Todd Smith for their service to the state, the department and the board.
You know, we've gotten such wise counsel and deep expertise and institutional knowledge.
It will be greatly missed.
And Amy, it'll be more than a couple of months that we will be thinking about missing you and Todd as well.
Brooks, I believe we have certificates of appreciation for Amy and Todd.
Would you please present them now?
Amy, on behalf of the board, thank you so much for everything you've done.
Couldn't say more than what the superintendent and Linda have said.
But your leadership and your camaraderie and your support both personally and professionally to all the board members and to us as board staff is incredibly important.
And honestly, I don't know what it's going to be like without you, but I'm scared to find out.
But anyway, thank you.
And Todd, Todd and I know each other even before I was in this job.
Anyway, Todd, likewise, I just echo everything that's been said.
Incredibly thoughtful, a problem solver in every way, both making sure everything was legally accurate, but also really always looking out for the interest of students and teachers like your family.
And that always came through in all the work you did.
And I know the board has really appreciated all of your partnerships throughout the years.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you very much.
And we'll send this to you, Liz, wherever you see this recording.
And of course, I'm not forgetting our wonderful departing chief counsel, Judy Sias, or that she's leaving us bereft, I might add.
And I will come back for a proper celebration of Judy after I complete the president's report because we have a couple of additional things for her to experience.
So I will focus on where California schools are in this moment.
We're not quite post pandemic here where I guess we're in the endemic, as they say, but we are working hard not only to rebalance, but to accelerate learning at a time of great need.
And many of us have heard talk about learning loss and learning recovery.
I just want to clarify because I've heard some misunderstandings of the term that students individually have not gone backwards in their learning.
They have not lost learning that they had.
But the concern is that they have not been progressing over this period of the pandemic as quickly as they would have had.
We not had all of the challenges and stress and trauma that children and families and schools have have experienced.
So it's really about what might be called learning lag or a slower rate of progress that many people experience, many students have experienced.
And the rate of gain is what we are really now trying to focus in on so that when we say that third graders did less well than last year, we're not talking about those third graders moving backwards,
but that the cohort of third graders has not been gaining as rapidly as we might have seen for that group of students in the past.
So last week, the National Assessment of Educational Progress results were released.
This is the only measure that can look comparably at achievement across all the states, and it gives us a certain kind of barometer for understanding where we are.
It's called the nation's report card, and it tests a sample of fourth and eighth grade students in every state in math and reading.
And typically, NAEP, as it's called, is administered every odd numbered year, but there was no NAEP in 2020 or 2021 due to the pandemic.
So the release marked the first national results since 2019 before the pandemic, and the results pointed both to our challenges and to our opportunities.
So the scores, as Superintendent Thurman noted, went downward across the country between 2019 and 2022, again, meaning that fourth graders in this cohort were not achieving the same level as fourth graders in a previous cohort and similarly for eighth graders.
But California students lost less ground than most states in every area and less ground than the national average.
And in the key area of eighth grade reading, California students showed no learning loss at all.
So we were comparable to where we were in 2019.
As a result, California has moved up in the state by state rankings across the board.
And in eighth grade reading, California has moved from 48th in the country in 2013, about a decade ago, at the very bottom, all the way up to the national average.
So we're seeing that the results of the investments that we're making are making a difference and certainly doing so relative to other states.
Among cities, there's a special city part of the NAEP where large cities are able to be tested and reported on.
Both Los Angeles and San Diego were in the NAEP urban districts analysis.
Not only did both do better than most other cities and the urban average, which dipped several points across the nation,
but Los Angeles actually gained slightly in fourth grade reading and significantly in eighth grade reading,
while San Diego remained the top scoring urban district in the nation in eighth grade reading,
and it scores states stable and in the top group of cities in fourth grade.
And I just want to note that we've been fortunate to have Alison Yoshimoto-Towry join the board,
and she was the chief academic officer in Los Angeles during this period of time.
So some part of this success is due to the work of her and her many colleagues there.
This is not to minimize the extensive work that is still needed both to recover and to continue supporting our students to forge ahead.
And while our decreases were less than those in most other states, our achievement levels have been and are much lower in math,
a point to which we will return.
And as you know, we will be hopefully not only adopting a mathematics framework early 2023,
but also investing in its strong implementation.
But I do think there are two important takeaways from the NAEP results.
One is that California's swift and comprehensive actions almost from the very minute COVID was discovered in our state are probably the reason for these relatively better outcomes.
Since the earliest days of the pandemic, California has invested nearly $24 billion to both assure the safety of students and teachers and provide intensive supports to keep students learning.
And many of those dollars are allocated in ways that will continue into the future.
They were not just one time moments for recovery.
This all hands on deck effort has left no aspect of education untouched for bridging the digital divide,
focusing in on learning support from the beginning.
Superintendent Thurman and myself and the first partner and the governor all were rolling up our sleeves from the minute the schools physically closed to pull digital devices by the tens of thousands into our schools.
And then the legislature added on enormous investments.
And we're continuing to add on for connectivity, offering digital integration guidance with extensive professional development for teachers,
upgrading HVAC systems, supporting free COVID testing and vaccinations.
So we had the fewest school closings per capita in the nation last year, expanding learning into before school, after school and summertime, intensifying social, emotional and mental health supports, bringing on tutors and coaches and investing in teacher recruitment and retention.
Los Angeles, for example, did all of these things using state and federal funds and initially deploying into its own reserves to ensure that students got food, computers and hotspots immediately upon school closing, offering universal summer school and tutoring for the last three years, supporting mental health supports and community schools initiatives.
Los Angeles was also able to open school this year with all of its vacancies filled, while many districts were experiencing substantial shortages in part because it was one of the first districts to offer substantial wage hikes and retention bonuses last year.
And we were told because of an aggressive recruitment campaign and its several teacher residency programs, which produced the well-prepared supply of teachers in shortage areas who've been staying in the classroom.
Los Angeles also put in place a coherent plan to support reading both in the lower grades and in the middle schools with an interdisciplinary approach that infused literacy into every subject area, giving students the opportunity to continue to develop their reading and writing skills throughout the grades.
So you'll also hear later in the meeting about evidence from our state tests that learning recovery may have been happening at a steeper rate over this past year than in the years before the pandemic.
So most importantly, the scores show us that California's commitment to the academic progress of every student must continue in full force in the days, months and years to come.
We cannot take our foot off the accelerator now.
These data serve as a clarion call to push forward the transformation of California schools that's been begun over the last three years when Governor Newsom and the state legislature increased school spending by 30% and began to redesign the system to meet 21st century needs.
And these initiatives include the universal preschool for all four-year-olds with its initial expansion this year, universal free school meals, summer school and after school learning and supports for literacy and STEM, many of which are already underway, with new standards for elementary teachers and educational specialists for their training for teaching, as well as educator preparation programs and others which will follow.
It also includes the $4 billion expansion of community schools, which research shows can help increase school attendance, improve learning and increase graduation rates.
And it includes the Children and Youth Behavioral Health Initiative that will connect closely with schools to ensure our students are able to thrive and focus on their learning free of the toxic stress that accompanies trauma.
We have an item on community schools that will include an update on the Behavioral Health Initiative today.
I'm very excited for us to all hear about it.
The whole child approach is critical to creating the kind of environment that supports high quality learning for every campus and every child across our state.
With both local and state leaders focused and ready to do everything possible to help students rebound and thrive, we will redouble our efforts to ensure that every student succeeds.
And with that, I'm going to move on to our more bittersweet business, and we are going to properly and fully acknowledge and congratulate our beloved Chief Counsel Judy Sias on her upcoming retirement and celebrate her many contributions to our 1,000 school districts, 10,000 schools and almost 6 million students.
During her 11 years as Chief Counsel, spanning two governors, two state board presidents and three executive directors, Judy has helped guide California's public education system through major changes, including implementation of the local control funding formula, its new state accountability system, the transition to new online assessments, new charter school policy, new curriculum frameworks and instructional materials, among many other things.
Her work includes analyzing complex memoranda and agenda items, reviewing contracts, providing oral and written legal advice to board members, staff and advisory committees, directing and reviewing the work of litigation counsel to ensure alignment with the policy direction of the board, managing cases, writing and reviewing amicus briefs, but Judy's skills go far beyond those.
With her help of her dog Bindi, Judy is the ultimate problem solver.
So whenever we have an issue that arises that requires creative thinking, the staff and often the board members turn to Judy, and Judy leashes up Bindi for a long walk.
Typically, the game plan is found by the time they return home or arrive at Chocolate Fish, their favorite coffee shop, whichever comes first.
And I have to admit that I've been on a number of those calls with Judy where we do amazing problem solving, which Bindi sometimes chimes in and helps with.
Judy is also a foremost expert on California education policy and the education code itself.
The superintendent noted that she has an encyclopedic knowledge base that is indeed true.
Her remarkable ability to set the context by explaining the history of any issue is an invaluable asset.
And more than once when asked a question, Judy responds with the exact section of the education code in which the answer is found, quoted chapter and verse.
That book is usually open on her desk, by the way.
Judy is also an adept relationship builder before coming to the state board.
She was assistant general counsel for the California School Boards Association, somehow managed to not only keep up with the many relationships developed there, but add new ones at the state board.
And more than anything, Judy is a great friend who is always there for a colleague in need.
Her ability to lighten up the mood with a spirited but often off key version of a pop song will also be sorely missed.
So we want to wish Judy best of luck.
We want to continue to learn from you in the days ahead.
We do have a certificate for Judy.
And Brooks, would you please do the honors?
Thank you again. I really appreciate all this.
I realized when Amy and Todd were speaking that their parents were both teachers.
My mom was a teacher. My dad worked at community college.
So I think there's a theme here.
I remember the first thing I did with education was my dad had me put door hangers walking around against Prop 13.
So I've been working on education issues my whole life.
And thank you for the Bindi call out.
And I'm sure Chocolate Fish appreciates the advertisement as well.
Thank you very much.
Wow. That's an interesting historical reference to Proposition 13, which we've been trying to get over ever since.
So thanks for your efforts as a child also, Judy, in that regard.
Well, we're going to move on to item two.
And item two is the 2023-2024 State Board of Education student member recommendation of three finalists for submissions of the governor for consideration and appointment.
And while we have just welcomed Naomi to the board and we're delighted to see you, Naomi, it's already time to begin the selection process for next year's student member.
So the State Board of Education's screening committee recommends that the State Board approve the three finalists for the position as identified in the item addendum.
And the approved finalists will be forwarded to the governor for his consideration and appointment as the 2023-24 State Board student member.
This item will be presented by the screening committee chair, Vice President Glover Woods.
Vice President Glover Woods, please begin.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
And again, congratulations, Judy, Amy, Todd, and Liz. Congratulations on your retirement.
I'm excited to bring this item forward to the State Board of Education for approval.
The student member selection process is always one of the highlights of the work of the screening committee.
And as it has been in years past, we had a remarkable group of students, applicants this year.
Just a little background on the process.
Every year, high school students in their junior year are invited to submit applications to serve as the State Board of Education student member.
This year, we had 20 phenomenal students applied.
The applicants were screened by the screening committee and narrowed to 12 candidates, and the screening committee met on October 18th to do that work.
The 12 candidates that were selected by the screening committee attended the Student Advisory Board on Education Conference.
And at that conference, they made presentations to their peers, the student delegates that were at the conference.
The student delegates chose six candidates who were interviewed by the State Board of Education screening committee yesterday.
Members Escobedo, Lewis, McQuillan, Porter and I have the very difficult task of selecting three finalists who we will be considering today.
If our recommendations are approved by the State Board of Education,
The names of the three applicants will be submitted to the governor's office for consideration and final selection of the one student who will serve as the 2023-24 student member of the State Board of Education.
It's my pleasure to announce the three finalists.
Anya Ayyapan, Eduardo Corona and Kristi Tu.
At this time, I would like to ask Anya, Eduardo and Kristi to introduce themselves and tell us the school they attend and the name of their school districts.
So I believe, oh, I see them right there in the conference room.
I would like to first ask for Anya to come forward and introduce herself, school and district.
Hi, everyone. Can you guys hear me?
It's great to see all of you. My name is Anya Ayyapan. I attend Doherty Valley High School in San Ramon, which is a part of the San Ramon Valley Unified School District.
Yeah, I think that's it. It's great to be here. Thank you so much for the opportunity.
Thank you, Anya. I'd now like to invite Eduardo to introduce himself, his school and school district.
Hi, everyone. My name is Eduardo Corona. I attend Canyon Springs High School in Murno Valley, which is in the Murno Valley Unified School District. It's great to see everyone.
Eduardo, it's great to see you as well. And now I'd like to invite our third finalist, Kristi, to the podium to introduce herself, school and district.
Hi, everyone. My name is Kristi. I attend Northwood High School in Irvine Unified School District, and it's an honor to meet all of you.
Thank you, Kristi.
I'd also like to acknowledge Sela Han, Sue Oh, and Katie Sin, who were identified as candidates for the 2023-24 student board member position.
I'd like to give them an opportunity to also introduce themselves and tell us where they attend school and the name of their school district.
Sela, would you go first, please?
Hi, everyone. My name is Sela Han. I attend Torrance High School, which is in Torrance Unified School District, and it was an honor to be here to meet all of you.
Thank you, Sela. Now I'd invite Sue to the podium.
Hello, my name is Sue. I attend Sunny Hills High School in Florida to join UA High School District, and I'm so honored to be here today.
And Katie, if you would come and introduce yourself, school and school district.
Good morning, everyone. My name is Katie Sin, and I attend Palm Desert High School at Desert Sands Unified, and thank you for having us here today.
Thank you, Katie, and congratulations to the finalists and also those who we had opportunity to interview yesterday.
Lastly, I will acknowledge six additional students who were selected by the screening committee as semifinalists.
These students are Alexis Aguilar from Granite Hills High School in the Grossmont Union High School District in San Diego County.
Anne Albumalala from El Camino Fundamental High School in the San Juan Unified School District in Sacramento County.
Kira Bird from Fred C. Byer High School in Modesto City Schools in Stanislaus County.
Nathra Damodaran from Daugherty Valley High School in the San Ramon Valley Unified School District in Contra Costa County.
Luvani Madari from Angelo Rodriguez High School in the Fairfield-Susan Unified School District in Solano County.
And Issei Nagada from Anaheim High School in the Anaheim Union High School District in Orange County.
So again, congratulations to all of those students.
And President Darling-Hammond, I will turn it back over to you.
Thank you so much. What a pleasure to meet all these amazing students.
I think at this point we are about to open for public comment.
And I think we need the public comment slide to be displayed.
And we will open the phone line as soon as that happens for public comment.
There we go. Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the slide that is shown now.
While we're waiting for members of the public to call in, I want other board members who participated in this year's student selection process, if they have any comments.
Members Lewis, Escobedo, McQuillin and Student Member Porter to make such comments.
Then if there are any clarifying questions, we can take them before we get to public comment.
Member McQuillin.
Yes, thank you. It was my honor to participate in the interviews this week with the students.
It was one of my favorite things. Really, really difficult decision to select three from the six candidates.
And just dynamite students that represent California so well, role models that represent their schools and their school districts.
It was a very difficult decision and a real pleasure to interview the students. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. Member Porter.
I want to say congratulations to all of the top 12, the top six, the top three and thank you to everyone who applied.
It is a hefty application process.
So thank you for saying yes to being that voice for students.
And I had a great time meeting all of you in person at SABE discussing ways that we can continue to further advocate for student needs.
And so thank you for spending your weekend, your Halloween weekend, working on the heart of these proposals to all the delegates.
And thank you to all the upperclassmen who you may not be directly affected by these policies, but you really want to create this improved schooling experience for your peers and lower grades.
So congratulations to the top three and to every student who applied.
Thank you so much. Member Lewis.
Good morning. I just wanted to add that it was a pleasure just sitting in on the interviews and meeting all of these young people.
I just want to say thank you to all of those who applied.
And it was just encouraging to meet them and just to hear their passion and their desire to make an impact on education for not only for themselves, but for their fellow students.
So congratulations to all who applied and to our finalists.
Thank you. Member Escobedo, did you want to add anything?
Yes, I applaud all those teachers that made an influence in the lives of these young, young scholars, because they truly were scholars.
Their passion, their thoughts, their really care for humanity was a prevalent topic in each one of them.
So I thank you for all the amazing educators to mold these young lives into just amazing young adults and future great citizens in our society.
Thank you. Thank you. And I want to add my thanks to all the board members who participated in this.
It's one of the more pleasurable commitments, but it is an intense commitment to participate and to help us in this process and add my thanks to all of the young people who applied and had the opportunity to share their ideas in this way.
We will now see if there's any public comment. Is there any public comment?
We do not have anyone in the queue for this item.
All right. And if there's any other further board discussion?
Seeing none.
Board members, I guess I need a motion now for putting forward these names. Member Glover Woods.
Thank you. I move that the State Board of Education approve the three finalists for the position of the 2023-2024 Student State Board of Education as identified in the item addendum and as was presented to you today.
Thank you. And do I have a second? Member Porter?
I second the motion.
Thank you. We'll now hold a roll call vote. Brooks, can you please call the roll?
President Darlene Hammond.
Yes.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Olken.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
She's motioning yes, but I think your volume.
We see you.
We have a problem getting off of mute.
For the record, we see it's an affirmative.
Yes, sorry, I couldn't unmute for some reason.
Member Petilla Broughton.
Yes.
Member Porter.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Yoshimoto-Tauri.
Motion passes unanimously.
We're now going to take up item three, the 2022 Student Advisory Board on Education Conference.
This item will be presented by the student representatives who participated in the 2022 Student Advisory Board of Education annual conference.
This item has an addendum, which is the 2022 Sabe Conference Report.
First, I'd like to ask Board Members McQuillan and Student Board Member Porter, as this year's liaisons, if they have comments to share.
So, Member McQuillan, would you like to queue us up?
I just know the students have worked so hard this year on preparing themselves and sacrificing their time, you know, around Halloween, as was said earlier.
That's a sacrifice, you know, of being at the conference and preparing themselves.
I'm really confident for the future of California and all of our students and our communities, because we're in good hands with the students that you'll hear from today.
So thank you for all your work and your sacrifices.
Thank you.
Terrific.
Member Porter.
So I just want to take this moment to thank the leadership at CASC, all the counselors, the researchers, the delegates for committing their time to improve our education system and giving up your time to do so.
Ultimately, the decisions that are made here in Sacramento and on this board affect students, and I'm just constantly amazed by the passion and the dedication of the delegates and staff.
They not only spent their weekend, but their Halloween weekend ahead of college application deadlines, that's November 1st, staying up until 3am, 4am in the morning last night to edit proposals, revise and research, and wake up early the next morning, ready to get feedback and ready to advise and to revise their proposals.
So thank you for your commitment, and it was a pleasure to meet and interact with all of you, and I am excited to hear your proposals again for this board today.
Terrific.
And we do have various presenters for this item, so each presenter will be introduced by Ava Gebhardt, who's the Education Policy Director of the California Association of Student Councils, with a brief introduction by Ellie Leann, this year's state president of CASC.
So Ellie, please begin.
Good morning Superintendent Thurmond, President Darlene Hammond, Vice President Glover Woods, and esteemed members of the board. My name is Ellie Leann, I am a senior at Portola High School in Orange County, and I also have the privilege of serving as the current state president of the California Association of Student Councils, otherwise known as CASC.
This year's Student Advisory Board on Education, SABE, has been especially rewarding, as directors and delegates alike have shown incredible resilience and flexibility navigating their first time in person since COVID-19.
Hearing the unique visions of students from all across California coalesce into a collective movement of change has reaffirmed the power of youth.
Of course, this experience could not have been possible without our 12 dedicated student board member candidates, the current student board member Naomi Porter, who oversaw the election process before race and supported the candidates to her fullest capability, and lastly our core conference team who worked tirelessly to make SABE possible.
This opportunity to create and share our proposals has been an unparalleled experience for our delegates, and we thank the California Department of Education for dedicating their time to honor our voice.
Your recognition of us not only as students, but also as emerging changemakers is what propels us forward, and for that we thank you.
Without further ado, I welcome the CASC Education Policy Director, Ava Gephart, for more on today's presentations.
Thank you for the introduction, Ellie. Good morning, President Darling-Hambon, Vice President Glover Woods, and esteemed board members. My name is Ava Gephart, and I'm a senior at Foothill High School in the Shasta Union High School District.
I'm the Education Policy Director of the California Association of Student Councils and the 2022 Director of the Student Advisory Board on Education.
Since 1963, the Student Advisory Board on Education has given students throughout the state of California a voice to propose changes in education policy to the State Board of Education.
59 years later, students continue to need to brainstorm, discuss, and make these proposals in the span of our four-day conference.
This year is monumental for us. For the first time in three years, behind me sits 40 delegates from throughout the state who have traveled to Sacramento to make a difference within their education system.
The proposals the students provide before you are completely of the students' own creations, made up of the experiences and knowledge of students who experience the California education system day by day.
With this staff act as neutral parties within the process of leading the groups to get the student voice as a whole.
Today, I come forward to you with a delegation of students ready to enact a positive change.
Our delegation has created comprehensive proposals on the issues of teacher qualification and training, political literacy, mental health, school safety, and socioeconomic equity.
I'm confident that our proposals being presented are of the utmost concerns identified by the delegation of our students.
I would like to thank all of you for this opportunity and for our students to present their proposals to you all.
And without further ado, I will go ahead and introduce Ida Ahola, who will be doing the teacher qualification and training speech.
A video recently went viral of a Riverside teacher donning a fake headdress and chanting during a lesson.
While teaching the math lesson of Sakatoa, she stomped around the classroom, made chopping motions, and pretended to pray in an effort to mimic racialized Native American stereotypes.
Riverside Unified School District only acted to fire the teacher after the video went viral and the district experienced pressure from Native American advocates.
Students should not have to rely on internet virality and community resources in order to hold their own teachers accountable for misconduct.
Good morning Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Glover-Woods, and esteemed board members.
My name is Ida Ahola and I'm a senior from Northwood High School in the Irvine Unified School District.
On behalf of the Student Advisory Board of Education, we urge the State Board of Education recommend local education agencies adopt the existing CDE uniform complaint procedure as a universal UCP form instead of using individually LEA-created forms.
This universal form would be clearly present online on district and school platforms as well as being printed on paper to ensure faculty is held accountable within the state of California.
As a consequence of the innate power imbalance within schools between teachers and students, students often feel as if they have no power in holding their own teachers accountable for misconduct.
Whether it be for fear of retaliation or ignorance of resources like the UCP, many students who feel belittled by their administration do not know that they have the option to report their teachers, let alone navigate this procedure.
Our hope is to create an accessible process for students to share their concerns regarding their educators.
My peers and I propose that the board adopt the existing state uniform complaint procedure as a universal outline for students and parents to report administrators' misconduct with ease.
Additionally, the universal UCP form would be multilingual and published in all school and district websites, at district offices as printed copies, and in person at school sites.
The UCP is a system undertaken by individual districts to ensure compliance with applicable state and federal laws and regulations.
The UCP addresses issues of discrimination, bullying, and harassment.
Currently, all school districts in California are required to have a compliance officer or body to address complaints from the UCP.
The UCP has jurisdiction over all programs and activities implemented by the state as well as personnel.
Students can file the UCP themselves or have parents file on their behalf with the goal of eventually conducting an investigation into the staff report.
We appreciate all efforts in legislation that has led to the creation of the UCP, but in its current form, it remains inaccessible.
Many districts do not provide an outline or display the form on many of their platforms.
Students find that they must excavate through links to find their district's UCP form.
Clearly publishing the form on district websites and in person decreases the barriers of filing.
With the pre-established system of the UCP, the implementation of our solution would have very low monetary cost.
By translating the UCP form, students and teachers or students and parents would feel highly encouraged to express their experiences because of the form's linguistic versatility.
Additionally, the UCP creates a recorded documentation of repeated violations by faculty members.
This allows for future jobs to access a faculty member's possible history of misconduct.
It would allow for full transparency and credibility of a faculty member when hiring new staff.
This decreases the risk of repeated instance of inappropriate misconduct from teachers at different districts, securing a safer learning environment.
We hope that the board will adopt the existing state UCP form as the universal outline for students and parents to report administrators' misconduct.
The increased availability of the form in multiple languages, both online and on district websites in person, at district schools and offices, will empower students to hold their teachers accountable for misconduct.
Increased access to the UCP form will enforce a safe learning environment for all students.
Though teachers are the ones who hold the power in the classrooms, it is students who have the most at stake in those environments.
Thus, it should be student voices that we are uplifting, as it is students that we all serve. Thank you for your time.
Thank you so much. We're going to take two or three board member questions after each of these presentations.
So we're open for questions if there are some or comments.
Member McQuillin.
Yeah, I just want to say thank you for the great presentation. Very good job.
One question or comment is the consideration of restorative practices also in the effort would be really fantastic.
As human beings, we do put our feet in it sometimes, and we make errors, and we have faults.
And every culture has that restorative effort and an avenue where people can make right and get back onto a good pathway by the act of forgiving and making the situation right.
So that's just a consideration in the whole thing. Thank you for your presentation.
Thank you. Member Rodriguez.
I meant to unmute and instead I applauded. Thank you, President Darlene Hammond, and thank you so much for that wonderful presentation.
And I agree. I agree that learning environments should be safe. They should be safe places for students.
They should feel comfortable, not feel like they're being bullied or harassed in any way.
And I also agree with Member McQuillin, right, you know, that there is, as a teacher, you know, I want all of my students to feel safe and I want them to feel that they're walking into a trusting environment.
However, as a human being, I also know that I may do something that could be misinterpreted.
And so I would hate for a student who, you know, just got a bad grade on a test or on an assignment to interpret that as bullying.
So while it's important to have a place where students can get that information and, you know, make sure to ensure that they have, that we're creating the safest environments, we also need to make sure that we have prongs in place to support us as human beings and as teachers, right?
You know, and that the due process is also there so that it doesn't become, you know, like the teacher that's very strict or this that students have a problem with that maybe it becomes personal.
So and I absolutely applaud all of your work. I always look forward to your presentations and your presentation was fabulous. Thank you so much.
So I'm going to ask if you'd like to respond either to the ideas about due process or restorative practice and maybe add one more thing to your thinking and response, which is do you have recommendations about teacher training on the front end that you think would be helpful in creating these safe spaces?
So we're turning it back to you for your thoughts.
Yes, absolutely. All of the questions you have asked and comments are something that we've tried to keep in mind through our proposal. In its current form, the UCP does ensure confidentiality, but it is not anonymous.
So students who file do have to state their name and describe the instance that occurred. So we hope that with this link to the individual student and with it not being an automatic termination per se, instead an investigation into the incident, we hope to also hold students accountable because we do understand that this form could be misused very easily.
So we hope that through the inclusion of a name, but ensure confidentiality that students are deterred from misusing this form purposefully. So I think that answers that hopefully. And so that's the current system that is already in place for the UCP.
Thank you. Thank you for your response. Did you have anything else you wanted to add?
No need. I just want to be sure I didn't interrupt you before you were done.
The issue about training. I understand that our topic is a bit misleading, but as a group while we were discussing this proposal, we kind of came across the two forks in the road of, do we want to address teacher training or teacher accountability?
And these were the two kind of areas that we had to battle with. And originally we have leaned towards the training path, which is why our topic suggests that we were focused on training. However, we found that addressing the training curriculum for teachers was a bit more complex than we had the resources to address at the moment.
And so we found the UCP is a form already in place. This is a system that has precedent. There's procedure to it already. It is a procedure.
And so our goal is to not essentially change that, but just to make it more accessible for students. And we found that through this proposal, we were able to make though more niche changes, we hope more feasible changes with our proposal.
Thank you. Thank you. We appreciate so much both the proposal and the presentation. And we'll move on to the next presenter.
Thank you so much. Our next presenter will be from the political literacy group. So when singer will be our presenter.
The 2020 Annenberg civics knowledge survey found that only one half of Americans can name all three branches of government and less than half understood the fundamental democratic principle of self governance.
Our current curriculum is simply too little too late as students who are reaching voting age are inadequately informed on how to vote or navigate political language with our democratic process.
Good morning, Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling, Darling, Charlie Hammond, Vice President Glover Woods and honorable board members. My name is Gwen singer and I'm a senior at Venice High School in Venice, California, part of the Los Angeles Unified School District.
My peers and I proposed the modification of existing state standards on civic curriculum in order to promote political literacy.
Political literacy is defined as the knowledge, understanding and navigation of democratic structures and their impacts across local, state, national and even global levels.
It is the season and ability to both interpret and apply concepts pertaining to governmental issues.
While political literacy encompasses civic engagement, it also clips students with the knowledge and tools to make educated decisions and function as well informed civic participants.
In light of the public over-reliance on media that provides what is often highly partisan political news, schools should carry the responsibility of objectively informing students about political structures and processes of government.
The first time I encountered any formal civic curriculum was this year when I started my senior year AP government class.
The California Education Code currently requires three years in social studies in order to graduate high school, including a singular semester of government.
But from within our proposal group, almost half of our students have observed that government and civics education is restricted solely to seniors in their schools.
This means that for many students, their first exposure to political curriculum is when they're about to graduate.
Every single student within California schools is a constituent of American democracy.
We are the next generation of stakeholders, voters and decision makers.
We need a robust civic education.
Only through consistent reinforcement of the principles of the democratic process, governance and policies that affect our everyday lives, will students be empowered to be active, educated participants in the political process.
Only then can they make their voices heard and apply their knowledge to real world situations.
Currently, the state seal of civic engagement exists as an incredible incentive to students that prioritize their civic education and engages active democratic participants.
Using this as a stepping stone, we urge the State Board to place a greater focus on the civic frameworks than history and social science standards so that all students across K-12 education are more politically literate and motivated to engage with and understand the politics and policies that affect them.
The Student Advisory Board on Education urges the State Board of Education to revisit and expand the existing history and social science standards through the incorporation of a milestone system of successively implemented standards throughout the K-12 progression.
This milestone framework can be presided over by appropriate California Department of Education staff who will readdress the existing educational standards and systemically incorporate greater emphasis on a political curriculum framework.
This would entail that at certain grade levels, students will be familiar with age-appropriate concepts.
We advocate for simulations of election processes and judicial review to be integrated in primary schools where students can experientially model what these processes look like.
We also recommend an expansion to include formal political instruction regarding voting, elections, and key aspects of government in middle schools.
We also encourage an interdisciplinary approach in high schools to ensure that students understand the practical applications and the language usage of the political process and policies that exist in the world around them.
The appropriate CDE staff to preside over the modification of these curricular standards will expand the existing frameworks within primary and secondary schools, particularly emphasizing political concepts may be fully objective at any point.
They may reconvene every five years to revise and update standards in accordance with the most relevant democratic principles that students should be well versed in, as well as ensure the frameworks maintain a neutral, nonpartisan position.
The last time these standards were updated was in October 1998.
Students are subject to antiquated standards that are older than they are, so the solution is a more modern education based on modern standards.
We implore you to implement these updated standards as soon as possible as now, more than ever, students are in need of a nonpartisan, credible source of information in schools.
This affects the future of state and national civic engagement and innovation.
When students are well educated and politically literate, democracy as a whole becomes accessible.
The content already exists.
We just need to reconsider the standards.
Subsequently, students can familiarize themselves with the world of politics through a long-term political education free from the polarization, contention, and bias that emerges in other sources.
By updating these standards in accordance with our proposed milestone model, the earlier, more expansive, and consistent implementation of nonpartisan political education standards makes certain that students have a firm understanding of all levels of government.
They will be motivated and prepared to take on the world of politics and policy, both prior to and once they reach voting age.
It will ensure that students are ready to fulfill what it truly means to be a citizen.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you so much.
And so timely with the elections just a few days away.
Let's see if there are comments or questions from any of the board members.
Member Porter.
Thank you so much, Gwen, for your presentation.
Something that I really admire about your proposal is that it isn't just a one-time lesson for our students with this idea of a milestone framework, very similar to the seal of civic engagement.
Learning at a young age, really the basics of our government and fostering good voting habits and reiterating the importance of being a contributing citizen will really only lead to a more productive and informed society.
So as a first-time voter myself voting in this next election, I had to acquire skills about the deliberation of issues and candidates really outside of the classroom through my own research.
And so I guess my main comment is also to highlight the importance of an unbiased approach when teaching this political literacy.
I think that's something that can oftentimes be tricky to do, but I want to highlight the importance of that in the classroom.
So I want to thank you again, Gwen, for your proposal, your presentation, your comprehensive research, and your clear passion that will benefit so many students.
So thank you.
Awesome.
Vice President Glover Woods.
Thank you.
And thank you so much for a wonderful presentation on political literacy.
And again, as President Darley Hammond said, quite timely considering what will be taking place in the next few days.
I would definitely like to applaud the emphasis on objectively presenting the information in a nonpartisan way and also acknowledging that knowing, getting information throughout the educational journey, if you will, from elementary school, middle school and high school is a very positive way to look at how to engage civically and what that does indeed mean.
I have a question, and I am perfectly comfortable if this is not something that the team has talked about, so please feel comfortable to say we didn't even talk about that.
You mentioned in your presentation simulations, and I was just kind of wondering, what might those simulations look like at the elementary level?
What might they look like at the junior high and middle school level? And how might they look different at the high school level?
Yeah, so I would actually love to talk about that. That is a really big thing that we focused on.
So a lot of our group members talked about how when they were in elementary school, they would model different processes.
For example, it talked about modeling the American Revolution. They talked about there were a couple examples that I can't recall off the top of my head.
But for example, the process of electing a line leader in elementary school education, learning how people can vote for that, learning how people can potentially campaign for that, even placing greater emphasis on the maybe fourth, fifth grade class president elections and talking more about what that process looks like in the real world.
Because in elementary school, of course, these processes are much more simplified, but introducing them to the formal terminology or the formal descriptions of what this will look like once they reach a voting age.
And then in middle school, kind of just expanding this a little bit more, maybe making them a little more complicated.
I know in my middle school, we had class president and class boards more than just a president and vice president.
We had the introduction of new positions. We had treasurer. We had secretary.
So that expansion into, like I said, the more terminology, the more in-depth of the process.
And then in high school, I'd actually love to share an anecdote. In my AP government class about two weeks ago, we did a week long campaign model, election model, voting model.
We talked about all of the political candidates and propositions that have been presented.
Regardless of our own personal bias or personal beliefs, we were randomly assigned a proposition and a candidate to campaign for, whether it was the mayor, the governor, the senators.
And it was a really wonderful chance for all of us to learn what it was like to run a campaign.
And that kind of hands on learning and hands on research, just having the students directly experience it themselves was so incredible for my understanding.
I didn't know how this worked behind the scene. I didn't know what kind of research went into it.
And that experience really allowed me to do that. And my AP government teacher was amazing for that.
And that's why I would love to see or think our whole group would love to see more simulations like that implemented or encouraged within the state standards.
It sounds like you've had some very exciting teaching.
Member Patil Bronson.
Good morning. I just want to thank you for the presentation and clearly I love that you're bringing such lived experience and positive ways of lifting up both your AP government class and also thinking about how to interweave this type of experiential
learning at sort of the elementary and middle school levels.
The question I had, I appreciate and I think that several board members have given voice to the need for this to be a nonpartisan activity, which I absolutely agree with.
I have maybe two questions. One is around how you would approach ensuring and promoting the idea that there would not just be sort of a tolerance of differing political viewpoints, but actually a respect and a healthy sort of discourse that could grow.
And then the second is about how you think about the critical thinking skills that are required in order to filter political information.
There's so much right now on the internet that is about really hot temper more than anything and not so fact based and how would you think about actually building that into a curriculum of how to evaluate different claims that are being made around the political system.
I think that this is where the interdisciplinary approach really comes in. For example, in English classes, making sure students can identify and navigate the language usage and from understanding language usage, you can kind of determine implicit bias.
So making sure that that's an emphasis from schools within, you know, science classes talking about the policies and legislation that went into different discoveries.
A big point of our proposal is it's not necessarily talking about modern candidates or modern political issues from the perspective of both sides of the spectrum.
It's making sure that students understand the processes behind things, understand what it means to be a voter, participate in elections, how these biases may be emerged rather than what they are today, talking about what led to bias, how can we look at sources and identify an implicit bias.
And this is where the CDE staff would preside over. They have the knowledge and the expertise to know what is appropriate and what is not appropriate to include in state standards.
But the focus would really be, it's not an op-ed. It's not a chance for teachers to push their biases on students. It's time for defining these definitions, define these processes for students and clearly explain.
Within our political system, we thrive off of discourse, we thrive off of diversity, making that a huge point that every single end of the spectrum has something invaluable to contribute and it's about finding the objective nature behind it.
Once again, that interdisciplinary approach really helps finding the science behind politics, finding the history behind politics, focusing on set patterns and set precedents and how that's affected the modern political sphere will allow students to develop those critical thinking skills as well.
We focus on patterns. We focus on change over time. And that's one amazing thing about the AP curriculum, even something that we can look to the AP curriculum for, is they focus so much on these historical patterns and historical developments.
And I think that's a really good, a really great way to pull information that exists, once again, standards that exist and just modify that these need to be implemented into state standards that kind of focus on pattern and development and change over time and definitions of how things really work fundamentally.
That's how that needs to be incorporated.
I hope that somewhat answers your question.
It does, and I just want to thank you again for such an outstanding presentation.
Thank you. We all, we all appreciated it.
Let's move to the next presentation.
Thank you so much. Our next presenter will be from the mental health group, and I now introduce Helios Lung.
There are a lot of similarities that my group and I see between California students and California's policymakers. For example, we all care about California's education system, and we all care about bettering that system.
But it seems the biggest similarity is in the way we deal with mental health. Even though mental health has been a priority of recent state legislation, such as SB 224, this legislation hasn't addressed an important resource to students.
Other students. Good morning, Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Glover-Woods, and esteemed board members.
My name is Helios Lung, and I am a sophomore at Montevista High School in Danville.
I'm speaking to you on behalf of the Student Advisory Board on Education, a subsidiary of the California Association of Student Councils.
For the past three days, my group and I have focused on how we can target the issue of student mental wellness.
We're here because we believe that, principally, mental health serves as a root problem for so many issues.
Sure, students are free to speak to their school counselors, but on a fundamental level, mental health resources and the status quo aren't being properly utilized because the distrust and distance between staff and students discourages students from seeking help.
It only gets harder when mental health stigmatization, established by societal standards and exacerbated by campus culture, makes it dangerously difficult for students to use current resources.
Here's how we've seen this problem addressed. My school holds a yearly event with an organization called Breaking Down the Walls.
Hundreds of students gather in the gym assembly style and walk to the center if they resonate with certain statements, such as walk forward if you've had an eating disorder or walk forward if you've been a victim of domestic violence.
And to my surprise, students actually opened up. The most important impact this has had in my school is that for the first time, so many students began to empathize with their peers and look past the surface.
For the first time, so many students that were struggling saw that they weren't alone. I saw that when students are reminded that they have support from others, it makes them more likely to seek the help they need.
But as much as we would like for every student to share that experience, not every school can afford working with an outside organization for several sessions and several hours.
This problem changes under today's proposal. Our solution suggests statewide access to peer counseling resources.
But first, what is peer counseling? Peer counseling is when students become informed confidants who function as someone that their peers can speak to.
Confidence will be trained under the curriculum that school districts provide through the guidelines of this proposal, increasing reliability and relatability for students who need it.
This also allows for the student helper to have the knowledge to care for their own mental well-being. This proposal allows schools to develop and establish these systems.
Peer counseling is so important because of its efficacy. A study from the Queensland government and James Cook University found that implementation of peer support groups in school environments increased average student satisfaction in guidance, reassurance of worth, and reliable alliance.
That means that for students talking to other students serves as the foundation for improving both accessibility, reliability, and community.
Our proposal suggests that governing boards of districts provide resources to schools that they're able to train students as student confidants, a set of guidelines that can be used to not only coach students on how to support their peers, but also to become committed to accountability, confidentiality, and empathy.
Our proposal allows every student to make a difference in their community. At a local level, advisors, whether those are teachers or adult counselors, will manage both peer counseling as well as the teaching of training curriculum.
This proposal is critical because first, it provides districts and local governing boards with the clear guidelines to develop their own curriculum or use curriculum from organizations that already exist and are already successful, such as Mental Health First Aid.
This allows them to best adapt resources to their needs and their exact situation. But second, it makes sure that established schools get the resources they need to create reliable peer counseling systems.
Because let's face it, when any sort of counseling is done incorrectly, the effects can be devastating. That's what this proposal changes.
But just one more statistic. The University of Virginia finds that 75% of students first reached out to another peer when they were in distress. 11% of students reached out to staff.
But it only takes the 11 members of this board to change that. Thank you for your time.
Thank you so much. Let's see who would like to ask a question or two. Member Porter.
Thank you so much for your presentation. So one thing that I love about this proposal is that it's based off the idea that it's hard to hate someone when you know their story.
And I think that students are truly an untapped resource to address this. And so I think that peer counseling does allow for a stronger sense of community within schools and really grows that empathy in that school culture.
And so two things I want to draw upon the importance of is confidentiality within the mentors, as well as the logistics of training these peers.
So my question to you to answer after member Oakland and member Escobedo give their comments is just how these peers are going to be trained and who will be doing that training.
So thank you again, Helios, for your hard work and for your initiative in addressing this very key issue.
Terrific. I will collect all the questions and then you can answer them all at once. Member Olken.
You're on mute. Thank you. I found it. So first I want to thank you so much and all the students for these incredible presentations.
Really thoughtful ideas about how we can make schools more responsive to students and uplift their voices.
And I really appreciate the focus on student mental well-being. As a school leader at this moment, I just see every day the really difficult cost, the difficult toll that kids are living with coming out of the pandemic and adults as well, honestly.
And one of the things we've seen at my school is the really important and powerful impact of affinity groups, so the ways in which when we connect with those like ourselves, some of the stigma and fear and power structures are decreased.
And so I really appreciate the idea of the power of students helping students. It's just it feels like it's such a meaningful approach.
And my question is similar to what we just heard, which is you made the point that this proposal will address the devastating cost of when counseling isn't effective.
And I was hoping you could double back and just explain that a little bit about how this will help ensure that counseling is effective, because I agree that's a really devastating potential. So thank you.
Terrific. Member Escobedo will add you.
Thank you. Sorry. Just really curious about some of the research you've seen on peer counseling. I know it definitely has some positive effects, such as creating that connectiveness with the student body, students not being as apprehensive.
However, have you studied the negative effects of peer counseling, especially for the person that's doing the counseling, if not well prepared, if you don't have even an avenue to help you process what you heard?
You know, sometimes these type of sessions or these constructs can have negative consequences as well. So just wondered if you also looked at some of the drawbacks of peer counseling, especially in the adolescent years. Thank you.
That's a lot of questions to deal with. We do have one more.
Member Roscoe Gonzalez, go ahead and add your comment, and then we'll ask for a response.
Thank you. I just have a comment. Actually, I want to let you know that I was a peer counselor over 30 years ago in my high school, and it was just so important for me and for my school.
And when I was a sophomore, and I got some of the training that you mentioned, which we called mental health first aid, and I thought that that was really important that you said that because it's so important to have reliable counselors and advisors to guide students.
I remember as a young teenager going through extensive training to really not only understand, but to be empathetic and to find ways to ask for help when I couldn't.
And when I didn't have the answers, because as a teenager, I didn't have a lot of answers, but what I did have was a good year to listen and to want to help and to want to participate in the success of the mental health of a student who was maybe struggling.
And I remember many times having think tanks and just sessions with group sessions just to break down walls. And I know you mentioned something about breaking down the walls and I remember doing that exercise in the gym and just finding that that was a calling for me and my calling ended up being an education and guiding students.
And I remember that training being so important when I was a first year teacher and when I was even a middle school teacher, because I felt that I could some of the issues that students had resonated with me.
So I want to just commend this work. And so it's not a question. I want to let you know that this work is important. And it's a way to just engage all the entire community, including students and how to support each other and guide each other through this process of difficulties that we have,
especially coming out of a pandemic. So thank you. Thank you. That's a wonderful unintended positive consequence of the work. So you have a set of questions. We'll let you respond.
Okay, thank you so much for the comments and everything. Those were really insightful and we'll definitely take those into consideration. So I'll just move on to answering some of the questions given to me.
So first, I'll address member Porter's question about who's going to oversee all of this. So addressing my speech and also my proposal, the advisors will primarily be adult counselors or teachers.
But the reason we still think that works is because under peer counseling, students can speak to a larger number of students because fundamentally it increases access and reliability.
So student counselors now have access to more information on the general consensus or general issues that the student body suffers from. And then moving on to member Olken's question. Sorry, if you don't mind restating that, I might have forgotten it.
Absolutely. You said in your speech that there were two things you were hoping to address. And the second one was the sort of the reliability of good counseling.
And I was wondering if you could explain that piece just a little bit more.
Okay, sure. So a lot of the students in our group talked about how at their school there's like a general distrust for counselors. And that makes sense, right? There's always rumors about counselors telling your parents and everything.
So we thought that increasing access to peer counseling is something good. But we saw the obvious concern that like you can't always ensure the quality of peer counseling, which is what we're trying to target with this proposal.
So we can establish reliable curriculum for every district to properly implement this because that implementation we believe is worse than no implementation at all.
And then moving on to I believe member Escobedo's question is how will these students, these peer counselors themselves address their own mental well-being?
So for our research, we actually found that teaching students how to deal with or how to counsel other students taught them to help like deal with their own mental well-being in a healthy manner.
And a lot of students saw benefits to both those being counseled and the counselors themselves.
And then I think that is all the questions.
Nice job. Thank you so much. Very thoughtful and very, very constructive. Appreciate it.
We're going to move on to the next presentation.
Thank you so much. Our next presentation will be from the School Safety Group and Ashley Castillo will be your presenter.
September 13th, 2022 at 9.43 a.m. in Los Angeles, California. I was working in class until my principal Mr. Devlatian frantically came on the PA system.
Hollywood High, we are on an immediate lockdown. This is not a drill. Get into your nearest classroom and lock all doors.
I repeat, this is not a drill. What did my classroom do? Nothing.
At 9.54 a.m., another announcement was made. But despite that, classes anxiously resumed.
Parents clogged phone lines and surrounded the school interfering with the LAPD.
So what led to all of this in the first place? Our school had become a victim of swatting.
Police officers arrived, weapons drawn, before the school was notified of a necessary lockdown because the LAPD didn't know which extension number would connect them with the right school office.
Students didn't know the proper procedures with law enforcement on campus, taking away time from the officers locating the potential threat.
And finally, the school had the wrong evacuation map on file with the LAPD, causing the LAPD to incorrectly evacuate students to an open football field.
This caused trauma, panic, and put students' lives at risk in the span of two hours.
If it had been a genuine threat to student safety, the consequences could have been devastating.
How was the school supposed to respond to a situation like this when they're not properly informed how to?
Good morning, Superintendent Thurman, President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Glover-Woods, and esteemed members of the board.
My name is Ashley Ana Castillo. I'm a high school senior representing Hollywood High and the LA Unified School District.
I've lived in California my entire life and have been a victim of misinformation about our school safety system since I was young.
I'm here on behalf of the Student Advisory Board on Education, urging you to ensure increased awareness and responses to emergency situations.
While external factors can be uncontrollable, this doesn't mean we can't prepare internally.
Our solution strives to combat misinformation and lack of communication regarding school safety protocols by adding a set of school safety guidelines to the
Existing Comprehensive School Safety Plan as a supplement to the existing recommendations provided under the CDE.
These guidelines would promote information flow by distributing accessible and comprehensive school safety procedures.
While ensuring a certain level of statewide standardization, it would also provide ample space for local controls.
Districts can emphasize protocols regarding specific incidences that are most prevalent to them, whether that be wildfires or drug addiction.
Materials would be translated into other languages determined by the district's population demographics.
Lastly, these guidelines would strongly recommend school safety plans being made available to the entire school community through various outlets,
such as evacuation maps posted in every classroom, uploading certain safety information to district and school websites, and sending copies of the safety plan home with students every year.
Our guidelines also encourage presenting information with digestible language or even pictures for younger ages, making them accessible to a wider audience.
The earlier students and staff are taught about these procedures, the more prepared they will be if an event occurs.
Yes, we already have safety procedures currently in place, but most students are unaware of what they entail.
Working together, we can ensure that students, staff, and families are aware of such safety measures, starting with tackling the fundamental issue, a lack of information.
Our school safety guidelines consider the unique circumstances of certain communities without compromising the standard of information shared.
Since they will be placed under an existing resource created by the California Department, our proposal would incur a minimal cost at the state level.
Additionally, AB 1747 already mandates the distribution of school safety information to local agencies requiring its use.
Our guidelines would simply place a stronger emphasis on interagency collaboration, bridging the communication gap between local agencies and the school that has occurred regardless.
So let's revisit that September 13th, now with our school safety guidelines.
Students, teachers, and law enforcement knew when and how to take action.
With our guidelines, everyone clearly understood next steps.
The officers smoothly swept the school, found no threat, and the lockdown was lifted.
That is what should have happened on September 13th.
That's what should happen in every situation.
Short and seamless.
And that is a reality that becomes plausible using our recommended guidelines.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for that wonderful presentation.
Let's see if we have some board member comments or questions.
Member McQuillin.
Yes, I just want to say thank you for this presentation and bringing up such an important topic that unfortunately is on our minds quite a bit these days with media coverage.
Just a great presentation.
You know, I think training is really important.
Training for all the players in the situation, for schools is so important on this topic.
And also, you know, the struggle right now, I know when we think of community schools and opening up our schools for more service providers on campus and more families coming onto campus and trying to find that delicate balance between opening up campuses and keeping campuses safe, I know is a struggle for our schools right now.
But again, thank you for this topic.
Thank you so much.
Member Lewis.
Thank you, Ashley.
Wonderful presentation.
And I want to emphasize, like board member McQuillin said, this is such an important topic with everything that has been happening, not only what happened at your local school, but in school districts across the state and also across the nation.
I think all of the points that you brought up are very important points, and I was sitting here reflecting on things of this nature in the district that I was just associated with before retirement.
And one of the most important things that you can do is make sure that information is disseminated to the individuals that really need it the most, just like you emphasized.
The training is so important.
First of all, when an incident like this occurs, when students are in the classroom, that teacher is the most important person in the room that can direct the students on how they need to react to the particular emergency that's at hand.
So the training is very important.
But not only did we learn about not stopping with the training with the adults, but students also need to be informed of what the procedures are.
So the training is very important that you talked about.
Also, the interagency collaboration.
I don't know if most school districts across the state were fortunate that we were to have our own police department where we did have meetings throughout the year with the agencies that surround school safety.
We partnered with the fire department with local law enforcement agencies to take our officers and others through drills at certain points during the year and also made the information about emergencies available in preschool meetings with staff and also in class meetings at the beginning of the year.
One of my questions, so I just think you brought up a lot of important parts in your presentation.
And one of my questions is, have you thought about what that training for staff and students should look like statewide and what it should entail?
I mentioned a lot of important things, so I know that was included in your conversations, but just kind of the scenario that you brought up after all that training, the safety guidelines and everything was in place sounded perfect.
So how do you how do you envision that we make that standardized across the state?
Great.
Thank you, Member Lewis. We'll hold that question and wrap it up with the others. If there are more questions, Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Thank you, Ashley Castillo from such a wonderful presentation and I think urgent presentation to really have a conversation around clear communication.
I hear clearly how this was a very traumatic event on the day that you mentioned in panic and I know that as a teacher in the classroom, we've gone through several drills where we tried to disseminate information and be very clear and concise about the guidelines.
I see that there was a lot of lack of communication and integrating interagency collaboration, and I mentioned how it's so important to have training, multiple forms of communication, and I hear you about the translation of materials, working in a large area of students who speak multiple languages.
It's important to have communities get information that is in their native language, also sending information home on paper.
I think it's important to have teachers include this information in their LMS systems to also use those communication apps to also send information like you said, not only on paper, but also electronically.
And I think how can student voice be included in some of these communications, and I would call them safety drills. How do you think students can become more involved and maybe help local agencies in putting together a more concise drill so that we're prepared?
Because unfortunately, that's the situation we find ourselves, whether it's a lockdown, an earthquake drill, or a more serious situation, how can students help out through this process? So that's my question to you.
All right. Thank you very much. Member Patil Bronson. And then we're going to try to move to allowing our speaker to answer the questions.
I also just wanted to thank you for such a powerful and personal reflection of the school incident that you described. I certainly also think it highlights how important it is to have students as co-designers in the process of creating safe spaces and safe schools.
One of the questions I think, or I'll limit it to one question that came up as you were describing both the incident as well as the set of recommendations, it does seem that the frequency with which schools are responding to swatting type of events is increasing.
And so I think the recommendations that you put forward around interagency, information sharing, clarity of processes and procedures all make sense. And I also just wanted to ask if, particularly from the student perspective, if you all reached this area of how you get to prevention in terms of this increased incidence of swatting?
Wow. Those are some meaty questions and we'll turn back to our presenter for some of the thoughts and answers.
Thank you so much for all the wonderful questions and comments. We really appreciate it. So starting with the first question on the distribution of this information and how that would be done.
So originally when discussing this in a group, we had originally thought of school-wide assemblies where this information would be distributed to all students at the same time and staff so that everybody received clear instructions and the same instructions and information.
And also in these guidelines implementing sort of kind of like a structure curriculum that teachers can use with certain dialogue in terms that can clearly communicate this information to the students.
So that way the students are all receiving the same information and that everyone is on the exact same page in terms of what to do when something like this happens.
And then to address the second question about student voice. So of course the school site councils implement student voice already, at least in my high school at Hollywood High.
I know that we implement student voice through the school site council and the school site council plays a role in creating the comprehensive school safety plan.
So I think these guidelines would also again place the emphasis on working with these agencies, these local agencies, and having more of these meetings, like I mentioned before, more of these meetings with these local agencies to better construct these lockdowns, to better construct these evacuation routes, to better communicate how the process is going to go.
Because unfortunately, even though we have bills already to address this and create this communication, there is still a gap of that communication.
There is still a lack of communication between the agencies and the school site councils in creating the comprehensive school safety plan.
So I think having this would just place more of that emphasis and create a more cohesive structure that also again implements the student voice.
And then I'm sorry, could you repeat that last question for me, please?
I think the last one came from member, no, from member Petia Brownson.
Just any recommendations as to how to decrease the likelihood or incidence really of these sort of false flags and swatting reports?
So, you know, what was found was that a lot of these swatting reports were actually found to be outside of halls.
For the investigation that regarded Hollywood High, it was deemed that this was an outside hall and it was actually made to a classroom that didn't even exist, classroom 106.
But our school doesn't have a classroom 106.
So this was deemed to be an outside hall.
And what we wanted to do with this proposal was, unfortunately, we can't prevent those external forces and those outside forces from interfering with our school safety.
But what we can do is prepare and to have better preparation, just having these guidelines in place to place the emphasis on the things that would make a more structured plan for the entirety of the school to know how to deal with these incidences.
So that way it is done in a swift and concise manner as mentioned at the end.
Excellent. Thank you so much for all of the thoughtful responses as well as the presentation.
And we're going to move to our last presentation.
Thank you so much. Next, we have Nathra Dehmaduran who will be presenting the socioeconomic equity group.
Thank you so much.
Stuck with the label of underachieving, immigrant and refugee students of lower socioeconomic status were pushed out of their school Davis High and Modesta City schools by school administrators in 2015.
It was only after public pressure, newspaper articles and federal civil rights complaints that these students were given A's just so that they could graduate.
This is just one example of painfully affected California students. One example of a lack of representation and administration for a group that truly needed it.
Good morning President Darlin Hamlin, Vice President Glover Woods and esteemed members of the board.
My name is Nathra Dehmaduran and I am a junior attending Dorothy Valley High School in the San Antonio Valley Unified School District.
I'm here to speak about the lack of diverse socioeconomic representation in school districts, specifically in the local control and accountability also known as the LCAP.
In California, 20% of all network is concentrated in the home of 2% of Californians, otherwise known as just 30 areas of codes.
This apparent socioeconomic disparity is reflected in our state education system as well. Those who are socioeconomically disadvantaged tend to statistically achieve lower test results, have access to fewer resources and overall have fewer opportunities to be represented and heard.
Therefore, equitable representation by the public must improve in local school districts.
Specifically among underserved students, our team identified a lack of community involvement throughout the LCAP process, leading to a lack of representation in educational planning.
Therefore, we suggest that under the engaging educational partners section of the current LCAP template, a new subsection is added that addresses collaboration between the community and the LCAP advisory board.
This will make strides towards increasing diversity and educational planning power for low-income students.
Depending on the district's technology access, committee meeting summaries will be mailed or emailed to community members, translation services can be provided during meetings, and community leaders can emphasize active community outreach events and programs to overall increase diversity.
The local LCAP committees will allocate funds for the addition of translation services based on the district's demographics.
Though the LCAP advocates for diverse students and households, more can still be done. The LCAP process at districts was identified as not friendly to the community by district and county leaders interviewed by the California School Boards Association.
Getting essential community input was noted as a significant difficulty as well.
This includes feedback from parents, students, and overall adult figures that don't have official roles in the committee.
Additionally, a lack of participation from parents and guardians of financially disadvantaged students may stem from a lack of knowledge about the committee meetings and proposals.
Issues such as these are important in the context of overall educational socioeconomic inequity existing in our state.
In 2014, for example, the high school dropout rate among people 16 to 24 years old was highest in low-income families compared to high-income hearts.
More parental involvement and increased funding of resources have been shown to improve lower socioeconomic status in schools.
This can only occur with increased access to knowledge among these communities.
We envision an environment where underserved students aren't at a higher risk of dropping out of school.
We envision an environment where people of all backgrounds, races, classes, and incomes can voice their ideas in cleaning the education system that they are a part of.
We envision an environment where the exacerbating cycle of inequality finally has a chance to come to a halt.
This potential adjustment of the LCAP template could revolutionize educational equity by reforming LCAP guidelines to allow for increased diverse community participation.
Underrepresented educational partners can voice their valuable experiences in the LCAP process.
Representation becomes an actual reality as long as solutions address and recognize language barriers, transportation access, and childcare.
At Davis High School, the lack of representation meant a lack of equity, but our proposal could change that.
Including all socioeconomic groups will empower students to take charge of their education, both locally and statewide.
As a result, they will succeed in an improved environment that prioritizes not only their well-being, but prioritizes the equitable education that every single student deserves.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you so much.
I will turn to board members.
Member Yoshimura Itari.
Good morning. Thank you to all the students for your presentations today.
I wanted to highlight that I was recently reading a book from the late Mike Rose, and he talked about how those with a lived experience have to be closest to the decision makers, people that have the ability to make decisions.
And so as we listen to you today as our student leaders, I think one of the questions that I'll have for you is you're actually in a position to influence things at your schools and in your organizations.
And so how might there be other ways of continuing to do what you're doing today at the state board locally at your schools?
And a good example is the previous example around school safety.
And then I want to make a comment to you about the fact that California is now asking graduating seniors, particularly for socioeconomic equity, to complete the FAFSA.
And there was a report that last year, almost 500 million dollars was unclaimed in California for PAL grants.
And so to support your student colleagues, particularly in this last presentation, I'd be curious to know either now or later, what might be some things you can do to share the opportunities to get grants for higher education to help improve socioeconomic equity.
Great question. Member McQuillen.
Yes, thank you. And thank you for the great presentation.
One of the most important, if not the most important topics to bring up in education in ensuring we have representation from our lower socioeconomic families.
You mentioned that, you know, access and childcare and transportation as being, you know, barriers that we can remove.
I'm wondering if you considered, you know, incentives or other, you know, rewards that could help involve our lower socioeconomic representation in the LCAP process.
You know, many of our families are struggling now with how to pay for food versus utilities versus transportation.
And it could grease the wheels to get that participation with providing some incentives.
But great presentation and very important topic. Thank you very much.
Terrific. And member Lewis, your hand is up here, but I think maybe it was left up from before. Is that correct?
Okay, so I'll turn to our presenter and see if you want to answer those questions.
So for the first question, I'll say thank you so much for all the questions and comments. We'll definitely take that into consideration and they're really helpful.
For the first question about continuing student voice locally, I think that, as you said, it's very important to continue that locally, especially considering the environment we're in right now, where we have the opportunity to do things at a much higher statewide level.
So locally, personally, I would say that one of the things that I could do is participate more in, I guess, specific to our topic, encouraging my local LCAP advisory committees to engage more in schools.
I think that one of the things we mentioned is about outreach. And one of the ways we can do that outreach is by requesting these committees to talk in school-wide assembly meetings in order to access more students and talk to these students about how families can get involved in the process.
And I think that's one of the best ways to do that outreach, to access all demographics. And I think that's something that many students can do as well.
For the second question about grants, grants are obviously a great way to gain access to increasing socioeconomic status. And I think for promoting that, that also just comes with the knowledge and awareness that may be lacking right now.
So I think especially along with our proposal, if we're able to increase the outreach and overall accessibility towards the knowledge of these LCAP meetings and their proposals, one of the things we can highlight in these meetings and proposals could be the access to grants that are being underused right now.
And I think that as soon as we're able to have more public participation, there'll overall just be more public knowledge about these grants and therefore better socioeconomic status for everybody.
And then for the last question about, I believe the last question about the incentives that can be offered, that's obviously one of the biggest things that we discussed in our group as well, how to get these parents engaged even if accessibility is granted because that doesn't necessarily guarantee that engagement.
So one of the things we found is that an incentive in itself could be the virtual conferences. A lot of the statistics we found were that there was like a nine-fold, six-fold increase in the amount of participants just because these meetings turn into virtual conferences.
And like eliminating things like transportation access, that in itself is an incentive to join these meetings because you no longer have to worry about fees and you can take care of your kid while working at home and still participate in the educational process.
And obviously these processes are up to the local district's discretion. So if local districts have the budget to offer more economic incentives and tax incentives, that would be a great way to approach having more engagement.
And if these districts have the capability, then our team would greatly encourage that.
Terrific. Thank you. Member Yoshimura Tari, did you want to add a comment?
Just a comment. I wanted to highlight that you really elucidated three things. You elucidated how we communicate that newspapers may not be the way that students are communicating.
So we need to think about how we communicate and what language we communicate. And three, where we put communication, because those are very timely. And then the many of the groups you talked about, community, trust, relationships, and just the dynamics there.
And so thank you for raising those important issues today, and we appreciate it very much.
Terrific. Thank you. Thanks to all of the presenters. Why don't we all join hands to thank every one of the groups and the presenters that brought these wonderful ideas to us and the very thoughtful replies to our questions, which is definitely part of the policy process.
So you are well on the way. And we will be thinking about your proposals in the days to come. Thank you so much.
And with that, we're going to take a break. It is 1041. We'll come back at 11 o'clock.
Back. Board members, we need to reestablish a quorum, so Brooks is going to call the roll.
President Darling-Hammond.
Here.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Here.
Member Olken.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Here.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member Porter.
Here.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Here.
Everyone present.
Terrific. Item four is the California Community Schools Partnership Program, or CCSPP.
This item is contained, is containing three external presentations, a CDE presentation, and two action items for the board.
For action, the CDE recommends that the board approve the CCSPP RTAC awards, which are the regional technical assistance centers, and that the state board approve the 2022-23 administrative plan for CCSPP.
We will hear from the following three external presenters, Dr. Mark Galli and Melissa Stafford-Jones from the California Department of Health and Human Services.
And then after lunch, we will hear from CCSPP State Transformational Assistance Center, the Anaheim Union High School District.
That item will be presented by Steve Zimmer and Pete Callis of the CDE with an introduction by Superintendent Thurmond.
Superintendent Thurmond, please begin.
Thank you, Dr. Darling-Hammond.
It's an honor to help to tee up this conversation on some latest updates on community schools and action that is before the board to select these regional technical assistance center leaders.
It's also an honor to be able to talk about the nexus in partnership with a very important program, the Children's Behavioral Health Initiative, which many of you remember is a $4 billion initiative that allows us to address mental health in a way that we've not seen before.
I like to call it the No Wrong Door Initiative.
It means that young people can be supported in school or in their community.
It allows us to create alignments within our systems and close gaps that have existed for a long time in how we serve folks in need of mental health support.
And so it's really appropriate to be able to present these items together, the Children's Behavioral Health Initiative and our community schools initiative.
As I talk about the progress of our program, as we approach the end of the first semester of our first cohort for planning and implementation, I want to remind you that our community schools program is the largest community schools initiative in the nation.
Now successfully launched in our state envision more than 458 campuses who have implementation grants and 172 LEAs that have planning grants.
We have before you today, as Dr. Darling-Hammond noted, our state transformative assistance team led by the Alameda County Office of Education to provide some perspective for you.
You'll get to hear from the Anaheim Union High School District about their incredible community schools program.
I've had the chance to visit on more than one occasion and thank Superintendent Mike Matsuda and his team who will be presenting this information for us today.
Then, of course, you'll hear from Deputy Superintendent Steve Zimmer, from our Division Director Pete Callis on this work.
I'd like to now turn to Secretary Mark Galli, Dr. Mark Galli and the Director of the Children's Behavioral Health Initiative, Melissa Stafford-Jones.
Dr. Galli needs no introduction, a foremost pediatrician in our state appointed in 2019.
You know, I would say that I've hung my hat on anything that he has said to us during the pandemic about how we keep students and families safe.
But then this happened. I had the opportunity to fly with Dr. Galli to an event focusing on how we support our schools and their reopening and health and mental health.
Maybe Dr. Galli will say he got stuck on the plane with me, but we flew to that destination and we flew back on a very small plane.
It gave us the opportunity to sit together and talk about Dr. Galli's perspective on how we approach health and human services.
It is a complete perspective. We talked about the importance of strengthening the work that we do around mental health and supports.
And it was a treat for me to be able to talk with him about all things, about how we support our students, about families, about children.
And it is a pleasure now to turn over the microphone for some remarks from our own Secretary of Health and Human Services, Dr. Mark Galli.
Please welcome him as he comes.
Good morning, Superintendent Thurman. Thank you so much for the warm introduction.
And I remember that back and forth trip to Monterey.
We actually ended up meeting up with President Darling-Hammond at a wonderful event at an elementary school where we saw so many important programs
re-ignited, reinstituted in the wake of closures and the pandemic.
And just a tremendous chance to see what I think are the elements of community schools in action and touring with the governor and the two leaders here.
Just really a treat to have a chance to be there to the board.
Thank you for taking some time inviting me and Melissa Stafford-Jones to make a brief presentation and hopefully leave a lot of time for dialogue and questions and the conversation.
I'm going to do what I normally don't do very well, which is share a screen.
Let me get that set up first and then see if we can.
OK.
One moment.
All right. Are you all able to see the full screen?
We are. Great. OK.
It's dangerous when they let a secretary drive the Zoom screen.
Normally doesn't happen.
So like I said, really privileged to be here.
Thank you for the invitation.
Be honest, in a week, I have a privilege of giving dozens of presentations about a whole bunch of different issues.
This is one that I've been anticipating for quite some time because in the sort of throws of this whole movement around behavioral health for young people,
it is hard to imagine the health field carrying it by itself.
And no one expects that.
But the importance of our conversation today on the heels of lots of work with partners in the education community across our state,
I think it's so important for me to emphasize to all of you what a privilege it is to be here with you to engage on this,
to see where there's opportunities, where there's maybe a rock we haven't flipped over yet,
to really uncover and discover what more we can do for young people to support them through their youth into productive adulthood.
So what we know about mental health in this crisis in California and across our nation are it's hard to summarize it with just data.
I think the personal experiences probably speak louder.
But now it's the leading cause for hospitalization in California for young people under 18.
I can tell you stories in Los Angeles where on every long weekend,
I was tasked with finding placements for young people who are stuck in emergency rooms on 5150 danger to self danger to others because we had nowhere to go.
Those weren't issues that happened over that long weekend.
They'd been brewing for weeks, months before, and they culminate in the emergency room.
And I say on long weekends because we could always handle a one day or a two day lull in the system.
But that third day seemed to break the whole system all across the state.
You all probably know that one in three Californians in middle school and nearly half of 11th graders are reporting being chronically sad.
We know the impact is disparate on different populations and LGBTQ youth reporting feeling sad or hopeless and usually stopping some activities at two thirds.
So you can see and know that this is a crisis of really epic proportions across our nation.
We also know that it's important to think about prevention and early intervention.
Half of diagnosable mental illness begins by the time kids are 14 and 75 percent by the age of 24.
We see some of the most extreme manifestations of severe mental health in adulthood.
But really, their evidence, their initial symptoms can be traced to childhood.
Fifty percent of young people in our juvenile justice systems have mental health needs.
I can tell you this from firsthand experience as a pediatrician in L.A.
I primarily worked in our foster care system in South Los Angeles, as well as the various holes in camps as part of the juvenile justice system and had a chance to see hundreds, thousands of youth over my time who were struggling with diagnosed and undiagnosed behavioral health conditions rooted in the circumstances in their community and lives and others that were manifestations of that first psychotic break that happened to just about every one of us.
There's not any family that you could imagine.
So seeing this and really pinpointing this as a big important issue in the juvenile justice system is important.
We know that the detection and intervention on mental health and behavioral health conditions and I say behavioral health to acknowledge the crisis we have with substance use disorders, especially among our adolescent students,
whether it's the issues with fentanyl and opiates or other drugs and alcohol that we know wreak havoc on the lives of young people and their academic and life success all the time.
And then this point, which I think is a milestone for us on the primary health care side, which is this real recognition over the last many years that in order for us to more effectively address the children's behavioral health crisis,
we need to ensure that we're continuing to build our roots in bringing together the behavioral health systems and the primary care systems to address early issues of depression, anxiety, and other behavioral health issues in childhood.
So Superintendent Thurmond referenced already that we in the administration have had a very fine important point of focus on children and youth behavioral health.
It culminated in some very important actions, but these are not things that came up in a week or a month.
They were really efforts that have a long tail and areas where we've been long concerned about how we can do a better job.
So in August, the governor doubled down with the first partner in the Central Valley, the announcement of the master plan for kids mental health.
This is probably more than $4.7 billion if you add all the threads, but certainly at least $4.7 billion that is looking to support the mental health and substance use services for young people under the age of 25.
So there's an early childhood learning component here. There's obviously a K through 12 component, and then there's a higher ed component each getting their special attention and focus, but all taken as equal high priorities.
They lead with the whole child approach. I appreciate the point that the superintendent makes about the no wrong door, every door works approach, which is really what we want to make sure is available.
This is multi year. It's not one year or a few years of funding, and there's about nearly a half a billion dollars that is ongoing through the various health systems that serve young people.
And it really represents a fundamental overhaul in the infrastructure available to young people.
Building on what we have today, but certainly filling a whole host of gaps and the Children Youth Behavioral Health Initiative, which I will focus on in a moment is a core to this master plan.
It's not the only piece, as you see below, community schools, the Medi-Cal Cal AIM initiative, which begins to, for Medicaid families, integrate health and behavioral health really pays attention to those who are system involved young people, whether it's the child welfare system or the juvenile justice system, allowing you to sort of essentially immediately be eligible for behavioral health services, for which in the past you needed to be able to do that.
In the past, you needed to be screened and deemed eligible through a medical provider. So Cal AIM, I'm sure many of you have heard about portions of it, but it does fundamentally reform how behavioral health is managed, not just for kids, but adults as well.
We've had some very important aspects for children, and then we can't have a conversation about anything in health today, especially on the heels of the pandemic without focusing on the workforce.
The explosion of need and demand on behavioral health has really squarely put the gaps of capacity and workforce capacity in specific in California front and center, and the governor and the legislature made $1.4 billion of explicit investments in the healthcare workforce.
But there are many, many more dollars that are intended to help beef up and build up fill gaps, the behavioral health workforce across our state.
So what is the Children Youth Behavioral Health Initiative? We call it CYBHI. It's a mouthful as an acronym or as a name, but it is, as I said, a historic five-year investment, initially of $4.4 billion, and at the very basic, it's meant to transform all the ways that we support young people.
It focuses on promoting mental, emotional, and behavioral health. It has a serious focus on prevention. We want to get upstream. The initial conversations that went into the CYBHI were really about how we, like in so many areas of health, wait too long to start serving people.
That we know the data that I shared with you on the first slide, that half of behavioral health conditions manifest by the age of 14, that full 75% in adolescents and young adulthood, and that we, knowing that, need to do more to be further upstream and be where young people are, be where their families are, be in their communities.
That this is not just about the point where we have a diagnosis, but this is really about supporting and providing screening or assessment to all young people. This is a big task.
I remember when I was speaking to the governor about it, he said, are you sure you want to go after all young people? And I said, there's no other way to do it, right? There's no other way to build a system for California's youngest citizens without focusing on all of them because behavioral health, although there's disparate impacts on some groups, it is an issue in an area that affects every young person, every family, every community, every school.
And we wanted to take in the vein of the governor's California for all a true all children, all young people approach. And then, although this is about lifting all boats, we know that some boats will need more lifting than others.
So addressing the inequities for groups disproportionately impacted is an important issue focusing on the systemic barriers to well-being, what those are, whether it's issues around the digital divide or the attributes of community health systems, or what we hope to have a conversation about what schools might need to address those inequities in behavioral health.
Broadly speaking, we're all interested in CYBHI to focus their anchored inequity. I think we are most concerned about ensuring that we take down the silos that have for so long existed between health schools and other systems that impact young people so that we can deliver on this promise that the governor laid out just about a year and a half ago.
So, as I said, I was super excited about this presentation in part because, and Linda knows this, and I even maybe shared some of these stories with Tony. When I first exited residency and worked in the Bayview Hunters Point community, I spent a lot of time in the lives of my patients, didn't live far away from Bayview.
But certainly the experiences of that community, any of you who know it, were radically different than those in the rest of the city. And I spent a lot of time with the families and the young people that I had the privilege of taking care of, and in fact, spent a lot of time in their schools.
I remember being on the small blue chairs in first-kinder, second-grade classrooms talking about primarily young boys of color, primarily black boys in Bayview who were being kicked out of class because of, quote, behavioral issues.
And I appreciated the challenges of the school and the teacher and always came with sort of brain and heart of how do we help support not just this young person, but the school and these dedicated educators on serving the needs, not just of the patient I have, but frankly, the whole classroom.
And sitting through whether it was IEP meetings or other brainstorms with that school and the educators and the leaders in that school quickly and for a long time discovered how important the alignment of our efforts to support young people are.
And that didn't change for me in Los Angeles. I shared a little bit about my experience in the juvenile detention centers, but that also had a great opportunity to work with our county office of education who were delivering the education services in the juvenile halls and camps and having a chance to talk about both the behavioral health, the mental health, the other health challenges.
And found that those relationships and those opportunities often led to the shared goals being sort of manifest and discussed between education and health.
And for far too long, I think the health system has seen this opportunity to, and I'm going to use a word leverage, leverage the education system and the schools where kids are to get our work done, whether it was health screenings or actually having health services delivered in schools.
When it comes to behavioral health, though, I think there is a real opportunity to talk about how schools and the education community can better leverage us on health to help meet the needs that are more and more evident in the classroom.
And one of the parts of this conversation that I'm most interested in is hearing all of your ideas for how that leverage becomes manifest where there's opportunities for deeper partnership and conversation so that we both take our approach with whole child in mind.
The opportunity around community schools, this epic opportunity with the Children Youth Behavioral Health Initiative, the focus by elected leaders, including the governor and the first partner on investing in behavioral health and really, frankly, drive a truck through this opportunity together so that we can better focus on the young people's needs that we know.
Frankly, are we're failing to meet at least as it comes to behavioral health.
So I'm going to just quickly fly through a few more slides to get us to the conversation component here. But over the next five years, these are the sort of bullets that explain what we're focused on.
We're focused on, like I said, really reimagining the entire ecosystem, focusing on prevention and early intervention, talking about reducing stigma, focusing on awareness, catalyzing that alignment and coordination between the health systems that often take care of young people towards
The sort of the more severe end of the spectrum of disorders and needs, but also coordinating with communities and schools and other entities where young people are focusing on the workforce workforce workforce can't say enough and making sure that we pay attention to the lack of diversity and the need to increase not just
The the the ethnic diversity of the workforce, but ensuring that all young people, no matter what they're facing and dealing with have somebody in the workforce that can relate to them benefiting from some of the important innovations that we saw scaled during the pandemic on
Virtual care and telehealth and using all of these to put together a system that I hope really does meet the needs of young people in the years to come.
There's four areas of focus here. We talked about the behavioral health ecosystem and the infrastructure. We talked about ensuring that coverage architecture makes sense.
And it's so easy for the state to focus just on medical and Medicaid and the opportunities there. But if we're really going to have an all children, all young people approach, we can't ignore the need to align with the commercial health systems and to ensure that those with private or employer
sponsored insurance have the same
Access to and ability to receive the benefits of some of these programs workforce again and then public awareness.
I like to think that one day soon, just as young students have no shame, no issue, no concern to raise their hand to say, you know, I need to go to my doctor or dentist appointment.
Similarly, young person as the courage, the security, the understanding to be able to be in an environment where standing up and saying, I'm going to seek support and help for a behavioral health issue or
participate in wellness activities that it's seen in the same light as a routine regular part of how we ensure young people are well taken care of in our state.
So I'm not going to spend a lot of time here. I'm going to skip to the next slide pretty quickly because this is dizzying in some ways.
Melissa is on she can help fill in some of the gaps, but this slide really just shows the 14 general areas of focus. We have 14 work streams, each one is
Connected but independent. They focus and fall under these four header areas that I shared on the previous slide.
And together, these are the elements of transformation. These are the elements of partnership and these are going to be the tools that if made widely available at scale and robust enough could really help transform the
Experience young people have both in preventing and focusing on wellness and also accessing the services they need when those initial services aren't enough.
So partnering with schools to support well-being. I think CYBHI just want to highlight a few things. I mentioned the behavioral health workforce investments. I'm going to spend the last couple of slides talking about the new behavioral health coach role that some of you may have heard about, but I'm excited to share a little bit more.
Building infrastructure through schooling partnerships. I use the word school linked very deliberately. Often people want to focus on school based.
But having shared a little bit of my experience in schools, I know that it's challenging to find the space to find the time to find the resources to be able to do everything on a school campus.
And some schools maybe have that capability today. Others, maybe not. So if we're trying to create a equitable system across the state, we can't depend on everything done for a young person.
Maybe it's appropriately done at a school, but we don't have the capacity to do so. So how do we make sure that they're at least school linked and ensure that this linkage is robust, that it doesn't mean that it's harder or less likely to happen, that a young person can access those services.
So this piece is really critical, I think, to understanding CYBHI's intent to work with schools. Yes, we want to figure out what might be where there's opportunities when it's appropriate to have resources on site, but if that's not possible, it doesn't mean that there's not a strong opportunity for partnership.
Scaling evidence-based and community-defined practices with an emphasis on equity. This is key. California, more than any other state, has the opportunity to not just have emerging practices embedded in our systems, but really create and develop the evidence to scale things that are working in one place and bringing them to others.
So this learning community, their opportunities, I think are, I want to say, endless. I think there's a lot that we have yet to do that really is an opportunity for us moving forward.
Supporting partnerships between Medi-Cal, so much of what we do in Cal HHS, even though we think broadly about health and human services and those social services, because of the way the federal government has set up Medi-Cal or Medicaid, there's a lot of opportunity to use it as one of our primary equity tools for low-income communities.
So this year, through some programs through the Department of Health Care Services, supporting these partnerships through the Medi-Cal Managed Care Plans, 23 of them across the state, working with LEAs and districts across the states and county offices of education, to really come up with collaborative approaches, real programs that can be used in a variety of ways.
And that could further the mission of Medi-Cal by engaging and partnering with our school partners. This, to me, is a real manifestation of what we can do together using the resources that are made available through Medi-Cal.
Cal Hope Student Services, I think I hope many of you have benefited from this. Cal Hope was something that we created in the throes of the pandemic for all Californians, primarily focused on adults, but the urgency of the needs for young people created Cal Hope for kids and youth.
And now has really become something where there's more of a learning community, a coalescence of, I think, hundreds of educators and education leaders talking and thinking about how we develop the tools to support schools for social-emotional learning, something that we're excited to continue to build on.
The funding alluded to in the next bullet around wellness, mindfulness, and resilience of students, really imagining that those dollars are made available to LEAs through sort of the Cal Hope model, if you will, to make sure those dollars are well mobilized across our state to support districts in implementing those wellness and mindfulness programs.
There's, of course, a focus on training from informed care, training done by the Office of the Surgeon General to educators, schools, and child care providers.
And then this last point, probably dull, probably easy to overlook, but really one of the key secret weapons of the entire Children's Youth Behavioral Health Initiative, as I said, supernatural, more frankly easier to just focus on Medicaid.
But part of what we worked with with the plans in the commercial space with the legislature was to make sure that what we could provide in schools linked to schools for young people on Medicaid was promised to also be provided by the commercial health plan.
So we are actively working on creating a statewide fee schedule so that the different services, the different programs that could be school linked actually come with a reimbursement rate that all plans agree to reimburse moving forward.
This does not happen overnight. It will take a couple of years, frankly, to get it up and running and implemented.
But moving forward, this is exactly the kind of tool that we need to make sure that we don't just create something that lasts a few years, but that we have a sort of pathway to continue having the resources to support these important programs.
This is just to show a slide that yes, we're focusing on outcomes and goals. This is a draft set. I don't expect anyone to sort of really ingest this now, but Melissa and her team are engaging lots of stakeholders, including educators on what these outcomes and goals should be.
How do we make sure we have access to the data and the information to track towards them? Because an initiative like this doesn't come about very often, and the ability to demonstrate its value in the transformation of the lives of young people, families, and communities is going to be key to maintaining this moving forward.
Before I go any further, we have been very deliberate to list the various departments in Cal HHS who work on this initiative. The Department of Health Care Services, Health Care Access and Information Department, formerly known as OSHPD.
They do a lot of our workforce work. The Department of Managed Health Care, who oversees the commercial and Medicaid managed care plans, helping us specifically in the areas of the fee schedule.
The Department of Public Health focused primarily on awareness and stigma engagement, and then the Office of the Surgeon General, their work on ACEs and the focus on ACE screening has really set themselves up well to help us focus on the trauma-informed educator tools and building out that whole suite of services.
So unlike most of the things that we do at the state where it's one agency, one department within that agency, this is really starting out cross-cutting across our agency, and if you put the tentacles to so many other partners, including you at the state board, the Department of Education, we see this as really an incredible collaborative opportunity.
So in one or two minutes, I just wanted to say that one of the most innovative parts of this whole initiative is a focus on the behavioral health coach role. This is not something in California that we have today.
It's frankly not a role that anyone across the nation has. This is a recognition that we have a serious behavioral health workforce crisis, that if we're going to meet the needs of young Californians, frankly Californians anywhere of any age or location, we're going to need to not just double down on what we already have, whether those are social workers or other therapists and counselors or psychiatrists or nurse practitioners and PAs.
But we're going to have to create some new roles as well, roles that are maybe even a little bit in greater reach for people in communities that allow us to tap into the diversity of both experience and interest across our state.
So the behavioral health coach role is something that HCI through their workforce initiatives is putting together. They participated in dozens, I think somewhere between 50 and 100 stakeholder meetings, getting input on what this role can look like, how it fits into the community continuum that we already have, including with schools, how it fits into the school infrastructure and staffing approaches.
It isn't meant in any way to supplant or replace what we already have. As I said earlier, we need more, not figure out ways to do things differently.
But this is a really important opportunity, I think, to bring in folks who we often talk about peers, that sort of notion of near peers with some strong education and support and supervision to do the work that I think I know and I expect many of you know our young people need.
Here are some of the services that they will provide wellness, promotion and education. They'll participate in screening, care coordination, extension of services, individual supports, imagining that the behavioral health coaches may be able to do a virtual group and support a group of young people who maybe aren't even at the same school or in the same community, but share some common experience.
And then, of course, crisis referral, which will require a good bit of training, but also something that we need more of, more antennas up, and then some additional competencies that will be built in to the education approach for these behavioral health coaches.
So I'm going to stop sharing and turn it back to you. I know that was quite a bit of information. I never say it as fast as I wish I could, because I really do want to engage in the dialogue.
And both Melissa and I are available for additional clarification, answer any questions, but really hope to have some back and forth with you to understand how this might better fit in to the plans and opportunities that you see as we all work together on that whole child, every child counts approach.
So, Linda, I don't know if I'm turning it back to you, but thanks again for the privilege of presenting to you.
We're so pleased to have you. And I just want to start by thanking you for your leadership in this, both in the sort of comprehensiveness of this approach and the fact that it is being designed to be so integrated and coherent, you know, with schools where children spend so much of their lives and where we want, you know,
both to be better informed about trauma informed and healing oriented care, which is part of the plan and where we want schools, of course, to produce less trauma, as well as to be able to respond to it.
So I would love to start off with one question, then I'll turn it to my board colleagues as well.
One of the things I think is so there's so much potential here for that we have not always been able to have before is a cross communication between mental health professionals who have a body of knowledge about trauma informed care and many other things.
And education professionals who have a body of knowledge increasingly about social and emotional learning programs, about restorative practices, which we've got a new study at LPI coming up shows the more restorative practices kids experience, the better their mental health outcomes, the less depression, the less suicidal ideation and so on.
So we want to be able to share those with the, you know, the connective tissue to the mental health so that we have professionals talking with each other with a common understanding of what each of them can do to reinforce the efforts of the other.
And I just wonder if you've been thinking about or have some beginning ideas for how we could structure this in a way that communication and shared practice could be developed.
So I think a couple of thoughts and then open it up to the group and Melissa as well. Two things come to mind. One thing I glossed over that is a core component is this virtual platform that is going to be the anchor of everything we do.
It's slated to receive hundreds of millions of dollars to create. It's meant to be the front door to the entire initiative. And it's meant to be used by young people, by caregivers and guardians and parents, and by educators to really engage with real tools that allow us to begin serving the needs that maybe are under addressed for a young person that you have in the classroom or in the community or family.
And we hope that it's a widely used tool. We're creating it and tailoring it so that it's sort of created by youth for youth in as many ways as we possibly can. But that becomes a very real time place where I think we'll have a lot of cross exchange of ideas and opportunities to learn from one another.
I mentioned the work that we have launched with the managed care plans and really creating partnerships between those entities. And you might say, well, why the managed care plans? Because frankly, they're the ones who drive Medicaid. They're the ones who start with the funding for Medicaid and they have the resources.
And so providers in the community where that plan works or overseas, they're going to really respond to the wishes of the plan and engage. So I think that becomes a table, those tables that are actively being created between plans and providers on the one hand, and LEAs and districts and schools on the other hand,
become a place where I think we can have that communication angle. We had one tool that will be created as part of the initiative as well is what we called an e-consult system. And as I mentioned before, as a primary care pediatrician, I could engage with specialists across the state or across my community through a collaborative,
what they call asynchronous approach to getting information to how to serve the patient in front of me or the student in front of you. And I think that this became a really two way communication opportunity focused on a real life situation that had immediate impact.
And so I think we have opportunities at the very high level to continue to bring each other together, but I'm really excited about how we create more tools to have sharing of information around specific, I call them patients, you might call them students, but young people wherever that we're seeing them.
So I think CYBHI creates those two opportunities at that level.
And, you know, I think beyond, I think those are great ideas and beyond the level of the individual student or patient, if we can communicate about the practices that are school wide, and the ways in which those support students generally and are available for specific cases, you know, that would create healthy environments that, you know, increasingly healthy environments that are part of the ultimate plan.
Ultimate puzzle. I see that member Escobedo, member Orozco Gonzalez, both have questions or comments. And member Olkins, so let's get them on the table. I know, Mark, I'm told that you have a hard stop at noon, is that right?
I'm going to, I'm just texting to move and get another 10 minutes. If you all have it, I'm willing to stay till about 10 after.
Well, by virtue of the number of hands that are up, I think we could use that.
Yeah, that'd be great. Member Escobedo.
Very quick. I applaud the work on changing the architectural coverage. Any thoughts about changing the architecture of a clinic or the hospital, namely having mental health services within the area of care.
For example, in the San Ysidro Health Clinic, where my students used to go for dental health, the therapist was right next door. And even it was a subtle yet powerful message that, you know, mental health is part of taking care of the whole child.
So, just any thoughts about that?
Well, I mean, first off, I think your illustration is key, right? We want behavioral health to sort of be seamless and around students, just like you mentioned dental care, I think about the primary pediatric experience, making sure it's there.
I think we have some work to do in making sure that clinics like San Ysidro and other FQHCs have the ability to, you know, bill or receive payment for those services.
So that's a whole different conversation that we're active with federally qualified health centers and others. But I think as we've seen in other areas of medicine, if the funding and the billing becomes more seamless and straightforward, suddenly the models and services exist.
So that's one thing. The other thing that I think is really important, and we're in this struggle right now, is that I often say, especially with behavioral health, we have to get out of the clinics, we have to get out of the hospital because so much of what we seek to do is really anchored in communities.
And, you know, schools as communities, I know we talk a lot about community schools, but schools as communities, I think, really understanding where there's an opportunity. So as we transform what it looks like within the four walls of clinics and hospitals and other places, I'm also, and frankly, even more excited about thinking about what it looks like to get the show on the road.
Awesome. Member Roscoe Gonzalez, and then I have member Olken, Patil Bronson, Glover Woods.
I know it's quite a bit and it just seems like two very different worlds are colliding in terms of preschool to 12th grade education and health and human services.
There is a prime opportunity for deeper levels of coordination and engagement between the community schools initiative and the Children and Youth Behavioral Health Initiative.
So my question to you is, what needs to happen to ensure we take advantage of this opportunity to leverage the resources and expertise to the benefit of our students, educators and communities?
Well, I think that conversations like the one we're having today and really making it a priority so that I know for me and Melissa can vouch for this, it's a leadership priority.
There is a lot of, I'm going to say, missed opportunity, things we've left on the table in the past because the partnerships haven't been as deep and candid as they need to be.
And when the superintendent talks about our plane ride back and forth, some of the plane conversation was about where there's real opportunities and where we haven't capitalized on it.
So I think one thing is making sure that the board, that I as the governor has, the superintendent, others, that we continue to prioritize.
Let's not figure this out on our own because we can't. I don't think we can.
But then we're going to really create the force function of bringing people together around the tables that Linda's asking about.
And I'm sure many of you are asking about. We have the start for some of that. I think we have the leaders who are absolutely interested.
But I worry that as new things come up that we lose the focus and emphasis. And that's why I would love to have this be an annual conversation or a biannual conversation where we are coming together with you to say, how are we doing on creating those tables?
And where are we still missing opportunity? Because as I said, Medicaid is this amazing tool and the commercial insurance world is this amazing tool to create the resources to do some of the things I think we all want to do for kids.
I see Melissa has popped up. Did you want to add something, Melissa?
Thank you so much, President Arlenham. I just wanted to note that I'm just really appreciative and grateful that CYBHI and Cal HHS have also had the opportunity to be meeting regularly with SBE and CDE staff and leadership on these issues.
So we are like rolling up our sleeves and digging in and thinking about, okay, well, where are the key intersection points between CYBHI and community schools or expanded learning? What might the behavioral health coach will look like there?
How can the virtual services platform connect? What are those opportunities? So we still have much work to do, but I just wanted to express my appreciation and gratitude for the partnership effort that I've already started.
This conversation is reminding me of a school I worked closely with in East Palo Alto where there was a lot of trauma that kids experienced and we had a relationship with Stanford Child Psychiatry Unit.
And so the interns and residents were able to come over and meet with students regularly in groups, you know, for group therapy as well as individually, and then be in part of the faculty meetings to talk about the various strategies that both the school and the professionals could, the mental health professionals could jointly be aware of and engage in.
And then if we can get to a place where that's the kind of integration that schools can experience, I think the benefits are just enormous.
Member Olken, you are next in queue.
Thank you. I want to first just say thank you so much for all this work and for sharing your time and expertise with us.
I think any of us who work in education have always really seen the important connection between student well-being and student academic success, and the pandemic just made that so much more evident and important and on all of our minds.
So this feels so well-timed.
And I just had a couple of thoughts and questions. So the first one is, I just want to say I love the behavioral coach model. And as I'm thinking about people with whom I work at my schools, who I could see incredible school staff wanting to like taking up that opportunity as a,
for increased learning and then perhaps as a career growth opportunity in a way that already builds on what they bring to our school.
And so I think that's amazing. Along those lines, Linda mentioned the importance of restorative practices, and this is just a small piece.
In that description of the competencies for that role, I would love for restorative practices to be part of it. I think that's such an important part of what that person or that role could bring in terms of expertise for a school site.
So that's that piece. And then earlier this morning, we heard presentations from the Student Advisory Board on Education, and one of the groups was on mental health, and their recommendation was that we should invest in peer support, peer mental health coaches and supports.
And I thought it was an interesting one too, you know, first of their, what they brought to us and then what you brought to us. And I just wondered about the ways in which we could think about supporting students to become supports to each other as a way to perhaps
focus on that might be a bridge for public awareness and the stigmatization. That's one of those four principles. And then another one is even workforce training and capacity.
Because I think the more our young people see schools as places where their expertise and what they bring to the table as being important, the more likely they are to want to pursue a career in education or in mental health.
And so I think there's a real link there. We could start getting young people on the path early and that would, based on the diversity of our schools, perhaps help us diversify the field as well, which is really important. So just some thoughts and I'm so excited. Thank you.
Can I just respond really quickly? I think the second piece is something we, there was a small part of this past budget that focused on engagement, especially diverse young students in getting them prepared for fields in behavioral health.
And there may be a nexus there to really think about how we amplify that and build that with the behavioral health coach model. Melissa, I'm sure, has some ideas there as well. We've been talking about the peer versus near peer difference and how does that look and feel.
So I think this is right for a conversation where we'd love to get your feedback about what would best work in a school environment. Where is it a good idea? Maybe where is it not as good as an idea? That's where your expertise certainly could influence how we look at this moving forward. So appreciate the point and see that as another place of opportunity and collaboration.
Terrific. Vice President Clever-Woods and then I have member McCullin, Patil Bronson and Rodriguez.
Thank you. And thank you so much for the presentation. I think anytime we see true and authentic collaboration and integration amongst all of our different agencies for the support of students, it's absolutely wonderful.
And I'm quite encouraged that the community schools program is actually a great model of what that can possibly look like.
I was also very encouraged around the idea of diversifying the behavioral health workforce, just as we're looking at how to better diversify the teaching workforce that interacts with our children every day.
A thought that I had, and it may be something that's already being explored, is perhaps finding an integration point with our CTE programs as well.
We do have, as many of you are already aware, that health services sector and there is a specific pathway related to behavioral and I'm looking at it right now, mental and behavioral health.
And as we're thinking about the behavioral health coaches and again just diversifying the workforce as a whole in multiple positions, integrating and connecting with the CTE programs in the schools might be a wonderful way to bring more students into the fold from more diverse backgrounds.
So that's a great thought and just to deconstruct our acronyms, that's our career technical education.
I was just going to ask, but terrific. You have your acronyms and we have ours.
Yeah, I'm terrible at defining ours. One important point that I don't think people hear enough, but this was recently surveyed again, but four out of five Americans believe that behavioral health is a bigger and bigger and more important and a grave issue in our country.
And four out of five surveyed individuals believe that it's not just the responsibility of the health system to focus on. They see a role for community, they see a role for family members, they see a role for neighbors.
So how do we take that idea and really amplify it in a community school model or any other model that you all think might make sense? And I think that concept is at the belly of the Children Youth Behavioral Health Initiative and I think amplifies this idea of diversity in the workforce.
I think I'm going to get it not entirely right, but 75% of the need is among people of color and 70% of the workforce is white in California in the behavioral health space.
So we have a real gap. We have a real need to focus on diversity if we're going to really pay attention to some of these equity issues that we're talking about.
And this notion of starting to think about these various pathways and on-ramps is really exciting.
Melissa, did you want to add something?
Yes, thanks so much, President Darling-Hammond. I just wanted to note that actually Deputy Superintendent Zimmer raised this issue with me and with our colleagues at the Department of Health Care Access and Information. I think it was this summer.
And actually they've started some meetings and conversations about the intersection of CTE with the Career Pathways programs that we have that HCI is leading under the Children Youth Behavioral Health Initiative and beyond.
Because we also have Career Pathways programs that reach into high schools as well as colleges. So there is some conversation that's been started about where those connection points might be. So we appreciate that being raised.
Terrific. Member McQuillin.
Thank you. And thank you for this very rich conversation. Dr. Mark, there was a lot in your presentation there to unwrap. Thank you for that.
You know, there's so much we need to do in terms of breaking down the silos between our systems and in education itself.
You know, we often run into, you know, that it's not my responsibility to touch on mental health or social emotional. That's the health class that deals with that. We still have some of that work to be done to bringing down those silos.
But I wanted to, and I appreciate all of it in terms of recruitment and definitely the CTE. I sit on that subcommittee with the with the members of the California Chancellor's Board.
And we need to raise that up in terms of helping to make sure that's a louder message out there that the health pathways are a part of CTE and it can be funded and supported there for that recruitment.
But I wanted to go back to I appreciate the school link linked services, not school based services and that that distinction you made there in terms of funding and accessing those school link services to zero in on continuing funding for the support services.
And do you see any other hurdles that we can focus in on for that, whether it be Medicaid or the third party billing to keep the services going? Thank you.
Yeah, and I'll ask Melissa to jump in on this as well because she's she's working on it day in and day out. But it's you know, you want to create an environment where the services are quote reimbursable in a way without turning the whole operation focused on billing.
Right. And we have a real chance to do that. This whole rate schedule for the commercial plans, which will be mirrored and built on what we're doing in Medicaid will theoretically create an opportunity for bread and butter services that might happen in a school or might be linked to a school to be reimbursed.
And even though I know that's focused on payment, but that is exactly what's going to allow us to keep these services going, not just for the five years of, you know, the Children with Behavioral Health Initiative, but way beyond that.
And we are adding more services that you'll probably recognize as useful to what is reimbursed under Medicaid and soon under the commercial plans. Right. So there's family based services where it's not just about the student, but it's about what happens to the family.
There's some population based services that might help cover, you know, a classroom or a school. There are some opportunities around virtual care and virtual services. So I think there's a real, again, collaboration that could bring together exactly what the school
communities believe they can do and need to do and want to do to allow us to use the health lane and leverage it for those resources when possible. So this is a part of it that I'm really excited about. So I'm grateful that you amplify it.
And I know Melissa spending time thinking through how we're going to actually get this right.
Melissa, I don't know if you want to jump in on anything more on this.
Nothing to add, but I'm happy to further time it's appropriate to dig in more to how the fiscal is going to work. It's really being developed as we speak. There's a new working group that's been established that just had its first meeting in October.
So we're in that stage of really rolling up our sleeves to design and develop how this ongoing reimbursement mechanism is going to work over time.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
flag that we're seeing, particularly in the early side,
that both in TK settings and early learning settings
that school districts have a line of sight to
that kids are coming in with less socialization
with different sort of challenges and speech delays
and how you're thinking about integrating that
into this set of programming.
Sure, and again, the sort of have four,
three, four key buckets, right?
It's sort of before kids get into the TK to 12 environment,
that environment of TK to 12,
which really breaks down to at least two or three,
and then the post-secondary education side.
I think the place where we probably,
and Melissa, you may need to update this,
have spent probably the least time to date
is where are we on the earliest age groups
where it's not necessarily all happening
within a formal public school environment
where it's a much more scattered network
of providers of childcare services.
So there we're leaning more heavy on things
like our platform and some of these tools
as the entry point to some of those services,
but that's still very early in its creation.
But Melissa, maybe you can talk a little bit more
on what the engagement has looked like there.
Sure, thanks so much.
Yeah, I really appreciate that.
I think we're still working through developing
the overall approach to early childhood
as Secretary Galli indicated,
but there are a few key pieces that actually are underway.
One is the addition of dyadic services
as a benefit in the medical program,
which was specifically meant,
particularly for our youngest children,
when behavioral and social-emotional issues are emerging
to make sure that we have services in place
that really allow not only the child,
but the caregiver, the parent,
to get some of the supports that they need.
And that benefit will begin on January 21st, 2023.
Actually, the Department of Healthcare Services
just released yesterday, I think it was on their website,
some additional information about the launch of that.
So a really important piece that we know
is coming to support not just the child, but the family.
Secondly, the trauma-informed training for educators
that Secretary Galli spoke of earlier
has a specific component to it
that is specifically for early care and learning providers.
And this training will be free,
it will be widely accessible
when it becomes available next summer.
And we know that given some of the challenges
and the schedules for early care and learning providers,
we're really hoping that that training
will be available and accessible to them
in beginning the work and the journey
of really understanding trauma-informed care
and how that can support them in their efforts
of the incredible work they do
in terms of caring for our youngest children.
And Dr. Galli mentioned the platform as well.
And then we are also the services in the fee schedule
for our younger children who are on school campuses.
We are looking at what those opportunities are there
to the third building out to the fee schedule
to think about that.
And we've actually begun some very early conversations
with our partners at CDE also about potential intersections
between universal pre-kindergarten and the CYBH guide.
Where might some of those key intersection points be?
And then just the other piece I'll mention
is two other pieces.
One is the behavioral health coach role
is actually envisioned to be a potential role
in an early care and learning setting.
We're not starting there first in terms of that,
but that is really something we would be interested
in working on over time with the early childhood sector
to think about what would that deployment look like
to have behavioral health coaches in those settings.
And then lastly, just to note the work on stigma
and public awareness,
something we have heard from youth and from parents
and a lot of engagement we've been doing with them
is the work around public awareness and stigma
as well as how to access supports and services
that work around navigation
that we think the platform is gonna be really helpful
to doing we know is also really key
for our families with very young.
That's really awesome.
With youngest children too,
there's often a very close nexus
between physical and biological health
and mental health and behavioral health.
And so I wonder if there's a component of this
that connects to the other health providers
and awareness of environmental hazards
and so on that can often get expressed
in behavioral dysregularities,
but that are really stemming from other experiences
the child is having physically or otherwise.
We are, Linda, just to that point,
one of the things we are exploring,
we wouldn't be the first state to do this,
but really what does a first thousand day of life
initiative look like that focuses on
how all of this is really tied together.
And that's another place where as we talked about it,
could certainly could use your expertise
and advice of the board on what that looks like.
So I think about things like,
autism is now one in 44 kids, right?
And there are a lot of behavioral manifestations
that people might pick up on,
but then there's a whole biological
and environmental component and so on.
So there's gonna, that integrated approach
that you're championing is just incredibly important
in so many ways.
Member Rodriguez, I think you get the last word.
Yes, thank you so much, President Darlene Hammond.
And a lot of what I was going to say has been said
and I won't be redundant and repeat it,
just wanna echo my appreciation for my colleagues
and especially member Petillo-Gruntz
because I was going to say, Dr. Galli,
thank you so much.
Your voice was a very calming voice during the pandemic.
And as you were here, I was taken back
to how much I looked forward to your updates.
So I appreciate that.
And also Melissa just talked about the stigma
and that's what I wanted to share a little bit about.
In my community, which is largely Mexican, right?
We live next to the Mexican border.
There is a stigma with mental health,
like, oh, it's all in your head.
And the stigma exists in other cultures,
but just suck it up and deal with it.
And so that's something
that our community has been working hard
and especially the support,
the behavioral health at our school.
We don't quite have the EPA model
of having psychologists working on our campus,
but right next to us,
we do have a behavioral health specialist
and a great relationship.
And I've seen how much my students appreciate
having a therapist, licensed therapist to talk to
when we have our school assemblies and they introduce her,
she gets the most applause.
And so we're making some great strides
and it wouldn't be possible without the commitment
from our governor, from your department,
from the CDE, Superintendent Thurman.
And this is what it takes
because I see a lot of desperation
and this is the hope, right?
When people are desperate,
especially a lot of our foster youth
is when they feel like they have nothing to lose
and these services bring in that light of hope.
So thank you so much.
Well, if I could just wrap by saying,
the last two members brought up the pandemic
and I will tell you, Linda,
we haven't had the privilege of connecting
since it's been calmer.
No.
But as we reflect back at some of the important efforts
in California, as it relates to pandemic response,
the more time I spend doing it,
the more I realize we were playing catch up
from the very beginning.
We have not invested enough in the community
infrastructure that we need to really carry forward
and be prepared for the next public health emergency.
And as much as the Children Youth Behavioral Health
Initiative, our partnerships with you as educators
of schools becomes about really anchoring
and building resilient, thriving communities
for young people and their families.
I think we are better set up to deal with
whatever comes across our plate,
whether it's the next variance or the really the huge number
or increase in behavioral health needs across our state.
So if anything that we do builds that community sense,
I think we're really doing more from this whole child
approach for kids and their families.
So this partnership is not just something
that we hope to talk about for an hour today,
but something that we invite all of your input on
and critique us, tell us, hey, it doesn't seem like
you're holding up your end of the bargain.
Can you do more?
Can't you think a little bit more flexibly?
And we'll do the same to you.
We each have our rigid ways of thinking about things.
And frankly, that rigidity is what probably gets
in the way of our collaboration the most.
So I don't mean to take the final word in any way,
but more an invitation to continue this conversation
in meaningful ways down the road.
Well, we appreciate it so much.
It's a hugely important initiative.
And Mark, I know we've been talking about this
for many months, how to bring the systems together.
I think it's wonderful to see the step being taken.
And we really appreciate you and Melissa joining us.
We'll have a chance after lunch to re-engage
with our community schools team and talk more
about the connections that can be made there.
Thanks so much.
Take care.
Thank you all, be well.
And I will announce that the rest of us can go to lunch.
It is about 12.16, so we'll come back at about 12.45.
We'll see you then.
Leave your, don't leave the meeting,
just turn off your camera and your microphone.
Thank you.
Welcome back.
Board members, we need to reestablish a quorum,
so Brooks is going to call the roll.
President Darlin Hammond.
Here.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillin.
Here.
Member Olken.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Here.
Member Petillo-Bronson.
Member Porter.
Here.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Here.
Everyone is present.
Terrific, we are now going to continue
with the community schools item with a presentation
by the community schools
State Transformational Assistance Center.
We're going to hear from Dr. Navdeep Pirwal
of Alameda County Office of Education,
and Dr. Karen Hunter-Quartz of the UCLA Center
for Community Schooling.
Dr. Pirwal, please proceed.
Good afternoon, President Darlin Hammond
and board members.
On behalf of our State Transformational Assistance Center,
or STAC, I want to thank both the state board
and Department of Education for the opportunity
to lead the statewide Transformational Assistance
for the California Community Schools Partnership Program.
During today's presentation, I will be sharing
our STAC journey and an update
on the Transformational Assistance
we have provided to date.
Then I'll be passing it off to my esteemed colleague,
Karen Hunter-Quartz,
Director at the UCLA Center of Community Schooling,
who will be sharing our Transformational Assistance
methodology and vision moving forward.
Our STAC journey begins with the team members
from our four partner organizations pictured here.
Aligned with the California Community Schools framework,
our STAC has been intentional
in fostering strong relationships among our team
through weekly meetings and in-person retreats.
During our time together, we have shared what brings us
to the social justice, equity enhancing work,
as well as identifying our assets
and opportunities for growth.
We have taken the time necessary
to engage in these processes in order to effectively lead
the transformation and redesign of schools in California
to be racially just, relationship centered,
and responsive to the needs of the whole child.
Early on during an opening activity
in one of our weekly meetings,
our team engaged in a discussion around
how the implementation
of the California Community Schools Partnership Program
promotes a process of social transformation
capable of disrupting inequities
rather than a siloed, top down approach to programming.
As a result, we made the shared decision
to change the term technical to transformational
and strive to help students, families, educators,
and community members acknowledge this opportunity
for authentic partnerships and reciprocal learning.
We believe that this program provides an opportunity
for coherence through the intentional alignment
of several whole child reform investments listed here.
Although this list is not exhaustive,
I wanted to acknowledge that the investments align
under the four pillars
of the California Community Schools framework
and that there's also alignment
within and among the pillars.
For example, the universal pre-kindergarten
and expanded learning opportunities program investments,
which align with the expanded learning time
and opportunities pillar, require plans
that include details on how the programs will work
in concert with each other,
encouraging the alignment of resources,
professional learning, and partnerships.
Another example is how the children
and youth behavior health initiative
that we heard about earlier today by Dr. Galli,
which aligns with the integrated student supports pillar,
shares key components
with a family and community engagement pillar
through the engagement of youth, families, and community
in the development and ongoing work of the program.
Our S-TAC is grounded in the belief
that working together collaboratively
with decision makers, implementers,
and recipients of these programs,
we can maximize the resources
and co-create sustainability plans
to support the diverse needs of children for years to come.
With the belief in the continuous learning
and improvement to redesign schools
to be places of transformation,
rooted in racially just, relationship centered,
and inclusive practices that demonstrate coherence,
this timeline illustrates our S-TAC's journey.
A few highlights include hosting
our first quarterly advisory board meeting in July,
which includes members from state
and nationally recognized organizations,
as well as launching our first webinar.
In August, we set into motion
our weekly collective learning space
and monthly community of transformative practice,
while establishing bi-weekly update
and calibration meetings with the CDE team.
In September, we engaged in our first monthly meeting
with the team members
from the California County Superintendents,
recognizing the key role of county offices
in supporting alignment and coherence
among local education agencies.
In October, our S-TAC team developed working subcommittees
focused on resources, communications, webinars,
communities of transformative practice, and data.
As we have been developing our own infrastructure
to ensure that our assistance is truly transformational,
we have been mindful of the importance
in being responsive to the needs of our partners.
So we have designed and facilitated an initial round
of transformational assistance highlighted,
and now I'll be sharing more about those.
Our webinars are a space where we encourage and welcome
planning and implementation grantees,
as well as families, students,
community partners, and school leaders.
Participants are provided opportunities to learn
about the California community school framework,
hear successes and challenges through stories shared
by community school implementers,
and take away tools and resources
for supporting planning and implementation.
The monthly community of transformative practice
is designed for members from county offices of education
to strategize ways to support grantees within their counties,
share expertise, and network with statewide colleagues
charged with the implementation of programs
that support the whole child.
And finally, the weekly collective learning space
is designed for planning and implementation grantees
who have questions or a desire to network
with colleagues on a regular basis.
The webinars, communities of transformative practice,
and collective learning spaces
have supported the development of relationships
and provided our STAC team the opportunity
to learn about planning and implementation needs,
which we continue to respond to
through our transformational assistance.
And now, Karen will share our strategic vision
moving forward.
Thank you, Nav, and good afternoon,
President Darling-Hammond and board members.
As Dr. Pirwell has shared, our STAC team
has been developing an initial set of learning opportunities
for grantees and counties.
Alongside this work, we've been meeting as a team
to flesh out this logic model
to capture the methodology of RTA,
the strategies and expected outcomes that guide our center.
So traditional logic models often start
with a problem or gap statement,
but our advisory board recommended that we reframe this
to focus on the opportunity we have right now
to redesign schools as relationship-centered,
democratic, and just spaces where students, educators,
families, and communities can thrive.
The California Community Schools Partnership Program
is the evidence-based program
designed to embrace this opportunity.
The framework starts with the four pillars
described in the field setting 2017 review of research
on community schools,
but it goes far beyond the four pillars.
It's a vision based on the science of learning
and development, the conditions young people need to thrive
and the work of classroom teachers.
It also lifts up the core commitments
that animate the movement, building on assets,
advancing racial justice, culturally proficient instruction
and authentic shared leadership.
And finally, the framework highlights the proven practices
that community schools use to propel social transformation.
So this is very much a transformational framework,
and we've tried to design a set of TA strategies
to integrate the allied reform movements
that Nav referenced and that we heard about this morning
and support statewide understanding
and commitment to the framework.
These strategies include communities
of transformative practice, webinars,
a collective learning space, study tours,
digital commons and resources,
and a deep dive strategy that I'll explain in more depth.
Key to our methodology is a focus on data, stories
and community-based measures to help grantees learn
and improve along this journey.
And as you can see in the last two columns
of this logic model,
we expect the California Community Schools
Partnership Program implementation
to lead to community agency and wellbeing,
redesign schools and improved outcomes on multiple measures.
So next slide, please.
To support this very ambitious vision,
we know schools, districts and counties
need tools to guide implementation
and track their progress.
So this slide maps out our process
to operationalize the state's framework
in what we're calling an implementation growth chart.
Our STAC team made the shared decision
to use this language instead of implementation rubric
to emphasize continuous learning and development.
We have been reviewing and synthesizing
implementation science resources,
as well as frameworks and rubrics developed
by local, state and national organizations.
Later this month, we will be sharing a first draft
of a set of foundational concepts and benchmarks
to guide implementation.
And we know how important it is to get these concepts
and benchmarks right, so over the next few months,
we will organize multiple opportunities
for feedback and revision.
One of our TA strategies, next slide, please,
is to take a series of deep dives
into local implementation contexts
to support learning and document the infrastructure
it takes to develop and sustain community schools.
Research on the science of implementation
cautions us, right, against lifting up sites of innovation
without paying attention to the systems and structures
that will sustain change and ensure coherence
at every level, from the school, to the district,
to the county, to the region.
For this reason, we are planning to partner
with three deep dive implementation teams
each year of the program.
In six years, we expect to have 18 diverse
implementation contexts to help us chart the path forward
and sustain community schools throughout the state.
We will work with these teams to document challenges,
systems, process and outcome data,
including local stories of transformation
and school redesign.
Data from these deep dives will be used to identify
what needs to be learned next.
So think of this as a large scale plan
for continuous statewide learning.
To identify the first three sites in January,
our team is currently analyzing and coding
the cohort one implementation proposals,
and we will be conducting follow-up data collection.
So staying on the top of data,
our STAC team is developing a multiple measures framework
to capture the many dimensions of social transformation.
This will include data generated
by the implementation growth chart
to help grantees learn and improve.
It'll also include support for community-based measures
that lift up outcomes local communities value
and use to track their growth.
For example, at the UCLA Community School,
they have collected biliteracy data for the last 12 years
to inform the development of their K-12
dual language program.
And at the district level,
the LA Unified has a graduate portfolio
to capture students' growth and development over time.
We're also very mindful that we are accountable
to the public for ensuring this historic investment
in public education is transformative.
To build coherence across programs and agencies
that support community schools,
such as health and social welfare,
we will be convening a cross-sector
multiple measures working group
to integrate accountability systems
from a whole child, whole community perspective.
We also look forward to the opportunity to support
the statewide evaluation
of the California Community Schools Partnership Program.
Next slide, please.
So we're excited by today's announcement
of the eight proposed
Regional Technical Assistance Centers.
Many of the people and partners in these RTACs
have connections and experience
working with members of our team.
We know they bring enormous expertise
and insider knowledge of their own regional contexts,
their local control accountability plans,
fiscal oversight system charter schools and county schools.
Next slide, please.
So as this timeline maps out,
we're going to be reaching out to each RTAC team
right away to further develop our relationships
and start planning together,
including a 2023 Statewide Summer Institute.
We're also preparing to release a set of resources,
including the implementation growth chart
and a set of guides and tools
to be housed on a digital commons
and widely shared in different learning spaces.
In January, we'll launch our deep dive strategy
to learn with and from three local implementation teams,
which we're calling our first cohort
community school fellows.
And in the new year,
we'll also convene our cross sector
multiple measures working group
to begin to integrate process and outcome measures.
So I hope this presentation has given you
a helpful overview of our S-TAC journey to date.
I'd like to end by sharing a little bit
about why we're doing this work.
So each Wednesday morning,
we start our S-TAC team meetings
with a jam board visioning activity
to help us reimagine California's public education system
rooted in our own team's strengths and experiences
combating structural racism and poverty.
As a multiracial community,
we have shared our hearts and our lived experiences
as educators, social workers, engineers, immigrants,
students, researchers, principals, farm workers,
parents and community organizers.
We lift up ideas and examples
from across the state and nation,
knowing there is enormous collective wisdom
to guide this journey.
This photo is from the UCLA community school where I work
and I'm continually inspired by educators
who lift up student voice and agency.
Last week, I had an opportunity
to visit another school garden,
the Magnolia Agriscience Community Center
in Anaheim, California.
And I am delighted that their team is here today
to further inspire learning about the promise
of community schooling.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Is that the conclusion of your presentation, Dr. Quartz?
Yes, it is.
Okay, so I want to move us along then
to the Anaheim Union High School District.
Superintendent Matsuda and his team are here.
So please begin.
Thank you so much, Chair of the Garden of Manhattan.
The State Board of Education
is really an honor to be part of this.
The State Board of Education is really an honor
to be presenting.
Or is, Jared, are you ready to go?
Yes, I just need to share so I can share.
There we go.
So now I'm gonna share mine.
Okay.
Give me one second, we pull it up.
I want to also thank Superintendent Tony Thurmond
and Steve Zimmer.
They've been to our district twice
in the last couple months
to see what's going on.
And I really appreciate our thought partners at UCLA
really putting theory to practice
and really being great thought partners
on challenging our own thinking.
But it's also nice to be affirmed
in terms of seeing theory in action in the AUHSC.
Finally, I wanted to really start this presentation
about the importance of the outcap.
Can you go to the next one, please?
And put a shout out to Governor Brown and Mike Kurtz
for and up in Linda Darling-Hammond
and all those who were involved in creating the outcap.
The L, as everybody knows, is local control.
And I think that's really an important concept here
because in terms of shared governance
and bringing in all the stakeholders,
including the parents and teachers
and especially the student voices early on,
I think that was huge
because we all know that we have,
those of us who are fortunate to have them,
part of the $4.1 billion investment
by the governor and state of California
for community schools,
we know that that money is limited five years.
And it's really gonna be up to us to ensure
that we have agency with our community.
And our goal is to institutionalize this
through the outcap process and the general fund five years.
So it's really gonna be up to us
and the community school recipients
to ensure that we have our community support
to make sure that that happens.
Next slide, please.
And I wanna put a shout out to Dr. Goley too
who really informed us on the challenges of mental health,
which on the ground, certainly the schools are dealing with.
And the challenge really is about teaching
for the whole child of mine,
as Linda Dwellingham and others have long really tried
to promote the role of the teacher
and the role of instruction
and bringing the challenges of community schools
into the classroom.
I think that's what we're attempting to do here.
And I think what you're gonna see
that we have made progress here.
One of the, I think, logistical challenges
of dealing with mental health
is just the amount of bandwidth that schools have
and communities have.
We're grateful for our 25 social workers
that we funded through the outcap
prior to the, mostly prior to the pandemic,
as well as our 85 counselors
who and our social workers generally
are working on the back end of this.
But let's not forget, we have 1,300 teachers
in the state of California, that's 250,000 teachers
who could be on the front end
if we can really connect deeper learning,
issues of deeper learning, we call it the five Cs,
to the community to give teachers the opportunity
to give students and challenge them
with the high learning and problem solving
in our communities.
Because there's no question that this generation of kids
has the most severe challenges.
We developed a three drivers,
we call it the Career Preparedness Systems Framework.
That's what all of it led to.
And it's really the three drivers
who are the soft skills, we call it the five Cs,
which I think the state board knows
that four of those Cs are already integrated
and approved in the state frameworks,
communication, creativity, collaboration,
critical thinking, we added the fifth C,
which is compassion, building a sense of empathy.
The other drivers, technical skills,
which are the partnerships with dual credit
with our community colleges, our CTE pathways,
and to provide those pathways, meaningful pathways to jobs.
The third driver, which is probably the most important
that people talk about,
is the sense of agency purpose and voice.
And a lot of this on the right side you see
has led to these cutting edge pathways in agency,
from AI to biotech, cyber security,
we even have an incubator lab.
So what the CPSF is is developing a new North Star
for education based on flat governance and shared leadership.
And all of this led to the development
of the Magnolia Agro Science Community Center,
and led by a teacher, led by a group of teachers
across the district and across content areas.
So at this point, I'd like to introduce our lead teacher,
Dr. Sabina Jocumus.
Thank you, Superintendent Matsuda.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I've been teaching science
in the Anaheim Union High School District for 16 years,
and I'm currently a teacher on special assignment
overseeing the build of the Magnolia Agro Science
Community Center,
and also the curriculum opportunities there.
So we call it the MAC Farm,
and our farm is a 2.5 acre urban farm
built on AUHSD property.
So I'm going to address how we have authentically engaged
our communities through this specific project.
As we all know, the pandemic opened our eyes
to the inequities in our low income communities.
And our district saw a need,
not only for access to fresh fruits and vegetables,
but also a need for education around nutrition,
how local food systems work,
and urban agriculture and climate justice.
So like so many of our school campuses,
we had some vacant land that was not being utilized,
and we saw a potential for its use.
So in July, 2021,
our AUHSD Board approved COVID relief funds
to be used in an innovative way to build the farm,
and also to fund the salaries of two full-time farmers.
So I think the MAC Farm has a model of instruction
that's pretty different than what you would see
at most traditional school gardens.
It was decided early on
that we would not have a standalone class
where students could sign up for a traditional course
during the day, the school day.
Instead, we utilized our educational partners at UC Irvine
to help us create curriculum for students
to experience a field trip setting at curriculum,
and then also curriculum for traditional classrooms.
So to date, we have had over 2,000 students
from across the district
come to the Magnolia Agriculture Community Center Farm
to learn about regenerative farming systems,
healthy ecosystems, and also growing food
in a changing climate.
So in the classroom, we also have teachers
who teach all different subjects
that are using civic engagement as a driver
to help students create action projects
that will engage their communities
around issues of food access and climate change.
And I'd like to just briefly talk about a specific example
of student learning that occurred this past summer
with the support of our city of Anaheim,
we were able to employ AUHSD students.
That means they actually got paid to work on our farm.
We interviewed students from across the district
and their job entailed new work skills experience
utilizing our MAC farm.
So these students were taught business modeling skills,
marketing strategies, regenerative urban farming practices,
and also community outreach tools.
So our AUHSD students were able to monetize
their business model of selling produce boxes
to communities in need,
which also gave them the skills that they would need
to improve a local economy when they graduate.
So this is just one example of a program at the MAC farm
that happened during the traditional school day
or traditional summer school time
where students have access to innovative curriculum
taught by teacher leaders.
Thank you.
So what Samina described as a new way of doing school,
no longer is it just happening in one classroom
or even one school.
Our concept of community schools
is widening the aperture of access for students
to these amazing opportunities by our teachers
and also through our partners with community colleges
and the four year institutions
as well as over 90 business and nonprofit partners.
And it's all centered around the student
developing 21st century skills, the technical skills,
and the use of voice and purpose.
It's really, really, I think an amazing testament
to the collaboration and shared leadership of teachers,
parents, and district and students
working together for this new vision.
At this point, I'd like to introduce
one of our parent leaders
involved in our community school steering committee
and she's just, she'll speak to the work
of the community school steering committee.
Thank you.
Jessie Alvarez.
Hi, thank you.
So again, my name is Jessie Alvarez
and I am a parent member
of our district community school steering committee.
We have built our model and approach
on collaborative shared leadership
and that really makes this work different
from how we've traditionally seen school systems
operate in the past.
And as was emphasized earlier,
it's what makes this truly transformational work.
Our 20 member district steering committee
is composed of union leadership, district leadership,
representatives from our community school coordinators
and community school teacher leads,
parents, students, and community partners.
We bring our expertise and insights
to help create and support systems at our school sites.
The meetings are co-chaired by the union and the district.
We are intentional about making sure
we are including the voices
of all of our education partners
and at the district committee level
and at our site level
so that we are truly representing the communities we serve.
Our community schools approach
began with a small initial pilot grant we received
that funded our first two community school coordinators
that has led us to our shared leadership model journey.
This began with a grant through NEA and our teachers union
and is what fueled the district steering committee
to develop community school teacher leads
at each of our sites.
This shared leadership model isn't just on paper.
It's put into action with every discussion
and step we take as a committee.
For instance, today, I'm a parent on our committee.
I'm not an employee of the district
and I have no formal training in educational leadership.
But this model gives every group,
including the parents, agency to co-lead
and be part of the decision-making.
The district trusts our expertise as parents
and sees us as assets to our schools.
I'm also a product of our district
having attended both of our flagship community schools,
Sycamore Junior High and Anaheim High School.
My son is currently a freshman at Anaheim High School.
In looking at continuing to build more partnerships
and sustainability, we recently presented
at the Anaheim City Council meeting
with speakers from each of our education partners.
Pictured here is Akali Huerta,
our community school coordinator
at Sycamore Junior High School,
myself and my amazing niece, Emma,
who is a student leader at Sycamore Junior High.
She spoke about the importance of this model
and the positive impact it has
and will continue to have on her and her peers at Sycamore.
We were able to engage members of the council
in a way we have not seen before.
We were truly interested in the work we are doing
and unanimously passed a resolution
in support of community schools.
This resolution is important
because it will allow members of the city council
and city staff to advocate for programs
and services that support our community school efforts.
As a parent, I'm deeply invested in the success
of not just my sons,
but of all of our students within our district.
We see the challenges that our students are facing daily
and we have to school differently than we have in the past.
Our students are the future
and we need to all come together as a community of partners
to ensure their success.
Thank you, Jessie.
I'm gonna go ahead and take over.
I'm Dr. Jared Fried.
I proudly serve as the assistant superintendent
of educational services for our great district.
And I wanna thank Jessie for her leadership and great work.
And I also wanna give a shout out to our steering committee.
They're actually meeting right now as we speak,
probably watching this,
but they're just an amazing group of people
who are leading our district through this journey
and helping us navigate
in the implementation of our community school approach.
So I wanna give them all a big kudos and thanks,
heartfelt thank you.
These core values,
in addition to the four pillars
that we have to examine closely
in terms of how to really build out our community school
approach, we also look at our district's core values
and making sure that all the decisions we make
and the work that we do are connected
to what we deeply believe in.
And through this presentation and also throughout my part
and what I'm gonna be speaking about,
I'm gonna make some connections to these values
and how it drives our work.
As Mike talked about this concept of shared leadership
in the CPSF or the career preparedness systems framework,
we really have taken a heart in that one pillar
that it talks about expanded
and enriching learning opportunities.
We really do believe that for the sustainability
of this grant, if and when the money should dry up,
that it's gonna be the work that we've done
to build capacity in our teachers
and integrate these concepts in our classroom.
And Dr. Darling-Hammond, you mentioned this earlier
when our earlier presentation took place.
That's really where the transformation takes place.
We couldn't agree more.
So we have invested monies.
It was part of our LCAP,
but also part of the community school efforts
to really build capacity in our teacher leaders.
So we're looking at the way that we approach teaching
and learning to integrate local, statewide
and national issues into the classroom
while connecting it back to the content.
So we're not sacrificing the traditional content
all the while building these skillsets
in our students and in our families
so that this work is sustained when this grant is over
or if it doesn't over,
we're just gonna continue to grow out this model
and continue to meet the needs
and celebrate the assets of our community.
So this is an example of how that might look.
Now, also, I know that you may not see this perfectly,
but this is just an example
of the systems not silos approach.
We really do believe in creating structures and systems.
So again, this work is independent
upon one person or two people.
If someone leaves, the work can continue.
And so baked into our learning organization
and the systems and structures
are our community school structures.
So you can see in this model,
we have our district steering committee.
We have our community school coordinator structures.
We have the structures for our community school
teacher leads in the work that we're doing
across our system.
So this is really essential for us.
So again, it's that shared practice,
shared leadership model where we're all working together
and not in silos.
Now, how do we know that this is working?
Because as Mike said earlier,
we've been doing some of this work
prior to this grant opportunity.
And now we're being able to take that
and really strengthen the work that we've begun.
This is just some data that just shares
the work that we're doing.
We know is making an impact on our students
and our families.
Without going over all the data specifics,
I know you can see it.
I do wanna highlight the state seal of civic engagement,
because that's what we're looking to bring
into our classrooms each and every day
that allow our students to engage in the content,
develop those skills,
but also look at the applied learning
and problem solving that we wanna develop in them.
And the first year that the state seal was given,
we had 2,400 plus students earn the state seal.
That's 45% of all the state seals
that were given across the state.
Now in the year two, we're now over 2,800 students.
So we're really proud that we're integrating
this approach into our classroom.
We have 17 California democracy schools.
So that means every single student on that campus
gets to experience a civic engagement project.
It's not just learning about civic heads,
but it's applying it through action.
So we're really proud of the work that we're doing.
And this is part of our community school approach.
And then here's some other data.
As you know, we have an articulated agreement
with our higher education partners, UC Irvine,
Cal State Fullerton, Cypress, and Fullerton College.
And although this is UC Irvine's data,
the data looks comparable
across those other college partners.
And we're seeing that our students
who are enrolling at these institutions
are not just outperforming in terms of their GPA,
but they are also out persisting.
They have a higher retention rate
than students across the state
who enter these institutions.
And when we talk to our higher ed deans
and vice presidents of instruction and presidents,
they tell us time and time again,
as a result of our drivers,
the result that we give our students purpose and agency,
that we make sure education works for them
and not the other way around.
And that we're activating their voice
and we're connected to the 5C.
So it's just another tribute
that the work that we're doing is making the impact
that we would hope that it would make
with and for our students.
And then lastly, we've been asked to talk a little bit
of how you as a State Board of Education
can support our efforts in the way that we implement
our community school approach through tactical assistance.
And I love what Karen said earlier,
our friend and partner at UCLA,
it's not tactical assistance,
we see this as transformational support.
It really is helping us redesign our schools
so that way it can work for our students
and for our communities.
We believe if you could help remove some of the red tape
or the bureaucracy that schools often are faced with.
So many of our districts who have asked us
they want to do this work,
they're often focused on teaching to a test
that doesn't promote the kind of student
that they're looking to become
to be able to succeed in life beyond school.
How can we liberate our sites, liberate our teachers
so that way they really do feel compelled and supported
in really teaching to meet the needs
and the assets of our students.
Through this end, we've talked about
one of the things that we could have support with
is through the creation of a ninth element
on their college career indicator on the dashboard.
I love how our friends at UCLA talked about
this growth model.
Well, in our district and I know in so many other districts,
they have capstone programs
or graduate or senior profiles
where it's not worksheets in basic assignments.
These are performance task assessments
and project-based learning assignments
connected to the work that students are engaged in
in classroom every day where they're reflecting
upon the skills that they're learning,
the content of the learning
and how they're finding their place in this role.
That could be a part of that structure
that allows schools to really focus
on what we believe to be the right drivers
in our North Star.
This is applied learning and problem solving at its best,
which you saw an example of what's happening
at our Mac Farm.
We also would love the opportunities
as our friends at UCLA also talked about
to create these innovation zones
or these innovation spaces
where through those leadership partners,
we can connect with other districts
who are engaging in this work,
where we can learn from each other
and share our best practices,
but we can also be vulnerable together
and share some of the challenges
and use these thought partners to help grow
and strengthen the gaps that we might have
within our system.
We also wanna, just before we end,
thank again our thought partners at UCLA.
They've been a tremendous help to our team.
I know Karen personally, along with Marisa,
has been really helpful in supporting
our district steering committee team
and the work that's happening.
I also wanna thank you, the State Board of Education,
as we close, for this amazing, amazing opportunity
that you have given us in districts and schools
throughout our state.
It is our hope that we can take advantage
of this transformational opportunity that you have given
to really make sure that we first accelerate, celebrate
and build upon the many assets and strengths
that our schools, our staff, our students
and our families bring to the table each and every day,
but also use this money to leverage
to close the gaps that might exist.
So we're really working towards that needle
and moving towards equity and justice.
So with that, I wanna thank you for this opportunity.
I'll turn it back over to Dr. Darlene Hammond
and our team is happy to answer
any questions you might have.
I think you're muted.
I am.
Thank you for that inspiring presentation.
I know we all really appreciated it.
And I see a hand going up,
but we do have a little bit more presentation
coming from the State Department.
And then I think we can turn to questions at that time.
So I'm hoping that the Anaheim team
can stay with us a little bit longer.
Is that okay?
Great.
And we really appreciate all that you presented.
So we're gonna turn back to our CDE colleagues
for the final part of the presentation.
I think Steve Zimmer and Pete Callis
are going to help us through that.
And then we'll open up to everyone
for questions and comments.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Dr. Darlene Hammond and board members.
I wanna thank all of our presenters today.
Superintendent Matsuda, Dr. Freed, Ms. Alvarez
and Dr. Giacomis, this is an inspiring presentation.
From the Anaheim Union, our S-TAC partners,
Dr. Purwall and Dr. Hunter Quartz.
The work as you can see is accelerating
and we're so grateful to the S-TAC for their partnership
for the integrated work that they're doing.
And of course to Dr. Ghali and CYBHI director,
Melissa Safford-Jones for really bringing us
an incredible possibility of what can be
when these two historic initiatives
work together synergistically.
I'm joined today by our division director, Pete Callis,
our senior advisor to the superintendent, Brooklyn Williams.
And the message, I apologize,
there's a little bit of a shadow on my screen.
There's something, the camera's malfunctioning a little bit,
but I don't want you to think
that there's anything ominous.
The news around community schools is positive
and is inspiring.
You saw an incredible example here today
with the Anaheim Union, the superintendent and I have,
Superintendent Thurmond and I have had the chance to visit.
Twice this year, we visited Dr. Escobedo and I
and the superintendent visited the school in Vista Unified
just a couple of weeks ago.
And we are hearing from schools
and LEAs throughout the state.
I want you to know that the division is happening.
It is being implemented.
We have all throughout our states teams of families
of staff members, of students doing assets
and strength assessments and gap analysis.
We have a shared decision-making councils coming together
and we have rich and deep and robust
and different positions about changing our school climates.
Those are happening 458 school sites throughout the state
and with implementation grants,
172 LEAs with planning grants.
And today is the next step in that process.
We're going to ask you to the board to approve
two critical elements of our movement forward.
First, the recommendation to approve
our updated administrative plan.
I will note, I'll explain this in detail in a later slide.
There is a slight revision to that administrative plan
that I will explain related to our COE allocations.
I'll explain that in the last slide.
So we'll ask you for approval
of the updated administration plan.
And also critically, we'll recommend the approval
of the grants for the regional technical assistance centers.
And right now I'm gonna hand it over with my great thanks
to division director Pete Callis
who has been our partner in implementing this program.
Pete.
Federal funding to administer
the California Community Schools Partnership Program
for existing California community schools.
This was expanded.
The program for community schools was expanded
and continued with CDE receiving over $3.1 million
in 2021-22 state budget to expand
the California Community Schools Partnership Program
for new schools and for existing community schools
through planning grants and implementation grants.
Moving into 2022-23, the legislature allocated
additional funding for the CCSPP
which includes an additional $1.1 plus billion
to be used beginning in 2023-24
for additional implementation grants and extension grants.
Another $2.5 million for formative evaluation
in 2023 through 2027, $140 million
for community office of education coordination grants
to support LEAs within their county
with implementation of their community school grant programs.
$350,000 for an interim technical assistance contract.
$742,000 annually for a community schools office within CDE.
And finally, the program was extended from 2028-29
to 2030-31 through the end of that year.
And then Steve, back to you.
Yes, so thank you, Pete.
And today, as noted, we'll ask you to approve
the applications for the Regional Technical Assistance Center,
Fresno County Office of Education,
LA County Office of Education, Monterey County,
Sacramento County, San Bernardino County,
San Diego County, Santa Clara County,
and Shasta County Office of Education.
And I'll refer board members to the item
where we've listed not only the regions
that we developed and rationale for those regions,
but also the partnerships that are part of these RTAGs.
And so it will give you a little bit more information
about the RTAGs in the item,
but these are, we feel very confident in the RTAGs
and confident in the recommendation
that we're making today that the work of the STAC
that Dr. Purwall and Dr. Hunter-Courts outlined today
can be implemented with fidelity on the ground
with these demonstrated in their application
knowledge of the issues on the ground in the region
with the great diversity of our states.
We'll ask for your approval of these RTAG awards today.
Next slide please.
And so we'll also talk through the administration plan
and that you will also find in greater detail in the item.
This plan includes an interim technical assistance plan
through the STAC, extending our contract with WestEd
and our team at STDE.
I'll talk about this in a little bit more detail.
The way that the calendar has aligned
and we are extremely grateful to the STAC for jumping in
and being immediately just accelerating that on-ramp
to their involvement.
We anticipate the same will happen with our RTAGs,
but we understand for this first cohort,
it was essential to have
an interim technical assistance plan.
I'll talk to you about the County Office
of Education Coordination Grants.
And again, as I mentioned,
we're going to make a slight adjustment to our asks.
We need to re-examine a few fine points of the data
on our figures there,
but I'll talk to you about the importance of this grant.
And then we have two RFAs that are coming up.
We released the RFA for the planning grant
and the due date for that,
the next round of the planning grant will be December 20th.
And then we will release in January the due date,
we will release the second round implementation grant.
Also part of our administration process
is the formative evaluation RFA,
which will also be issued in the first quarter
in January of 2023.
And then our outreach efforts with which Brooklyn Williams
we'll discuss in a little bit more detail,
but it is our goal that we are able to reach areas
across the state where there are high levels
of qualification and to date, lower levels of participation.
And next slide, please.
This is what I spoke about in terms
of the interim technical assistance plan.
Very important to us to ensure
that as we are developing this program
between this transformative assistance program
that Dr. Prowall discussed
and Dr. Hawthorne of course elaborated on,
that there is a robust interim technical assistance plan
for this cohort.
To date that has consisted of three elements.
One is webinars that have been held by weekly,
co-hosted by ourselves
and the Alameda County Office of Education.
They've been very well attended.
And I've noted in the webinars,
usually it's 400, 500, even more than 500 participants
in these webinars.
We've established a call center and email box system
between ourselves and ACOE.
We will be, as we extend our contract with West Ed,
West Ed will provide additional bandwidth for us
on both the call center and this email box.
We meet weekly together as a team,
both Alameda County and ourselves as a CDE team
to calibrate our RTA responses.
And to tell you the truth,
we're in constant contact in between
those calibration meetings to ensure
that we are getting both accurate,
but also to our cohort one
planning and implementation grantees who are reaching out.
And then the last element that we are bringing together
now in anticipation for some more detailed questions.
And particularly as the implementation grant is released,
we're working on interdisciplinary guidance teams,
meaning not only interdisciplinary CDE, ACOE and West Ed,
but interdisciplinary in terms of the expertise
that we're bringing into these teams
from each of our respective agencies.
What we hope is that we bring a team together
based on the question or concern
that's happening with the cohort one grantee.
And we're able through that interdisciplinary process
to get them all the assistance that they need
to reach their implementation goals.
I'm gonna hand it to Pete for the next slide.
Thanks, Steve.
So as noted in a previous slide,
the legislature allocated up to $140 million
for county offices of education
to receive coordination grants.
And those were county offices serving at least
two qualifying entities
that are receiving a community schools grant,
whether it's a planning grant or an implementation grant.
County offices of education will assist grantees
with coordinating county level governmental
nonprofit community-based organizations
and other external partnerships
to support the implementation of their CCSPP grants.
County offices will have a community schools liaison
to coordinate with CDE
and the respective regional technical assistance centers.
The county office of education coordination grant awards
are based on the number of community schools funded
in the county and the number of students
enrolled at those schools.
The allocations will be between 200,000 and 500,000 annually.
Additional allocations will happen
after cohort two planning and implementation grantees
are determined.
So on the coordination grant model,
we built the allocation model
based on the spread of enrollment at school sites
and the spread of school sites within each county.
In the future, we'll need to revisit this
based on how many additional county offices of educations
will come online with their additional
community school grantees within their county.
So the initial allocations that will be going out
were based on this model that we put together.
It could change in the future,
just depending on how many county offices come on
and their enrollments and the number of schools
within their county.
Okay, Brooklyn, I'll pass this over to Brooklyn Williams.
All right, thank you so much.
Pete, good afternoon, board members and community.
As stated, my name is Brooklyn Williams
and I serve as senior advisor to Superintendent Thurman.
It has been an honor to be a part of the team
supporting the California Community Schools
Partnership Program.
And I'm very happy to be with you all this afternoon
to review grant making information.
As you can see, the RFA for round two
of the planning grant was released yesterday
with the plan of the State Board of Education
approving grantees in March of 2023,
and the funding released in the winter of 22
and the spring of 23.
The RFA for round two for the implementation grants
will be released January 23rd of next year
with State Board approval in May
and those funds going out in the spring of 23.
Our outreach plan is both top down and ground up.
CDE will host a series of webinars
on Monday, November 7th and Wednesday, November 9th,
as well as an early childhood education specific webinar
on November 14th and another general webinar on December 6th.
We are engaging with our community partners
to support with outreach on the ground
to help increase interest from families, communities
and local districts and also awareness
of the webinars CDE will be hosting.
And with that, I will turn it back
to Deputy Superintendent Zimmer.
Thank you so much, Brooklyn.
The final piece of the implementation plan
involves the formative evaluation.
And this is also an RFA that we will be releasing
in January and as community schools is transformative.
We are taking great care
and the legislature is taking great care.
I know the Board has taken great care
in ensuring that our evaluation process
reflects the transformative nature
of what we need, of the ambition and the goal of CCSPP.
So we will look at outcome data,
including measurements of student wellbeing, engagement,
and including but not limited to measures of attendance,
but also ways to measure school climate.
Analysis of the services being provided
and changes that are taking place in schools,
areas of progress and challenges to be addressed,
to meet the goals of the CCSPP framework,
including but not limited to the quality of education,
the framework, including but not limited
to the effective integration of instructional
and student support services,
support for authentic student and educator
and family engagement,
or also looking for evidence and best practices
and successful strategies
for integrating multiple funding systems
to meet the LEA's school improvement goals
identified in their outcome.
The first date for a formative assessment
and annual formative assessment
will be the end of the next calendar year, December 31st.
And that once you know,
this is a conversation that we've begun to engage
with the STAP and several of our university
and top partners on this.
We look forward to reporting back to the Board
about our progress in this area.
And I've promised to get to our final slide
where I just wanna go over what we are looking
on the Board today.
First, the approval of the selection and recommendation
of the regional technical assistance centers.
And then I'll read to you directly
what we're asking for in terms
of our updated administrative plan.
We're asking the Board's approval
of the updated administrative plan.
We are also asking to delegate CDE in consultation
with and subject to the approval of the Executive Director
of the State Board of Education
on our ability to build a final list
of the 2022-23 County Office of a Coronation Grant
allocations consistent with this administrative plan.
These awards shall be posted for public review and comment
filed to the posting of a final list.
The final list shall be posted on November 18th.
I would just say we had an unexpected technical problem
with our data set that may have caused a few errors
both in allocation amounts and determining
whether a COE had the necessary two grantee threshold.
We believe that we can reconcile this with this delegation
reporting in collaboration with our partners.
And I'll just wrap by saying that I appreciate,
and I know the Superintendent appreciates
the just incredible collaboration in this department.
I appreciate the just incredible collaboration,
the incredible work first of Pete Callis,
Lisa Reimers, Brooklyn Williams,
and Deanna Niebuhr, whose term of service with us has ended
but was a great contributor to this process.
But also our collaboration with State Board of Ed staff,
particularly Roger Osarro and Jessica Haltz
who have been our partners on this
in every step of the way.
It truly has been a collaborative spirit
to which we work on this that is extended to the ARTAC
and very competent will extend to our work with the ARTAC.
And if the work of the Anaheim Union
and the schools we've been able to see to date
is an indicator,
the investment that has been made by this board
by our government in the future,
we truly do have a chance
with the California Community Schools Partnership Program
to support other schools.
Superintendent's vision, I know,
President Darling-Hammond's vision as well.
So thank you for the opportunity to present today
and welcome your questions.
Thank you so much.
That was a very rich presentation.
I know people have a lot of comments and questions.
We do want to open the public comment line.
And so if we could put the public,
there it is, the public comment slide.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item may do so by calling the telephone number
and using the access code provided
on the slide that is shown now.
While we're waiting, I'm gonna ask our liaison member,
Escobedo, if he has any initial comments.
And then if there are clarifying questions from the board
for any of the people who've presented,
we can take those.
Then we'll take public comments,
then we'll come back for a full board discussion.
So that's kind of the order of operations.
From here, Member Escobedo.
Thank you, Dr. Hammond.
I truly believe that every system is perfectly designed
to achieve the results it gets
and I also know that the system that is being created
and we're voting on with these regional techs
and how they're gonna support districts and schools
at a local level is really crucial.
And I look forward to seeing those results
and hearing what those outcomes are.
And I'm really grateful that we will be hiring
an entity to do that.
And so this really is a start of creating this system,
the system that can, that has a great potential
to transform our great state of California
and transform teaching and learning
at a significant number of school sites
throughout our state.
Yes, I would just add to that.
I have the opportunity to hear about what folks are doing
between the board meetings who are involved
with both the technical assistance functions,
the work at the department
and those in the community school grantees themselves.
And it is quite inspiring to see the level of engagement,
the level of thinking, the transformational frame
that is being brought to the work.
So we know that this is an enormous lift
at a time when people are already very stretched
in the state, but we appreciate all of the effort going in
and the good signals that are already apparent
in so many communities.
And especially appreciate the work of the staff
that has been nonstop and intense
ever since this process got going.
We have clarifying questions now.
So I'm gonna ask folks to keep their questions
to clarifying types of questions.
And then when you wanna dig in on the discussion,
we'll come back to that after public comment.
Vice President Glover-Woods, you can kick us off.
Thank you, and I'm quite excited to engage
in our discussion after a public comment.
This is, again, quite exciting.
My clarifying question is in regards to the RTATs
that were listed in the board item.
I noticed that Monterey County Office of Education
did not have any formal partners listed.
I just wanted to know who their partners are.
Yeah, thank you, Board Member Glover-Woods
for elevating that.
We met with Monterey County to discuss that very issue
prior to our recommendation.
They had not formed formal partnerships
prior to their application.
But we were able to, in the discussion with them,
just they extensively listed the partners
that they were working with.
And it really was a kind of,
well, I won't say misunderstanding,
but it was how they interpreted the question
in the application that led them
to not formally list the partners.
And I can get you a list of their partners,
but they did include CBOs.
They did include other components
on the county support system,
as well as other county offices of education
in their region.
So we left them very reassured.
We're just kind of governed by the confines
of how to kind of legally list this.
It wasn't in their application
in the same way it was in others.
And so we did have that meeting.
I want to share with the board.
We did have that meeting to clarify
and left that meeting very reassured
of the partnerships that they have on the ground.
Thank you.
Thank you for the question.
Appreciate that.
Member McQuillan.
Yes, thank you.
Thank you for these presentations.
Also very exciting,
the rollout of the community schools.
Question of clarification on the TA centers.
Will each, I see Shasta County,
maybe the rural connection.
Will each of those centers have like model programs
or schools that others can say,
hey, this is working here.
Come look at this model.
Thank you.
Yeah, that is absolutely the intent.
Both from the regional TAC,
but also as Dr. Quartz outlined, very intentional.
We've been involved in these conversations
with the S-TAC as well,
creating these models,
creating opportunities for virtual visits
and actual visits.
I know that the S-TAC will be,
and I want to take Dr. Perot's thunder,
I know the S-TAC will be taking a tour, so to speak,
after this approval process
of making sure that they are learning on the ground
what are the models in the different regions
and different areas of our state.
So board member, that is exactly the intention.
Thanks for that.
Terrific.
I'm not seeing any other hands for clarifying questions.
So with that, I think we'll move to public comment.
If there's any public comment for this item,
we encourage people who are calling in
to state your name and affiliation for the record
and remember to turn down the speaker volume
of your computer if you're following the live feed
and speakers are limited to one minute each.
Are there any public comments?
Yes, we currently have 24 callers in the queue.
I will open the phone line now.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
Thank you, board president Darling-Hammond
and members of the board.
My name is Dante Soliano
and I'm the executive director
for the Sacramento County Office of Education.
And on behalf of the Sacramento County Office of Education,
I'm calling in to support item number four on the agenda.
We greatly appreciate the California Department
of Education's recommendation to select
the Sacramento County Office of Education
for the 2022-23 BCSPP Regional Technical
Assistance Center RTAC Awards.
We will be co-leading this effort with the Placer County
Office of Education to support the region.
So we eagerly await the opportunity
to continue the work that we are supporting for.
We're supporting for community schools
and in serving students families and districts
as a leader in this space.
So we're grateful for the time and effort
put into the development of this program
by the CDE State Board of Education
and the State Transformative Assistance Center.
We look forward to continuing to work with you
all to ensure the success of the CCSPP.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon everyone.
Thank you Board President Darling-Hammond,
board members, colleagues and community members.
My name is Alicia Garrupa and I'm honored
to serve as the Chief of Well-Being
and Support Services for Los Angeles County
Office of Education.
I am also here in support of Item 4.
Our County Office of Education along
with our formal partners at UCLA Center
for the Transformation of Schools
and the LA Trust for Children's Health
are honored to be recommended to serve
as the Regional Technical Assistance Lead
for our greater LA area.
We are truly enthusiastic about the opportunities
that CCSPP presents for the transformation
of LA County Schools to break the cycle
of childhood poverty and realize the promise
and potential of our public educational system
especially and particularly for our
historically underserved children and communities.
We are deeply and unwaveringly committed
to partnering championing and accelerating
the success of CCSPP in alignment
with the other historic state and regional
initiatives and investments in support
of all children youth families educators
and communities.
Many of these initiatives have been highlighted today.
And with that I'd like to thank you for your leadership
and for the opportunity to serve.
Thank you. Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello.
Yes caller your life.
Yes.
Please state your public comment.
Hi.
My name is Lorraine Richards.
I am a classroom teacher representing
California Teachers Association.
CTA is pleased with the work that the S-TAC
and we believe that all the support provided
by the newly awarded R-TAC must be driven
by the S-TAC to ensure that the support is consistent
and grounded in the framework.
Additionally we look forward to working with the CDE
to help ensure that grantees are truly
committed to the framework.
It's four pillars and the four cornerstone commitment.
We believe that grantees in round two must be held
to a higher standard of implementation
to transition from a planning grant
to an implementation grant as well as for implementation
grant recipients to receive year two funding.
All the great work occurring at the state level
to provide these transformational opportunities
for our students educators and communities
will be compromised if we allow substandard
implementation at the local level. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller ending in the last four digits 5 5 3 5
you are now live. Please start your public comment.
Good afternoon members of the board.
My name is Eric Yanez.
I am an alumna of West Contra Castilla Unified
School District a resident of Contra Costa County
a policy advocacy manager and a partner
with the California Partnership.
Thank you for today's presentation.
We appreciate the various layers of assistance
for community schools implementation
and we want to make sure all levels are aligned
with the community schools framework
and have support to be effective and transformative.
For the 42 county offices of education receiving
coordination grants totaling in 140 million over seven years
the current plan does not make clear how they will be
supportive and assisting planning
and implementation grantees.
We seek clarification around what capacity
building support will be provided by and to these
county offices of education to ensure they are effective
including having county-level community
schools liaison participate in S-PAC or R-TAC
communities of practices to establish alignment
with transformative vision of racially just
relationship centered community schools.
I want to leave you with this.
Transformation can only happen when students families
communities and educators and directive leaders
are authentic partners.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record you have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon President Darling-Hammond
and esteemed state board trustees.
My name is Francisco Ortiz and I have the privilege
of being a homegrown teacher in West Contra Costa
Unified School District.
I'm also the community schools organizer
and vice president of the United Teachers of Richmond.
On behalf of the 1600 educators we will present
the UTR is excited and grateful that the CDE
is moving forward with the approval of regional
technical assistance centers to support our efforts
to strengthen and expand our community schools program
in West Contra Costa which received the fifth largest
implementation grant in the state.
We hope that through these regional supports LEAs
will strengthen efforts that center and reinforce
the transformative power of shared leadership practices.
We know that this pillar built on trust
is a relational glue that holds the community
school strategies together while positively
impacting academic improvement and student learning.
Transformation can only happen when students families
educators district leaders and communities
are authentic partners.
Remember that nothing about us without us.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Thank you. My name is Amanda Dickey.
I'm the executive director of government relations
for the Santa Clara County Office of Education
and I'm here today on behalf of Dr.
DeJuan the Santa Clara County Superintendent.
We are very pleased that CDE has recommended
the Santa Clara County Office of Education
to serve as the Bay Area ARTAC and we look forward
to bringing our expertise that our staff has acquired
as an operator and a TA provider of community
schools in our county for the last several years.
We also are really looking forward to bringing together
the county office community school liaisons
to ensure that the role of the liaisons for all
counties honors the legislative intent
and aligns with the state's adopted community
school pillars. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Dr.
Annie Sharp and I am calling on behalf of the Fresno
County Superintendent of Schools Jimmy Ovino
to support item four on today's agenda.
He is appreciative of the California Department
of Education's recommendation to select our county
Office of Education for one of the 2022-2023
CCSPP Regional Technical Assistance Center awards.
In partnership with Kern County Superintendent
of Schools West Ed and Fresno Pacific University
we are eager to continue the work that we are doing
with community schools and serve as a leader in this space.
We greatly appreciate the time and effort put
into the development of this program by the CDE
the State Board of Education and the State
Transformational Assistance Center.
And we look forward to continuing to work
towards success for all students through
the California Community Schools Partnership Program.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
I have a very hard stop at 245.
I literally have to get my card out somewhere.
Okay.
I was even wondering.
So if you know if that doesn't happen I'll take my eye out.
Caller.
Caller ending in the last four digits 7 0 8 3.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Hi. Good afternoon.
Sorry.
Dr.
Hayen Kimner with the California Community Schools
Learning Exchange.
The goals of CSLX are to support systems transformation
not random acts of whole child programming
that often presents at the school level.
It's critical that central office staffing
and practices must model communicable
priorities and integration strategies
because just like schools this requires significant
shifts in how they are structured and supported.
We are especially concerned for implementation grantees
ability to do so given the stipulation that LEAs
may retain the lesser of five hundred thousand
or 10 percent of grant funds to administer grants
manage professional learning and coordinate services.
For example the extreme Delta and capacity
for change of a 30 million dollar grantee
with 30 schools and five hundred thousand dollars
versus three million.
And whereas the state's investment
and coordination grants at the county level
reflects an understanding of necessary layers
of systems change this cap for LEAs does not.
The CCSPP funding is intended to provide infrastructure
for alignment of the other state investments
including CYBHI ELOP UTK among others.
We encourage you to reconsider how such grant
limitations impact the long term efficacy
and sustainability of this strategy.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello this is Dr.
Kendra Fair with the California Community
Schools Learning Exchange.
We appreciate the detailed proposed timeline
and CDA's continued commitment to a two year planning grant.
The planning process is critical to meaningfully
engaging students families and community partners
building foundational knowledge generating buy-in
and planning for long term sustainability
of community schools.
We're concerned that the cohort 4 implementation grant
is flagged as potential.
If this grant is not available for 25-26 an entire cohort
of planning grantees will not have access
to the full two years of the planning process.
We flag this as an equity concern
and also a concern with quality implementation.
Limiting the planning period to one year
risk limiting the critical relational work
of engaging community stakeholders
in shaping community school vision strategy
and development.
Commitment to share decision making
and participatory practices is a cornerstone
commitment of the CCSTP and shortening the planning
period would negatively impact the grantee's ability
to do this.
Also initial CCSTP applicants tended
to be from districts with higher capacities for grant writing.
Many small rural and remote districts
were left out despite serving some of the highest
need students in the state.
Applicants coming to CCSTP funding and later cohorts
should be awarded the same quality planning opportunities
as their earlier peers.
Thank you so much for your continued support of this work.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Lynn Marie Crediani.
I'm here to speak on behalf of Orange Unified School District.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller, ending with the last four digits, 0984.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Oh, thank you.
My name is Sue Gilford.
I live in Orange Unified.
My husband and I have lived in Orange Unified since 1976.
Our sons graduated from the middle school
and on the high school.
I'm sorry, caller.
I apologize for interrupting.
I believe you're calling for the next item.
If you don't mind calling back in in a half an hour or so.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller, ending in the last four digits, 6261.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Hi, my name is Sandy Davidson.
And I'm motivated to speak today as a passionate
about the issue on the change in the school district
for panorama students.
So all three of my children are panoramas students
in San Diego.
Caller, I apologize for interrupting.
I believe you're calling for the next item.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
I'm sorry.
I don't know.
Caller, I'm sorry.
I believe you're calling in for the next item.
If you don't mind calling back in just a few minutes, please.
Thank you.
Caller, ending in the last four digits, 8642.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Good afternoon, members of the board.
My name is Cole Harless.
I am a field study intern with Healthy Contra Costa
in Richmond.
I'm a student advocate and much more.
As a recently graduated high school student,
it's very exciting to hear that the board is listening
to feedback from the community as well as organizations
on community schools.
I'm calling in today to urge the department and board
to be overly transparent with decision making
as well as including the voices of shared
decision making teams.
It's important to note that these shared decision making
teams should be made up directly of impacted
students as well as their families.
These shared decision making teams must include
Black, Indigenous, and immigrant participants
along with community partners and educators.
From the perspective of a recently high school graduate,
students, families, and community members
should be supported as full and equal partners
in discussion and decisions.
If I could leave you with one important statement today,
I would like you all to remember that transformation
cannot happen without shared leadership
and transparent communication. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Aracely Simeon
and I'm the executive director for the Parent
Organization Network based in L.A.
We are excited about the investment
in the community schools program and its potential
to transform the experience and outcomes for students.
I am here today to urge the department,
board, and the state TA center to consider
the indicators for racially just relationship
centered community schools in the implementation
rubric in the annual formative assessment discussed
in the administration plan.
We want schools that not only better coordinate services
but that actually build community between students
families and staff.
When adults are better able to partner to support students
school transformations more achievable and sustainable.
For this reason we were surprised to see
that only two of the eight regional TA centers
listed organizations that work with families.
When the state has so many organizations
that support in this area leverage our expertise.
We CBOs and families want to be part of the solution.
Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Maritza Benudez
and I'm a parent leader in Anaheim Union High School
District and a community organizer with Ocopico
Education for Liberation and the California Partnership.
Students families and community partners must have an equal
and respected voice in decision making at every level.
From our school sites to our districts county
offices and the state partnering with students
families educators and community partners
is fundamental for transforming the way we're doing school.
We really need to have an authentic representation
of shared decision making and truly value
what our partners bring to the table.
And we are ready to support as partners in this process.
Transformation can only happen when students families
communities educators and district leaders
are authentic partners. Nothing about us without us.
Thank you so much.
Thank you. Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon Dr.
Darling-Hammond and members of the board.
My name is Clara Medina policy coordinator at
Californians for Justice and with the California Partnership.
We continue to celebrate the rollout of the California
Community Schools Partnership Program
and this historic opportunity to create racially
just relationship centered schools across the state.
As grants are being implemented we urge the board
and department to send a clear message to county
offices districts and schools that they are required
to publicly present their plans to their school
communities and at the district level every spring.
The board and department should also communicate
clearly that plans should be co-developed
and co-presented by shared decision making teams
that include students families community and school
and district educators and that those teams
should be convened now so that they will have
the opportunity to work together to determine
how to reflect on learning measure progress
and present plans in a way that students families
and community can understand.
Transformation can only happen when students families
communities educators and district leaders
are authentic partners nothing about us without us.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now.
Caller ending at the last four digits four six six four
you are now live please start your public comment.
Yes good afternoon my name is Ernesto Vela
assistant superintendent with the Monterey County
Office of Education.
Good afternoon President Darling Hammond
members of the board and colleagues.
On behalf of the Monterey County Office of Education
Dr. Deneen Gossett County Superintendent
I am calling to support the record.
Thank you.
I am calling in support of item number four on the agenda.
Our county office appreciates the California Department
of Education's recommendation to select our county
office as the 2022-2023 CCSCCSPP Regional Technical
Assistance Center ARTAC award.
I listened earlier to the question of the board
regarding our partnerships and we will follow up
with CDE to provide any required documentation.
We are eager to move forward with the objectives set
out by the community school strategy and serve
as leaders in our region.
We greatly appreciate the time and effort put
into developing this program by the CDE,
the State Board of Education, and the State
Transformation Transformative Assistance Center.
We look forward to working closely with all of you
to ensure that success of the CCSPP grant.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is James Fields and I'm calling
on behalf of the San Marino County
Superintendent of Schools Office.
I'm calling to voice our support for item four
on the agenda.
We are honored to have been selected by the CDE
for the 2022-23 California Community Schools
Partnership Program and the Regional Technical
Assistance Center award.
We want you to know that we are excited for the opportunity
to support our schools by connecting them
with community agencies and local government
to help improve student outcomes.
We do recognize the huge lift it has been to develop
this program by the CDE, State Board of Education,
and the State Transformative Assistance Center.
And we look forward to continue to work with you
and our schools to help ensure the success of the CCSPP.
That concludes my comments.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller ended in the last four digits, 2939.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
That's me.
I just gave my public comment.
Thank you.
Caller ending the last four digits, 8600.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Good afternoon, President Dyerling-Hammond
and members of the board.
My name is Brianna Brands.
I'm the Director of Policy and Advocacy
for the California County Superintendent.
I'm calling in to support item four of the agenda.
We're appreciative of the California Department
of Education's recommendations for the eight recommended
CCSPP Regional Technical Assistance Center awards.
In addition, we are supportive of CDE's updated
administrative plan relative to the modified
CLE coordination grant timeline,
and we look forward to working with you on that.
We greatly appreciate the time and effort
put into this program by CDE, the State Board of Education,
and the State Transformative Assistance Center.
We look forward to continuing our work together with you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
We will need two minutes for interpretation.
Okay, please go ahead.
Buenas tardes.
Mi nombre es Alma Laredo.
Soy madre y organizadora de padres
de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la comunidad de la
Point vale concept of a community a tree of
Point.
Playstation liked
I'm a mother and a parent organizer with bone.
County Padres Unidos and the California partnership.
Regional technical assistance centers should draw
on the expertise of students families educators
in the community just as we hope community school grantees well.
We were pleased to see that some regional technical
assistance centers named community partners
in their applications.
However we did notice that there were some technical
support centers that do not have any formal
community partners listed.
Regional technical assistance centers should seek formal
partnerships with community organizations
that have experienced engaging families and students
from Black and Latino communities in authentic
shared decision making processes.
Plans that are developed in authentic partnership
with students families community and educators
are more sustainable over time.
Nothing about us without us. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Lucero Soto.
I am a parent community organizer with Sacramento Act
PICO and the California partnership.
We urge the department and board to communicate
a clear and consistent message and to support schools district
and county offices who receive planning
and implementation grants to convene their community
school shared decision making teams.
These shared decision making teams must include Black
Indigenous immigrants and other communities impacted.
Student families and community members should be supported
as full and equal partners in discussions and decisions.
Transformation can only happen when students families
communities and educators are authentic partners.
Nothing about us without us. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller. I'm sorry. I'm calling for the Panorama Heights issue.
Okay. If you don't mind calling back
and when we're on that item that would be wonderful.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi. My name is Elvia Vasquez.
I'm a parent in a community organizer with Sacramento Act
and PICO in the California Partnership.
We urge the department to reconsider the priority
criteria for round two implementation grants.
We are concerned that limiting grants to schools
serving 80 percent and in duplicated students
had had an intended consequences of excluding
schools that serve high need population experience
and severe education equity gaps in particular schools
that have significant population in black
and African-American students and students with disabilities.
We urge the CBE to work to ensure that all our schools
with the students experiencing great equity gaps
have access to transformative opportunities.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon President Darling-Hammond
and state board members. My name is Jonathan Lopez.
I'm a community organizer with ICUC PICO
and a member of the California Partnership
for the Future of Learning a statewide alliance
of community organizing and advocacy groups
that censor black indigenous and brown students families
and communities of color across the state
to advance a shared vision for schools.
We appreciate how at the department board
and STAC have listened to our feedback rooted
in the engagement of directly impacted students families
and educators who the community school program
is intended to serve.
Today you will have heard from members of our network
about how important this opportunity
is for school transformation.
We ask the department and STAC to review our proposed
indicators for racially just relationship centered
community schools supported by 42 organizations. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Angelica Honco.
I'm an Oakland mother an advocate of public
advocates and the California Partnership.
We're excited by efforts so far to align
the community school program with other school
transformation initiatives like the historic
$4.7 billion dollar investment in youth mental health.
We urge you to support LEAs to leverage all funds
available from various initiatives towards
a holistic approach to school and district transformation.
As our comment letter and the STAC recognize in addition
to the CCSPP expanded learning universal pre-K
and mental health funds LEAs must be supported
to leverage opportunities like the $1.5 billion
dollars in educator effectiveness multi-million
dollar investments in professional development
and anti-bias the expansion of the community
engagement initiative and the overall increase
in LCFF dollars cross-sector collaboration
and assistance to align and knit together funds
for systems transformation will be critical
to realizing a coherent and shared vision
of transformative racially just relationship
centered community schools. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi. My name is Dr.
Stephanie Houston and I am the assistant
superintendent of innovation and engagement
at the San Bernardino County Superintendent
of Schools Office.
I also serve on the CYBHI equity work group led
by Melissa Safford-Jones and I'm a trustee
for the San Bernardino Community College District.
On behalf of the San Bernardino County
Superintendent Schools I'm calling in support
of item number four on the agenda.
We're so appreciative that CDE is making
the recommendation to have the San Bernardino County
Superintendent Schools Office as one of the regional
technical I'll say transformational assistance
center awards.
I've been on this call since 830 this morning
and I've been listening to Superintendent Thurmond
talk about the retirement celebrations
and I've listened to the student presentations
and I'm so excited to expand the work across our region
for this cross-sector collaboration
to co-create community schools within the southern
inland region local context.
So appreciative of the effort that went
into the development of this program by CDE
the State Board of Education
and the State Transformative Assistance Center.
Look forward to working and continuing to work
to ensure the success of the CCSPP.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute your time starts now.
Caller ending in the last four digits six six six eight.
You are live please start your public comment now.
Hearing none next caller ending in the last four digits
eight four six two you are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Okay it looks like that concludes public comment
for item number four.
Thank you very much.
I just want to thank everyone who called in
and I appreciate the degree of commitment and engagement
that this agenda is creating among all of our partners
across the state.
We are now going to open up for a discussion.
So please raise your hand if you have a question
or a comment for any of the folks
that we have heard from today.
Member McClellan.
Yes thank you.
Thank all the callers for calling in
and the great presentations of this exciting rollout
of the community schools.
More of a follow the theme of some of those calls.
What are the built in assurances for true authentic
shared decision making in this process?
That's one question.
And then are there parts of the state
that are underrepresented
in some of the initial applications?
How does, how is it looking in terms of the rural parts
of our state or are they applying at the same rate
as other parts of our state?
Thank you.
Steve do you want to respond to that?
Sure.
So in terms of, you know, assurances
on a genuine authentic engagement.
What I can say is that this is,
it was very intentional that this was highlighted
in the framework, in the way that it was,
that we brought to and it was adopted by the support.
I can say that it has been a priority
of the S-TAC as we've begun this process
and the webinar very directly focused on that.
I can say that I anticipate it will be part
of the formative evaluation and the, you know,
the implementation, the next implementation grant RFA
is designed to reflect elements of the planning process
that would include this.
And so those are four areas where we think that we can,
that we can use the tools in our toolbox
to elevate this work.
But I think that the fifth is exactly board member
what you referenced the first time
in your first clarifying question,
which is these models for authentic engagement
and being able to share those models
both regionally and statewide.
That's where I see our pathway.
To your question on areas of slow uptake and higher uptake,
it is varied.
There are areas where we did not have strong levels
of initial applications where we thought that we would.
And there are areas where we have a quite
a strong concentration.
I will say that there were in terms of our rural schools,
there were areas of the Central Valley
that were strongly represented in both the planning grant
and the implementation grant, the initial cycle.
But there are certainly areas of gaps
and I'm happy to provide some granular detail.
There are specific areas of the state
where board members provide granular detail
as to where there were strong concentrations
of applications and where there were more
kind of what we've been calling community school deserts.
I hope that answers the question.
And just to follow up a little bit,
what is the plan from the department's state tech
or regional tax to do outreach to those regions
and to support applications?
Thank you for the follow up.
So as Brooklyn discussed,
it's kind of a bi-directional strategy.
We are aware of a significant organizing
that is going on the ground to be able
to generate higher levels of application.
I wanna take us back to last year just for a second
and remind everyone I know that you're aware of them today.
One of the areas of feedback that we've received
from dozens and dozens of LEAs
was that they just had too much on their plate last year
and that they do intend to apply in this round.
We very much hope that that is the case.
I'm encouraged by what I'm hearing from the ground,
from folks who are doing organizing.
As Brooklyn mentioned,
we've doubled the number of webinars
that we've scheduled today for this round of planning grant.
We're willing to do more in specific counties
where that might be requested.
But we also, we wanna be supportive
of kind of the grassroots organizing that's going on,
not by CDE, that we are aware of
and we've been in conversation about.
So doubling the number of webinars is part of the work
and then the ongoing collaborative work
that we're doing in regular meetings
with many of our partners is the idea.
Thank you, I appreciate that.
Every member of the board who has not yet spoken
has their hand up, so I see you.
And I'm excited for this conversation.
I don't want to short shrift it in any way.
I do wanna let you know
that we're about a half an hour now past the time
we thought that we would have ended this item.
So we'll probably be about an hour over
by the time we complete our conversation.
So I'm encouraging you to be succinct,
but not to fail to mention anything you want to fail,
anything that you want to mention.
So I'm gonna go from member Yoshimoto Tari
to Orozco Gonzalez, member Glover Woods, member Lewis,
member Rodriguez and member Escobedo and member Olken.
You are all in the queue, member Yoshimoto Tari.
Thank you, thank you.
So a brief comment and then a question.
So having recently been in the field,
I think that I wanna just commend leadership
because the infrastructure that's been put in place here
is so critical as well as the evaluation components
and the democratic nature of this initiative
because solutions that are co-created with people
really honors the assets
that we have in our communities and in our schools.
And truly schools have to do MOUs,
service delivery agreements, data use agreements,
figure out reimbursements
and that is not something schools are used to doing.
And so putting this infrastructure in place is incredible
and thank you for the evaluation components
that will build coherence.
I had a question for our exemplary leaders
at Anaheim Union, Superintendent Matsuda and team,
including our parent today.
You really showed the connection
between the community school efforts
and by literacy rate, civic engagement,
you know, civil civic engagement,
demonstrating how the workforce opportunities
and action-based learning connects
with the community school initiative.
How has your implementation
of the community school initiative really shown,
helped your outcomes altogether
if you were to look at all your dashboard outcomes
and what is your superpower?
Fantastic question and I'm gonna defer
to Dr. Jared Fried for that.
Thank you, Ms. Ratsuda.
Yeah, we've seen,
I remember we've been doing this for quite some time
and obviously with the grant,
we've been able to take it and inject steroids
into what we're doing.
We have seen, as you saw with our data improving,
even on our dashboard, we're seeing a rise.
We're outperforming our demographics
compared to other districts.
And even when you look at our A through G rates,
we're not only surpassing districts who are like us,
but we're actually working in very close
and proximity to districts
who typically would be outperforming us.
So we're seeing significant improvements.
We're starting to see less and less students
ask questions of their teachers,
why do I have to learn this?
They're seeing connections to the things
that they care about being brought into the classroom.
We've had our instructional coaches or our five seat coaches
for quite some time now.
And because of the grant,
we've now added a tremendous ally
with our community school teacher leads.
So they are a tremendous asset
that we're looking to bring into our systems
to help support and even further grow this work.
Our attendance rates have improved,
our discipline rates have improved,
kids, our students are just more engaged.
So we've seen that connection.
And I know our director of community schools
and family community engagement,
Carlos Hernandez is on this call.
He could probably also share just the impact
we're seeing across multiple levels.
I do want to add something because Steve Zimmer
brought up the evaluation piece,
looking at pupil attendance and school climate.
I think as everybody in this room knows
that we cannot affect school climate
unless we have teachers involved in this initiative
and teachers creating more applied learning,
engaging lesson plans
that are going to really attract,
give kids a reason for going to school.
And I think that that's the model
that we want to present today.
The teacher led transformation of schools.
Thank you.
I'm going to ask that you continue to teach us
what you're doing, how you're braiding funding,
state funding from educator effectiveness dollars
to expanded learning dollars to mental health dollars
and keep sharing that with us.
Thank you.
Member Arosco Gonzalez.
Thank you for your question.
I just think that that really resonated with me
because one of the things I'm so passionate about
is just really having a community of partners
and your community steering committee is really exemplary
and I'm so excited to hear more about it.
I really appreciate collaborative work
in your shared decision-making.
That really is at the heart of your work.
Here's my question.
What have you learned from this shared decision-making process
and the implementation of your steering committee?
Any advice to districts who are nervous about sharing power
with teachers, students, parents, and community?
I know in Montebello, we have a planning grant
and we're in that process of getting started
and sometimes there's so much hesitation
in that community of partners and having voice all around
to really giving authentic partnership
to every stakeholder in the community.
What advice do you have for us
and I would love to continue this conversation
at another time because I know we're short on time,
but anything that you can share with us now.
Thank you for the question.
We're gonna defer to Carlos Fernandez,
our director of community schools.
Thank you.
Thank you for the opportunity to answer that question.
We actually live behind me
is the district community school steering committee
that is made up of those partners,
the teacher association, their president,
and a couple of teacher leads are sitting in the room
facilitating with the district
our district community schools manager,
musical coordinator, students are here,
high school student, a junior high student,
couple parents also having and pushing on each other,
community-based organizations,
the city of Anaheim representative is here
and really that you mentioned power,
to be able to negotiate that opportunity to share
in that similar vision and priorities
that meet the needs of our students,
the families and the community members,
the city of Anaheim residents,
the educators, everyone's voices in the room.
We just had a guest be with us in the morning
at one of our schools and they were here with us
hearing and how things are negotiated.
It really is an opportunity to a model
what we have been doing at the opportunity
that our teachers, our different community stakeholders
are able to share that.
It is a little nerve wracking
to give up a little bit of that,
but the word negotiated is really the word I'd like to say
where everyone sees each other
and we see themselves going farther together
because of the ability to give up that.
Real quick and thank you Carlos for that,
but it's very important though
that those decisions are then communicated to the sites.
So if you wanna scale up, you need districts
that have the systems and structures in place at the sites
because ultimately this needs to work at the sites.
And I think that's a gap that we've recognized
with some of the districts that are struggling.
I see, and I just have a kind of building question on that.
I know you said it's all collaborative effort.
I wonder if you're since you're collaborating
with the Teachers Association,
if you've included an article
in your contract for community schools.
So yes, I'm not the assistant to HR,
but they're in negotiations right now.
And we, there is language around community schools.
And matter of fact, I know,
even though they haven't settled yet,
I know that there is an MOU
that's gonna come out of the negotiations
to talk about our involvement in community school efforts.
So that is coming in.
It's been tentatively agreed upon,
but it's not finalized until the entire contract.
But I think it's a great question.
We remember because we're talking about
changing the cultures of schools
and really pushing on some of the more traditional folks
in our system, right?
And so the union leadership is vital to embrace things
the concepts that we all talked about in community schools,
especially all of our BIPOC
and our students that have been marginalized in the system.
So a great question.
And hopefully, I mean, I think we can get there together.
Thank you.
Vice President Glover Woods.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
And again, kudos to the Anaheim Union School District team
for sharing how you're just transforming education
for the students in your district.
Your presentation was inspiring and example,
a lot of the different pillars that we know
are essential for community school.
So thank you.
Also wanted before I ask my question,
just recognize and thank the STAC as well as CDE
for the tremendous amount of work
that is taking over this last year
to really get support in place
for those who are applying and grants
as well as the implementation grants
of the community schools program.
I think we've seen today from our presentation
as discussions we've had in the past
that the community schools program
is really going to be transformative
for the students that are enrolled at those schools.
And there's a lot of work.
I believe key to that is alignment and coordination
and ongoing collaboration.
So I have a couple of logistical questions to ask
and I'm going to pose my question to CDE.
I in the presentation that there are dollars allocated
for a CDE office or community schools.
My question to you is, is that office operational right now?
And if not, when will it be up and running and staff
and kind of what is the vision for how that office
is going to support the tax, the community,
the county offices getting the coordination grants,
the community schools implementing in all of those pieces?
Thank you so much for the question.
And the answer is, is we hope soon.
We have a, we have the job posted
for the educational administrator for the office
and the job postings in the queue for all of the staffing.
Of this office, I'll try to be happy to give more detail
because I think it's a critical question.
There are three elements to what we're planning
to do in terms of the office.
Number one, there is the operational execution of the grant.
There is the, we anticipate a far higher volume
of planning and implementation grants in the next cycle.
Every grant, as you know, there's processes around it.
And the small team, P and Nisiko I mentioned,
have literally worked like around the clock
at certain times to make sure there haven't been delays
in our program.
The second element is the collaboration
and coordination support that you referenced
and ensuring that we can keep the volume
of collaborative meetings that we have been engaged with
to keep that going as the breadth and the depth
of this program increase.
And then the third piece is the type of outreach
that board members and so many of the folks
that we have been working with in communities
impressed upon us, which is the need to have staff support
in areas where community schools implementation
may need more support.
We've heard very strongly from our rural
and tribal communities.
We have heard very strongly from our ECE community,
which is directly mentioned in the legislation and more.
And so that's how we envision it.
As I said, the educational administrator is posted.
We have all the other postings in the queue ready to go.
We hope to have it fully operational by January.
And I would say, I guess I would take this opportunity
to also do some advertising.
This is important and critical work.
And if board members know folks who are good folks,
good applicants, we are always looking for strong applicants
to build our team at CDE and board president.
Excuse me if I was out of line with that,
with that last line, but I couldn't resist the temptation.
Oh, no, that's okay.
And President Donningham, and if I could please,
I just had a couple of requests.
In our future updates, if we can get a updated list
of the partners for the RTACs,
I know that there was some conversation about that.
So if we can have some of that information
in a future update, as well as to hear more
of how the community schools and the districts
supporting the community schools are communicating
and aligning the work of the community schools
along with the LCAP and all of the other entities
that we have in our, and then lastly,
an advantage of schools that we know are eligible
for the grant that have not applied for a planning grant
as of yet, just for some base information.
But again, thank you so very much,
President Donningham, and thank you for allowing me
a little bit more time with my comments and questions.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, and Member Lewis, it's your turn.
Thank you, President Donningham.
And I will say that both of my issues
have already been addressed by other Board members,
but I still have comment to make.
And first of all, I want to thank everyone
for their presentation today on this item,
and really thank Anaheim Unified School District
for sharing their plan and their wisdom
and their experience.
My two questions were about the outreach,
what was the follow-up, which has already been answered
by Mr. Zimmer, and thank you so much for that.
And also about the shared decision-making
and stakeholder engagement,
which he'd already addressed that.
But I just had one comment to make.
On the one slide where it outlined what the entity
that you would eventually engage with to come up
with what that annual evaluation would look like,
if maybe the stakeholder engagement could be identified
as one single item, I know you have it in there
on that third bullet where it says information sessions,
including parents and students.
But if there could be a section on that evaluation tool
that really spotlights what the stakeholder engagement
process has been, and that could include
the steering committee as well as any public meetings
that are held with regard to get input
from parents, students, and other stakeholders
who are not part of that steering committee,
and also how the information is reported out to the public.
I think that would give everyone a sense of transparency,
and we heard that through some of the callers
who were calling in, that's a concern about making sure
that all relevant stakeholders are involved
and know the process, so just a suggestion.
Thank you.
That was a very succinct answer.
I understood it to be a suggestion
that I agree with all of it, so I want to thank
board member Lewis.
That's great.
Member Rodriguez, you have the last word.
Okay, and I will keep it short because every-
Oh no, member Escovedo just put it in.
Oh, okay.
Go ahead.
I'm gonna do the motion, so.
Okay, member Rodriguez.
All right, I will be succinct.
I will be succinct.
I want to acknowledge Superintendent Matsuda
and what all of his staff is working on.
It's wonderful.
You're an inspiration, the torchbearer,
and also I want to reiterate what has been said
about making sure that there's a structure in place,
that we have all the voices
that truly represent the community,
and that we can, you know,
we still have a lot of that top-down mentality,
and when I think of the spirit of community schools,
we all truly have a say,
and especially the families and our students of color.
So thank you.
Thank you so much.
I think we're ready for a motion, and member Escovedo?
Yes.
Now it goes to you.
Yes, I will motion, number one,
for the approval of the CCSPP
Regional Technical Assistance Centers,
as well as approving
the California Community Schools Partnership Program
updated administration plan,
and delegating to CDE in consultation with,
and subject to the approval of the executive director of SBE
to develop a final list of our 22-23
coordination grant allocations
consistent with the administration plan.
I second.
All right, member Roscoe-Gonzalez, thank you very much.
At that point, if there's no further discussion,
we'll ask Brooks to call the roll call vote.
President Darling-Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escovedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Aye.
Member Lewis.
Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Member Olken.
Yes.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Aye.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Porter.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Motion carries unanimously.
Terrific.
Well, that was an exciting set of presentations,
and now we will have an exciting break for 15 minutes.
We'll see you back at 3.05.
Thank you, Board President.
Thank you very much.
Board members, we need to reestablish a quorum,
so Brooks is going to call the roll.
President Darling-Hammond.
Here.
Member Escovedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Here.
Member Olken.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Here.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member Porter.
Here.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Here.
Everyone's present.
All right, we're going to take up regular consent items
five through nine.
Understand we have three members
who need to recuse themselves from item five in this vote.
Board members Escovedo, Olken, and Yoshimoto-Towry,
please appear yourself
by turning off your camera and microphone.
Please stay close to your computer
so you can rejoin quickly after the vote.
And we will now open the phone line for the queue
for public comment on consent items five through nine.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment
on consent items five through nine may do so
by calling the telephone number and using the access code
provided on the slide that is shown now.
Are there any public comments
on regular consent items five through nine?
We do have some callers in the queue.
I'm not sure if they are on the line for the next item.
I'd like to remind everybody
if you would like to speak towards consent items
five through nine, please stay on the line.
If not, please hang up and dial back in
when we are on item number 10.
Thank you.
I will open the phone line now.
It looks like some of them dropped.
Okay, we do not have any callers for regular consent items.
All right, given that there's no public comment,
I'll ask for a motion on consent items five through nine.
Vice President Glover Woods.
I move that we approve consent items number five through nine.
Thank you.
Do I have a second?
I second.
Yes, thank you.
We'll now hold a roll call vote.
Brooks, please call the roll.
Present, Darling Hammond.
Yes, aye.
Member Escobedo is abstaining.
Vice President Glover Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Olken is abstaining, recusal.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Yes.
Member Patilio-Brownson.
Member Porter.
Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Motion passes.
All right, so board members Escobedo, Olken,
and Yashimoto-Tarier are now able to rejoin the meeting.
And let's see if we've got them all.
Member Escobedo back, yes he is, great.
Thank you very much.
Item 10 is a public hearing regarding the appeal
from an action of the Orange County Committee
on School District Organization to approve a petition
to transfer territory from the Orange Unified School District
to the Tustin Unified School District.
The California Department of Education recommends
that the State Board affirm the decision
of the County Committee to approve the proposal
to transfer territory from the Orange Unified School District
to the Tustin Unified School District.
Regarding the election required to finalize the transfer,
the CDE further recommends that the State Board
not expand the area for the election
beyond the territory proposed for transfer.
This item will be presented by Larry Shirey of the CDE.
Larry, you may begin.
Good afternoon, again, I'm Larry Shirey,
the School Facilities and Transportation Services Division.
Today we're considering an appeal
from an Orange County Committee
and School District Organization approval
of a transfer of territory
from the Orange Unified School District
to the Tustin Unified School District.
The Orange Unified School District
is the appellant in this matter.
Most of you on the board have only heard
one reorganization item, the one we had in July,
about the formation of the Northgate Unified School District
from a portion of Mount Diablo.
The State Board is the lead agency, as we mentioned,
for all formations of new school districts.
And that statute requires you to either approve
or disapprove those proposals.
For territory transfers, the County Committee
is the lead agency with the responsibility
for approving or disapproving.
Local approvals can be appealed to the State Board,
and when that happens, it's your statutory responsibility
to either affirm or reverse the local action.
Just to make the distinction between those two processes,
since we're in the heart of football season
and the World Series is going on,
I'd like to use a sports analogy
to describe what we do regarding appeals.
The CDE treats appeals much as if there is a call
on the football field or a call on the baseball diamond,
and one of the teams challenges the call.
When that happens, the officials can make
one of three determinations.
After reviewing all the information they have,
they can say, yep, we see something that confirms the call,
so that will be what our call is, the call is confirmed.
Or they can see something that causes them
to want to reverse the call, that the call wasn't accurate,
and then their call will be that the call was reversed.
If they don't find compelling information,
compelling evidence either way,
then the call is gonna be the decision stands,
the call in the field stands.
And at the risk of spoiling the outcome
of our recommendation here, that's what our recommendation,
our general recommendation is, that the call stands.
The territory transfer itself is 459 parcels
with about 127 students.
The Orange County Superintendent received the petition
to transfer that territory signed by at least 25%
of the voters residing in the Panorama Heights area
of North Tustin.
The county committee determined that all nine
minimum threshold conditions of the education code
are substantially met, and then it approved the petition
on an eight to one vote.
It also, since the Orange Unified District
opposes the transfer, an election is required
to give final approval.
So the county committee decided after looking at the effect
of the proposal on surrounding communities
that there was nothing significant enough for them
to expand the election area beyond the area
proposed for transfer, excuse me,
which is the default area and statute for election area.
CDE recommendations are that you affirm the actions
of the county committee to approve the proposal,
and that you establish the territory proposed
for transfer as the election area
when it does have to go to election.
Again, that was the termination of the county committee.
The map on the right is a general description
of where the proposed transfer area is
in relation to the school district boundary,
which is the dark black line,
and the boundary of the North Tustin unincorporated area.
It's an unincorporated area.
Also, it's a census designated place
according to the Census Bureau.
We find some lack of clarity regarding
the actual boundaries of North Tustin,
which we'll get into a little bit later.
But the boundary that we accept for our analysis
is what is on that map on the left.
Petitioner reasons for transferring are on the right.
They note that their territory,
their neighborhood is in North Tustin,
the majority of which is already in
the Tustin Unified School District.
Many of their students already attend Tustin Unified
on inter-district transfer agreements,
according to Orange Unified.
For this current school year,
22 of the 127 students attend Tustin Unified.
Their community-based activities
are all in Tustin Unified,
and that the county committee approved a similar transfer
a number of years ago.
Both Orange Unified and Tustin Unified are large districts.
Orange at over 26,000, Tustin just over 22,000.
And the two districts are relatively similar
in terms of the composition of students
on both racial ethnic categories,
as well as on some of the socioeconomic indicators,
as you can see there.
Tustin Unified is a little more minority,
but the minority groups between the district
do change a little bit.
Hispanic, Latino students are about 10% higher,
10 percentage points higher.
In Orange Unified, while in Tustin Unified,
Asian students are about 10 percentage points higher.
But there are a great deal similarities.
On not only the racial ethnic composition,
but also on students who are socioeconomically disadvantaged,
who are English learners,
are eligible for the free reduced price meal program.
The county committee, as I stated,
found that all nine minimum threshold standards
are substantially met by the territory transfer proposal.
They voted eight to one to approve the transfer,
and then, again, they established
the territory proposed for transfer as the election,
just a summary of what the county committee did.
The Orange Unified appeal has three major components.
They claim that five of the minimum standards
are not substantially met,
and that the proposed territory transfer
should not be approved, should not have been approved,
and that if approved,
if the state board allows the proposal to go through,
the election area should be expanded
to include the attendance area
of the El Modena High School.
That high school is the high school that serves
this area proposed for transfer,
and also contains the attendance boundaries
of the middle school and the elementary school
that serve that area.
Here are the five standards
that the appellant claims are not met.
They believe, they claim that the community identity
of the districts will be damaged by the proposal.
County committee found, as I said,
found that at what went, that was substantially met.
We agree with them.
I'm gonna jump down to the fourth one,
increased property values.
That standard states that a proposal should not be approved
if it's primarily for the purposes
of increased property values.
County committee did not find that.
We found no, even though we accept
that property values may go up, up to 18%,
based on the district of residence,
we find, we do not find any rationale to support
that the primary reason for the petitioner's desire
to transfer territory is because of property values.
The other three we'll address in the next few slides.
Orange Unified claims that the proposal
will promote segregation in the districts
and will harm the district's ability
to educate students in an integrated environment.
And those claims are based on a comparison
of the existing racial ethic composition
of the schools that currently serve
this proposed transfer area to the schools
that would serve it in Tustin Unified
if the proposal were approved.
CDE agrees that there are substantial differences
between the sets of schools,
but does not agree with the claim
that the transfer will negatively affect
the Orange Unified's ability to educate students
in an integrated environment for two reasons.
First, as we noted previously,
the racial ethnic comparison of the districts
is much closer than is the comparison
between these sets of districts.
Neighborhoods within a district,
that composition reflects a neighborhood
that is served by the school,
and those neighborhoods do not reflect
the district as a whole,
do not necessarily reflect the districts as a whole.
For example, Tustin Unified has three high schools.
You can see Foothill High School
with 42%, 43% Hispanic or Latino,
and 41% white, but if you look at Tustin High School,
that high school is 82% Hispanic, Latino,
and less than 8% white.
The third high school, Beckman High School,
is 22% Hispanic, 25% white,
and over 40% of the students are Asian.
So again, you kind of aggregate all those together,
and the district's composition
looks very similar to Orange Unified.
Secondly, that's not the point,
that's not the point of this condition anyway.
The point is that the proposed transfer
will not negatively affect the district's ability
or a school's ability to educate its students
in an integrated environment.
This shows the effects of the transfer
on Panorama Elementary School,
which is the smallest elementary school
in the second smallest elementary school
in the Orange Unified School District.
If all the students are transferred out,
all the elementary students are transferred out
from the proposed transfer area,
then it would only change the racial ethic composition
by a couple percentage points at most.
Looking at the middle school and the high school,
which are much larger schools
with fewer students from the transfer area,
the change is in tenths of a percentage point.
The next standard that the Orange Unified claims
is not substantially met is negative effect
on the educational programs of the schools or districts.
Orange Unified notes that Panorama Elementary student losses
will result in reduced staffing at that school,
will result in grade level combination classes
where none already exist,
and lower levels of parental participation.
And they also claim that the middle and high schools
will also see staff reductions and less parental involvement.
Our findings regarding this condition
is that less than one half of a percent
of the district enrollment is affected
based on what we've seen in territory transfers
in past decades.
Student losses will occur over a number of years.
Whenever a territory transfers,
it's not like all the students are gonna leave their teachers,
leave their school, leave their classmates,
that shift will happen over a period of time.
The educational programs of Orange Unified are very good,
and no one is complaining about the quality
of the educational program.
Orange Unified notes that there are many exemplary
and innovative educational programs provided in the district,
including identification of a number
of award-winning schools,
seven gold-ribboned and distinguished secondary schools,
19 elementary gold-ribboned schools,
and the designation of El Medina High School
as the best public high school in Orange County
by parenting Orange County magazine.
So we're talking about programs that are functioning well,
showing good results.
So we do not see that the loss of fewer than,
less than one percent or less than half of a percent
of the students in the district will have any effect
of those high-functioning programs.
Additionally, the appeal does not identify
any specific effects on educational program
only regarding what might happen
at the Panamara Elementary School regarding staffing.
The last condition that we're gonna look at
is that the Orange Unified School District believes
that this transfer will cause a significant
negative fiscal effect on Orange Unified.
Specifically, the transfer would exacerbate
long-term declining enrollment in the district.
The loss of ADA would result in decreased district funding,
and the loss of assessed valuation
would reduce the school bonding capacity for the district.
Our findings, again, it's very similar
to the ones on the educational program.
Less than half a percent of the enrollment is affected.
Enrollment decline that has been less than
what the district has projected for the past few years.
Less than one percent of the district's assessed valuation
is affected, and this is a district that's seen
its assessed valuation grow about 24%
over the past few years.
So in summary, we agree with all the county committee's
findings that the nine minimum threshold standards
are substantially met.
However, as we discussed at the July meeting,
approval of a district reorganization
is a two-step process.
We first look at those nine conditions
and then try to determine if there are reasons
to move forward with the change.
That's the court's interpretation of what the state board
as well as the county committee's responsibility are,
and to help guide us in terms of reasons we can look at,
the legislature has given us its intent
that local educational needs and concerns
shall serve as the basis for a future reorganization
of districts in each county.
We'll look at some of those needs and concerns next.
The state board has considerable discretion
when it comes to school district reorganization matters.
You can consider really any issue that you want
when it comes to making your decision.
Again, using the sports analogy,
what we're doing here is we're looking for things
that would confirm the county committee's action.
Two of those issues that the petitioners have brought up
is that there's a greater sense of community identity
with North Tustin and the Tustin Unified School District
and that the county committee previously approved
a transfer of another Tustin, North Tustin neighborhood
from Orange Unified to Tustin Unified.
The map on the left shows the transfer area
and its relation to the district boundary.
Orange Unified School serving the area
and Tustin Unified School serving the area
if the transfer is approved are also noted on the map.
Tustin's Arroyo Elementary is about a mile further away
than is Orange Unified's Panorama School
which is really kind of a community school there.
It's named after the, as I noted, Panorama Heights
is a neighborhood and Panorama Elementary School
kind of goes with that.
Well, Tustin Unified Middle and High Schools
are about three quarters and a half a mile closer
than our Orange Unified School District.
However, we don't see those distances
as being particularly significant,
especially since Orange Unified provides bus transportation
while Tustin Unified would not.
As I mentioned, the proposed transfer area
is part of Panorama Heights and as the name suggests,
the community is located at elevation.
The only access to the community
is on the southeastern edge which abuts Tustin Unified.
Again, that geographic feature
is not particularly compelling for us.
The map on the right is the U.S. Census Bureau
boundaries for the North Tustin Census Designated Place.
And according to the Census Bureau,
the petition area is not within the boundaries
of North Tustin as the census designated place.
And that gets to the lack of clarity
that I mentioned earlier regarding what North Tustin is
but the Orange County maps are a little different
as are Google maps but as I mentioned,
the boundaries that we are using in our analysis
assumes that the petitionary is in North Tustin
despite the Census Bureau's indication.
So that lack of clarity somewhat diminishes
the argument of community identity for us
even though I need to note that the Orange County Committee
focused on this as its primary rationale
for approval of the territory transfer
and they didn't state that specifically
but through our review of the audio recordings of meetings
and written transcripts of meetings,
that was a determination that we made.
There was, there have been previous transfer approvals
from North Tustin area to from Orange Unified
to North for Tustin Unified.
The most recent was the Rocking Horse Ridge transfer
and that's again not particularly compelling to us.
It was a very different circumstance
than what the proposal is here.
Rocking Horse Ridge was a new development
that was split by the district boundaries
and Orange Unified did not oppose that one.
They were neutral on that one.
As looking for reasons to confirm the action,
you can also consider any reason or concern you want
in making your decision to reverse local approval
of a territory transfer.
Two that we often look at are,
one, the territory transfer likely would establish
a precedent for future transfers.
Or the transfer removes a student population
that has higher socioeconomic status.
In our opinion, there are two other areas of North Tustin,
the unincorporated area of North Tustin
that would remain in Orange Unified
if the transfer area were approved,
if the transfer took place.
Area one and area two, they're on the map.
The real light red area shows the boundary.
In looking at these areas, we think, we believe
that the number of homes and the number of students
combined in those two areas
is less than what's in the transfer area.
So we don't see this as a particularly compelling rationale
to reverse the action.
I will also note, however, that area two there,
Panorama Elementary School,
Orange Unified Elementary School is located in that area
which would create additional concerns
if there was a transfer proposal from that area.
As with the earlier examination
of racial ethnic composition of the schools
that serve the area or that would serve the area,
there are differences between those sets of schools,
between Orange Unified and Tustin Unified.
But again, as with racial composition,
the district numbers are much more similar.
And again, as with our racial ethnic comparisons,
the point is, would there be a negative effect
on what is in the schools, any of the schools?
And even though we did not collect information
on students in the area
who were socioeconomically disadvantaged,
English learners or eligible for the free
and reduced priced meal program,
given the small numbers and the size of the schools,
we do not believe there would be any effect
on any of the schools and especially not at the district.
So in summary, our findings are as follows.
We find that all minimum standards are substantially met
by the territory transfer proposal.
The county committee demonstrated strong support
for the transfer, eight to one vote,
and identified a reason for its action,
a community identity issue that we discussed.
The CDE finds, excuse me, no local educational reason
compelling enough to support the transfer,
but we also find no educational reason or concern
compelling enough to reverse
county committee approval of the transfer.
So again, using our sports metaphor or analogy,
the local approval, in our opinion, should stand.
The CDE also finds no effects on other communities
that warrant expanding the election area.
We recommend, as we mentioned earlier,
that the state board affirm the actions
of the county committee and establish the territory
proposed for transfer as the election area.
I know you have a public hearing scheduled.
I can respond to any clarifying questions
that you might have before then,
or we can do that after the public hearing
at the discretion of the board president.
I'm on mute.
If there are any just factual clarifying questions
that you wanna ask now, we could do that,
but I'm not seeing any hands up.
So I think we will move to the public hearing,
and then we'll have any additional questions
in conversation and discussion thereafter.
I hereby open the public hearing at 3.34 p.m.
We will first hear from the petitioners
who are in favor of the territory transfer.
They will have 12 minutes to make their presentation.
We will then hear from Orange Unified
and those who are opposed to the territory transfer.
They will have 12 minutes to make their presentation.
After the presentations, we will open up the phone line
for public comment from individuals
who are not part of either presentation.
Petitioners, you may begin.
Hello, just doing a sound check.
This is Marlene Graham speaking.
We can hear you.
Awesome, I am going to share my screen.
I do believe we sent it in earlier,
but I will hope this will come through.
We can see it.
Great, thank you so much.
Well, good afternoon, honorable President Darlene Hammond
and fellow board members.
I thank you for your time and to just let you know,
it is a great honor and privilege
to speak in front of you today.
I'd also like to take a second to thank Layari Shirey
and the rest of the CDE Executive Office staff
for their thorough report.
We most definitely agree with the CDE recommendations
to affirm the decision of the local County Committee
to approve the proposal to transfer territory
from Orange Unified to Tustin Unified.
And we also agree with the motion
that they do not expand the area
for the election beyond the territory
proposed for the transfer.
So I will go to next slide.
Before I start, I did want to just do a quick minute
just to introduce myself again,
and I will turn it over also
to my fellow Chief Petitioner, Jennifer Lampman.
As I said, my name is Marlene Graham.
I'm a proud fourth generation Californian.
I had the pleasure of going through
all of the California public schools from elementary
all the way through high school
in my beloved hometown of Montevideo Unified School District.
And I'm also a daughter of a retired LA USD teacher
from Echo Park.
And lastly, my dad would be unhappy
if I didn't talk about the fact that he was a immigrant
at 17 years old with who greatly benefit
from the great programs in California.
He came to this country speaking only Spanish from Nicaragua
and has excelled in life thankfully
to the great education for the California public schools.
I am a mother of three, one still in elementary school
and twins in middle school
that went through the elementary school at Tustin Unified
and is now still on transfer to their middle school.
And I bring that up because this is why I'm here.
This is why Jennifer Lampman's here.
These are children that get to walk to school right now
from their homes to their local neighborhood schools
in North Tustin.
So that's just a little bit about me.
I just wanted to give you a picture
of my deep roots in California
and my deep support of California public schools
because I believe there's nothing more important to family
in feeling safe and not having anxiety to question
where your children will be able to go to school
and that they will be able to go to school
with their friends and in neighborhood community.
Jennifer.
And in the interest of our time,
I'll just introduce myself really quickly.
I too am a product of public schools in California
and the daughter of a 30 year high school math teacher
and specifically in Irvine, California.
And so I just wanna say thank you for all the hard work
that you guys do.
We definitely understand what a challenge teachers face
and the hard work and commitment
to the students that they have.
So now I'll give it back to Marty.
Thanks, Jen.
So I wanna hit on this point most definitely
because the idea that we are a community,
even though we are unincorporated,
should not be up for grabs.
We are unincorporated,
but we do have many great associations
that help make sure that our interests
and that we're served through our community as we align.
And so the idea is that North Houston really is a,
I like to call it a secret little gem
in Orange County being unincorporated.
We don't have sidewalks,
but yet we walk out,
we walk and say hi to neighbors every single day.
And with that, it comes with the idea
that we probably live in our community
because we love that freedom
and we especially believe in the parental rights
of our community to have our children go to schools
based in our community within walking distance
from our homes when they are old enough to walk
from home to schools.
And as mentioned earlier,
there were previous suits that went uncontested before,
one in 2012 and then another one previously in 2002.
Go to the next slide.
Just to give you a brief timeline,
we started this petition in 2015.
We began conversations
or we attempted to begin conversations with Orange Unified.
We never received any response.
And so, but we did have meetings
with testing unified register voters
and we started the process.
We collected over 350 signatures
more than the requirement to submit the petition.
We went through the entire process
was received the approval from OCDE
where we received that we substantially met
all nine requirements.
The one dissenting vote was from a current board member
from Orange Unified.
The appeal process started in 2017.
And the reason why I put in the COVID delay
because we don't blame everyone,
we have all been on this pause.
So we understand the five year delay,
but here we are five years later.
And I show this timeline
because this is seven years of commitment
from our community.
It might be only Jen and I speaking in front of you today,
but our vast majority of 459 homes, neighbors,
we have stayed committed to this, talked about this
through every medium that you can imagine
from neighborhood meetings to next door
to everything you can imagine.
So the point is we have been committed to this petition.
And just really quickly to talk about this North Tustin
community profile and our identity with this,
as mentioned, it's roughly about 10,000 homes
across this large unincorporated area.
We are 100% serviced by the county,
not from any other city,
not from the city of Orange or any other city.
It is all by the county.
And as such, the census designated area,
there are multiple small communities,
if you wanna call them that.
Cowan Heights, East Tustin, Lemon Heights, North Tustin,
and our South Panorama Heights, including Red Hill.
Our mailing address, my mailing address on the hill
and surrounding Panorama Heights area,
it is recognized by the U.S. Postal Service as North Tustin.
It's what's on my passport, my driver's license,
all my mail.
And also my ballot that I just turned it.
So our diverse community, I wanna highlight that too,
because I came from a diverse neighborhood
where I grew up in Montebello and I loved it.
And when I picked my community to move to next,
that's what I wanted to live in,
in an area where we felt we had people
from different backgrounds and experiences
and provided a rich environment for our families.
What's really of note also is the rest of our neighbors,
my neighbors that I can touch across the street
are already part of Tustin Unified, 95% of them.
Panorama Heights too, and we call it too,
because what you saw previously in the map,
you might've seen the word Panorama Heights
and it was cut in half,
because our other neighbors in Panorama Heights
were drawn in for Tustin Unified.
So what we're looking at is to unite
the last 4% that we represent,
that is still currently in Orange Unified
to be part of Tustin Unified.
You saw this map earlier, what this really is,
is a map of Tustin Unified School District boundaries.
As mentioned, the 95% of North Tustin,
which we are most 100% definitely part of North Tustin,
this is the map that we're looking to include.
As I mentioned, 95% already under Tustin Unified,
we represent the missing 4%, and as in total,
the affected students are less than a percent,
which is a third of a percent of Orange Unified's population.
I'm gonna turn that over to Jen at this point.
Okay, thank you.
Just really quickly, I know we heard the argument
that there would be a negative impact on finances,
so we just wanted to highlight
what we have been able to find,
because obviously that's not our intention
is to hurt anybody in this endeavor.
But in looking at Orange's budget
for the current fiscal year,
they're projecting $341 million in revenues
compared to 335 million in expenses,
and are actually projecting to increase their fund balance
over the past fiscal year.
As a finance director for a local city
whose budget is sadly only 45 million,
I can strongly agree with the CDE's assessment
that the transfer of less than 1% of the territory
would not have a negative impact financially on Orange,
and in fact, it'd be so small,
it'd be considered de minimis.
Same goes for their bonding capacity with the assessed value.
I professionally have seen the reports
on the assessed value growth
and agree that there would be no impact whatsoever
on any bonding capacity in the future
should the transfer be pushed forward.
In addition, there was no fiscal impact cited
for the previous transfer of Rocking Horse Ridge.
It wasn't just uncontested,
they actually stated there would be no fiscal impact,
and the argument that it was a new development,
it actually was built in 1981,
but not transferred for 2012,
so it wasn't really cleaning up
the separation of a new development.
It was really similar to what we're looking
at doing right now,
and I just wanted to highlight there on the bottom right
that some of the projections for declining enrollment,
each as the CDE analyzed and reported out,
didn't come to fruition.
They didn't lose as many students
as they had originally thought,
and even as one of the board members is highlighting,
the enrollment is up in Orange over projections
while most other districts are experiencing declines.
Next slide, please.
One thing on, also just really quick,
we also wanna highlight there's a new development
in Orange Heights of approximately 1,200 homes
being constructed,
which should more than make up for development impact fees,
and also any sort of vacancies,
they're gonna have a significant amount of students
that could easily backfill the vacancies created,
specifically in Panorama Elementary.
As Marlene communicated,
our goal of this petition's always been
to unite North Houston,
and while property values increasing are only good
when you go to sell your home,
and as my son has made me promise never to sell my house,
that's definitely not our goal of this petition,
and the appraisal that was cited,
just to highlight, was done in 2013 under a scope
for determining the chance of success
for a proposed bond measure,
so it wasn't looking at specific zoning or property sizes.
It's not an apples-to-apples comparison,
so given the timeframe that's elapsed,
and just really the big picture scope of it,
it's really not a support tool for this argument by Orange.
But really what we wanna highlight,
the biggest one is that this is personal for us.
Sorry to interrupt, your time is up.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
At this point, we will hear
from the Orange Unified representatives,
and those who are opposed to the territory transfer,
they will have 12 minutes to make their presentation.
After the presentations, I'll note
that we're gonna open up the phone line for public comment
from individuals who are not part of the presentation,
so they can get ready.
Okay, thank you.
Good morning, members of the Board of Education
and State Superintendent Thurman.
I am Andrea Yamasaki,
President of the seven-member Board of Education
of the Orange Unified School District.
We appreciate the opportunity to present
on this important issue that deeply impacts Orange Unified.
Our presentation is a summary of the highlights
due to the limited time afforded to us today.
Orange Unified opposes the transfer
because it is a drastic measure
that has severe consequences
and negative impacts on student education.
We encourage this body to scrutinize
and to deny this petition.
Deference to the 2017 County Committee recommendation
is neither required nor just.
I am now going to call on Vice President Kristen Erickson.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, members of the State Board of Education
and State Superintendent Thurman.
My name is Chris Erickson,
and I was elected to the OUSD Board in 2018.
My trustee area includes
Orange Unified-Santorama Elementary School
and Santiago Charter Middle School,
which serves students residing
in the proposed transfer area.
I come also as a proud graduate of El Medina High School
and a parent of two former Santiago Middle School students
and two El Medina High School graduates
who I'm proud to say have graduated from college
and one has gone back to serve
as a public school teacher at Santiago Middle School.
The other is attending law school now.
I've been aware of this issue before this committee
since 2016, and I spoke as a parent at that time
to the County Committee opposing this transfer five years ago.
I found it inconceivable,
and I still find it inconceivable,
that a tiny group of mostly wealthy people
who knowingly moved into Orange Unified School District
could force their will and acquire,
like a hostile takeover, a portion of OUSD
and merge it into another district
for no real reason except their personal feelings
of identity with another community.
This area we are talking about
has been part of Orange Unified School District
for nearly 70 years.
80% of the students that reside in this area
are enrolled in Orange Unified School District School
currently.
This is a view from Panorama Elementary School
looking west up Crawford Canyon Road.
The red car that you see is within one-tenth of a mile
of Panorama Elementary School.
All of the houses you see here have been in Orange Unified
since it was formed in 1954.
If the proposed transfer is approved,
all of the students residing in these houses
that you see up here on the hill
will no longer be part of Orange Unified School District.
This is another view of all of the homes
that are currently within Orange Unified looking east.
The houses in the foreground will be left in Orange Unified,
but all the houses that you see on the hill back there
will be transferred to Test and Unified
should the transfer be approved.
Here's another view looking west
from these luxury homes on the hill
that will be transferred to Test and Unified.
Petitioners have not included any of the homes
behind these luxury houses in their petition for transfer.
The school behind these homes, Jordan Elementary School,
and the adjoining houses will remain in Orange Unified.
It's clear from looking at these pictures
that the petitioners excluded low-income homes
from their proposed transfer.
This will in fact exacerbate the socioeconomic disparities
that already exist in the attendance area.
Less than 20% of the students who reside
in the proposed transfer area
choose to attend Test and Unified schools.
Students in Orange Unified already have the choice
to attend Test and Unified through an existing robust
inter-district transfer program.
The idea that Orange Unified's
inter-district transfer process is unduly burdensome
is unsupported by the fact.
Looking district-wide for the 2022-23 school year,
there are 401 students attending Test and Unified
on inter-district attendance permits granted
by Orange Unified.
Further, our process encourages applicants
to visit our schools
before they make a final decision to transfer.
The transfer process in Orange Unified
is similar to all those in our neighboring districts.
We all have pride in our educational programs,
and we would love for our residents
to stay within our district.
However, we don't force anybody to stay in our district.
Focusing on just the proposed transfer area,
there are currently 127 students residing there.
105 of these students that represent 63 households,
or 82.7% attend Orange Unified schools,
and only 22 students that represent 15 households,
or 17.3% choose to attend Test and Unified.
It would be absolutely unreasonable
to force the parents of 82.7% of the students
in the proposed transfer area
to seek transfers back into Orange Unified
to attend the schools that they are currently attending.
It's important to note that the 17.3%
that currently have transfer permits
did not seek those transfers
because of dissatisfaction with educational programs
or opportunities,
but rather stated reasons are generally
continuing enrollment, sibling enrollment,
and parental employment.
Like most districts in Orange County,
Test and Unified is also in declining enrollment
and is vigorously encouraging
inter-district transfers to their school.
Test and Unified has already posted instructions
on their website for how to apply for permits
to attend Test and Unified
for the upcoming 23, 24th school year.
So between our robust inter-district granting of permits
and their desire for students from outside of the district,
there's no problem for those who want to choose
to go to Test and Unified from that area.
There is no reason to transfer the entire property
over there for just a few students.
The forced transfer of half of the Panorama attendance area
will result in a cut to teachers and staff
and may lead to Panorama's closure,
which by all accounts would be tragic
as everyone agrees Panorama is a gym to the community.
I thank you very much
and I will now call on board member Anna Page.
Good afternoon members of the State Board of Education
and State Superintendent Thurman.
I am board member Anna Page
and I'm also a family and engagement,
community engagement expert
and a doctoral student in education.
I am proud of our schools.
Orange Unified Schools provide a fantastic education
and I know firsthand from being a graduate of OUSD
and also having my two young children in OUSD.
This move to secede is all too common.
It is happening all over the country.
Numerous communities have seceded from their school districts
and these communities involved were less diverse
and had higher property values
than those they left behind.
This compounds socioeconomic inequalities
that plague public schools.
I'm very concerned that if the proposed transfer
is approved that it will result in an even greater disparity
of socioeconomic differences within the attendance area.
The CDE acknowledges
that some county committee members express concerns
noting that the overall demographic disparity
between the districts were a little troubling.
Members further commented that the proposed transfer
if approved probably would move those numbers
in the wrong direction
in reference to the racial and ethnic disparity.
It is further troubling that the CDE
only compared district-wide socioeconomic data
between the two districts
when the integrated education environment should be viewed
comparing the six impacted schools.
There's a marked difference in the socioeconomic data
between these six schools.
The three orange schools as depicted in the orange color
serve a significant larger population of students
who are English learners,
receive free or reduced meals,
and are generally socioeconomically disadvantaged
compared to the three schools in testing
as depicted in blue.
In conclusion, the question is not necessarily intent,
but the impact of this transfer.
This transfer would exacerbate disparities
and negative impacts of mental health
in other students and proposed transfer area.
This undermines diversity, equity, and inclusion efforts
by Orange and the state board.
The CDE makes no mention of these crucial impacts
and is out of date and out of touch with reality.
Thank you so much for your consideration.
Hello, and good afternoon, state board members
and state superintendent Thurmond.
I'm Gumri Hansen, superintendent
of Orange Unified School District,
and I was previously the deputy superintendent
of educational services.
And I did meet with the two petitioners
at that time in 2017,
as well as again, when I became superintendent.
There are conclusions that are made by the CDE
that strongly support reasons
why the transfer should not be approved.
Unfortunately, the staff report
defers to the county committee's decision,
despite its numerous flaws and omissions.
On page 15, the CDE staff report agrees
with the academic quality assessments
for the Orange Unified School District.
And another reason for the denial
is that the CDE acknowledges
that the county committee took no formal action
to identify the reasons for its approval
or for the proposal.
The CDE also found that the approval was quote,
was prompted primarily by the county committee's
determination that the petition
had a greater sense of community identity
with the test in Unified School District
than with the Orange USD.
The county committee decision was based
on subjective beliefs of the petitioners
rather than objective factors affecting the community.
In fact, CDE found that none of the reasons
offered by the petitioners made a compelling enough case
to approve the proposed territory transfer
because of the following issues.
Number one, lack of consensus regarding
the territory North Tustin comprises,
which was discussed by Mr. Shirey.
The fact that the additional North Tustin territory,
and this is number two, would remain in Orange USD
should the current proposal be approved.
And number three, the long standing attendance
from the proposed transfer area at OUSD schools.
In all due respect, the CDE is incorrect
and should not defer to the county committee's
recommendations which apply an arbitrary standard
that there must be a compelling reason
to deny the proposed transfer.
That erroneous standard does not comply
with the education code or title five, section 18573.
Again, the CDE is not a referee
and this is not a sports match.
The burden in fact falls on the petitioners
to justify the merits of the proposed transfer of territory.
Again, the proposed transfer will have a negative impact
on Orange Unified educational programs.
Any loss of students from, CDE opined that any loss
of students from Panorama Elementary School
would be gradual and occur over a period of time or years.
This is purely speculative.
There's no valid reason why Panorama Elementary.
Your time is up, thank you.
Thank you.
At this point, we wanna open the phone lines
for public comment.
Somebody should mute.
Thank you.
We're gonna open the phone lines for public comment
according to the slide that is now on the screen.
Members of the public wishing to provide public comment
can do so by calling that telephone number
and using the access code provided on the slide.
We remind you to turn down the volume of your computer
if you're following the live feed.
Speakers will be limited to one minute each.
Are there any public comments?
Yes, we have currently have 27 people in the queue.
I will open the phone line now.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits, 3352, you are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Hi, my name is Tatiana Kuyumkin
and I live in the neighborhood that is being considered
to be rezoned to Tustin Unified School District
and I do not consider myself a part of CUSD.
I went through Orange USD since kindergarten
along with my four younger siblings,
two of which are attending Alvedina High School currently.
I loved OUSD so much, I wanted to come back and teach here.
So I'm now a middle school OUSD teacher
at Santiago Charter Middle School.
I do not agree with the rezoning of my neighborhood
to Tustin because everyone who lives there
and wants to continue to attend Orange Unified School
will now have TUSD as their home school of residence.
If parents want their child to attend Tustin Unified,
I believe they can do so
with the inter-district transfer form
and instead not make everyone else have to apply
to continue going to their current OUSD school.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Yes, my name is Steve Lampman.
I live in the area.
My neighbors and I have endured
an enormous amount of stress and anxiety
at the annual inter-district transfer process.
The process changed almost annually
to include changing forms, increased denials,
and recently the change in transfer application dates
to miss a line and not even open
until Tustin Unified transfer window closed.
Like all students in the state,
my twins have had a rough few years
due to the pandemic and the stress
of potentially having to leave
the only schools and friends they've ever known,
attend a school in a foreign community
a great distance further away
and or explore private school options
has not been healthy for our kids or our families.
As the board discussed earlier today's agenda,
the social, emotional, wellbeing,
and mental health of students in California
is at a crucial point.
COVID is trying to clear things.
People need their community, stability,
and belonging more than ever.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits, 6059.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Good afternoon.
I am Heather Irwin a teacher and parent
of Orange Unified School District for over 20 years.
I have taught at Panorama Elementary since 2010.
All three of my delightful children are products
of Panorama Elementary.
Currently I have a freshman at El Medina,
an eighth grader at Santiago,
and a fourth grader here at Panorama.
Although we choose to have our scholar athletes
play multiple sports in custom including baseball,
football, and cheerleading,
our core community is the family connection
we have made here at Panorama.
These are the families who we rely on for carpools,
babysitting, and social engagement.
If this transfer occurs I will lose my community
and thus would affect school pickups,
after school activities,
and loss of friends for both me as a parent
and my children.
And as a teacher I am terrified of this transfer.
Class sizes would be smaller.
Thus creating more combination classes.
Thank you caller your time is up.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits 0 5 7 7
you are now live. Please start your public comment.
Hi my name is Lana Tellman.
I am a Panorama High president in favor
of transferring area to to USD.
Currently I have a lot of stress and uncertainty
in knowing where my kids will be attending
school in the future.
Fact is my daughter attends elementary school
currently at OUSD and none of her friends
live in our community now.
The children that live by us do attend to USD
or are in private school.
My daughter will finish the sixth grade
due to my work schedule.
I'm going to need to request a transfer so that her
middle school and her high school will also
be walking distance from our home.
When that time comes I'm not even sure
if my transfer would be approved.
My son will start kindergarten next year
and I will be requesting a transfer at that time.
I don't want to risk uprooting my son in middle school too.
He currently plays soccer with North Testen
and my husband coached the team that plays over at Arroyo.
So my family attends church kids sports
and the kids friends live in this North Testen community
and we'd be really grateful if our kids schools
align with that as well.
Well thankful for the CDE recommendations
and we hope that you affirm as well.
Thank you for your consideration.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits 3-8-0-0
please start your public comment now.
Moving on to the next caller.
Please start your public comment now.
Caller with the last four digits 6-6-6-8
please start your public comment now.
Good afternoon.
My name is Anthony Dang and calling in
in petition for the fact that my family,
our family just recently moved to the neighborhood
in Paraguay because we fell in love with the community
and that is so diverse and tight-knit.
So we've been participate with a lot of things going on
with the rest of North Testen neighborhood
where we have soccer for my little daughter over Sundays
and then my newborn son is going to get baptized
in the church down the hill near Foothill High School here.
So that's where we go to church.
But then you know we often play they often play
with each other as well as my neighborhood.
Now we not knowing where we're going to be going for school
and especially with the you know I'm listening
to this whole thing about the inter transfer looks
like we have to do it every single year
if that's what we need to do for my kid to attend school.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record you have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits 7 6 8 4 you are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Caller with the last four digits 6 3 6 6
you are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Caller with the last four digits 6 2 6 5 please start
your public comment.
Good afternoon members of the board.
I am Erin Roseli the principal at Panorama Elementary.
I have been in Orange Unified School District
almost my entire life first as a student
then as a teacher at Panorama and now as the principal.
I am extremely concerned about the negative impact
this proposed transfer will have on the community
of Panorama Elementary.
At this time 53 of our current students reside within
the impacted area.
The loss of these students and the loss
of the attendance area will substantially impact our school
with the elimination of teachers staff funding
and our programs offered.
Additionally we currently have a very involved
and active parent community to support our educational
programs and activities.
This significantly depletes the families at our school
and impacts our Panorama community.
During my time here our attendance area
has already decreased.
I'm concerned about the future of Panorama
as its attendance area continues to be depleted.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits 0 9 7 5
you are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Yes my name is David Rivera.
I'm the Deputy Superintendent for Orange Unified.
The facts that, first of all Orange Unified
is a very diverse school district
within the Orange County area.
The facts are incorrect and generalized
with the data that was shared early in the presentation.
18 of our schools have unduplicated accounts
of 75% or higher and they're in the close proximity
of the transfer area.
23 of our schools are in the more affluent areas
and they have a UPP of 25%
but they're five to 10 miles away.
For this reason with all due respect
I'm challenging the representation as accurate.
I disagree with the staff report
that the transfer has minimal impact to OUSD.
The district has already implemented
$20 million of budget reductions
as a result of enrollment decline.
The impact of this decision will not only impact
the Panorama community but it will also be felt
across the district.
Thank you caller.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits 2233
you are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Thank you.
My name is Kathy Moffitt.
I am a trustee of Orange Unified School District
since 2001.
I have also been a member of the Orange County Committee
on School District Organization for six years.
I want to repeat the testimony given by the petitioners
that OUSD did not respond to their earlier attempts
to contact us.
As a board member I spent several hours one morning
with all of the petitioners.
I'm shocked that they don't remember that
but it was an in-depth conversation.
But I want to tell you today that my position is
and it's a strong position that this petition
must be denied for this very important reason.
It seeks to segregate this small elite wealthy subset
of the community from the larger community of culturally
and economically diverse neighbors whose kids now
all attend school together in Orange Unified.
These, the vast majority of Panorama Heights students
and their parents all have chosen
to go to Panorama, Santiago.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Caller with the last.
Good afternoon members of the State Board of Education.
Good afternoon members of the State Board of Education
and State Superintendent Thurmond.
My name is Eddie Angel, Executive Director
of Student and Community Services for Orange Unified.
The Orange Unified School District is committed
to providing rigorous and engaging education
to all students to lead them to college career
and life readiness.
Despite having a process in place for incoming
and outgoing inter-district transfer requests
similar to our neighboring districts,
the Orange Unified School District works diligently
to provide all students with a safe
and equitable learning environment.
After submitting their inter-district transfer request
application, parents and our legal guardians
are highly encouraged to meet with the school principal
to allow our district to showcase our excellent programs.
If a family should decide to move forward
with their inter-district transfer request,
the Office of Student Community Services
will collaborate with the family on their request.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
We have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits, 4, 4, 6, 6.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Good afternoon.
This is Kathleen Corrella.
I am the Assistant Superintendent
with Orange Unified School District.
It is imperative to note that the rocking horse
rich transfer bears no relevance to this proposed transfer
and it is wholly distinguishable situation.
CDE mentioned that in 2012,
part of the rocking horse ridge subdivision
was transferred from Orange to Tustin
and only transferred 43 students.
Rocking horse ridge was a newly developed,
guard gated and self-contained subdivision.
Both districts were neutral with the transfer
of this small piece of territory.
By contrast, this proposal would take 125 students
and territory from Orange Unified
that existed for over 60 years,
forcing students out of one school district
into another for what the CDE staff reports omit
is no compelling reason.
And for no compelling reason,
less than 20% of the students in this proposed transfer
will be allowed to dictate where over 80%
of the students attend school.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Sandy Davidson.
I'm motivated to speak today
as I feel very passionate about this issue.
I'm a parent and an active community leader.
I believe that if the petition is approved,
it will have a huge impact on our community.
All three of my children attended
Orange Unified School District schools,
Panorama, Santiago and El Medina.
They had many friends from the affected area.
They've grown up with these kids
that they've played sports with
and gone to Girl Scouts with,
and they're continuing to get together today.
So many entities will be impacted
if this change is allowed to go through.
OUSD revenue base will be eroded with the bond measure
we passed to upgrade our schools,
taking these high value homes out of the equation.
Our Girl Scout Service Unit will be impacted
as we have many members from this area
and we are aligned with schools and a school district.
Our Little League will be impacted
as the boundaries for South Sunrise
are aligned with a lower portion of our school district.
That'll have a huge impact on that community.
We've all been a part of this community together.
It may also put our local elementary school,
Panorama, at risk of losing.
So there are many unintended consequences.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits, 6261,
you are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Caller with the last four digits, 1680,
you are now live.
Please start your public comment.
My name is Christy Franco.
I'm calling in opposition of the rezoning
of Panorama Elementary School.
In 2001, my husband and I purchased our home
in Panorama Heights neighborhood,
the exact neighborhood that's being considered
for rezoning because it was in Orange Unified
and it was .5 miles from Panorama.
Our daughter and son both attended Panorama,
went on to Santiago Charter Middle School
and El Medina High School
with their Panorama Elementary School friends.
Both thrived academically, socially, and emotionally
during their time in Orange Unified.
Our daughter recently graduated from Gonzaga University
and our son is a junior at Seattle Pacific University
as a student athlete.
Our children's current achievement began
and are directly due to their academic origins
at Panorama and continued academic
and extracurricular opportunities in Orange Unified.
It would be unfair for those who want to attend
test in Unified to force my entire neighborhood
to be rezoned.
They have an option of doing so
through inter-district transfer
and if they want to attend tested,
they could do it in that.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Good afternoon board members.
My name is John Besta and my real job is retiree
but in my spare time, I serve as the president
of the Santiago Charter Middle School Board.
I've had the pleasure of serving on the board
of this wonderful school for the last five years.
In addition to this, I've lived just one block
from the area in question for the last 26 years.
I'm very familiar with the schools
on each side of the line.
All of the schools we are discussing regarding this move
are excellent and offer great opportunities for students.
Speaking as the Santiago Board President,
I'm against any change to the current district boundaries.
Why?
Because we are an independently operated charter school.
The proposed change could cause a dramatic deficit
to our operating budget.
While it may be easier for Tustin and Orange Unified
as large districts to bear the changes to enrollment,
it's much more difficult for us
and the school of 1100 to lose students.
We could be looking at the loss of student programs,
employees and operating budget.
I recommend Panorama Heights neighborhood
remain as part of the Orange Unified school district
and no changes to be made.
We already have a process of many times.
Thank you, caller.
Many times.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Good afternoon.
My name is Dr. Jim D'Agostino.
I am the Executive Director
of Santiago Charter Middle School.
Santiago is the middle school
that the Panorama Heights neighborhood feeds into
as part of Orange Unified's attendance area.
Santiago currently has 17 students
who reside in the Panorama Heights neighborhood
and attend our school.
In some years, that number is as high as 25 students.
That's more than 2% of our student population.
If the Panorama Heights neighborhood
is rezoned to Tustin USD,
it would require all of the parents
who live in that neighborhood
and selected their homes based on the attending OUSD schools
to have to apply for an inter-district transfer
to continue attending their home schools,
which would create challenges for parents and students
who simply want to stay in OUSD schools.
This does not seem reasonable to me.
I respectfully request that the State Board
take action on this issue today
and deny the transfer of the Panorama Heights neighborhood
to Tustin USD.
Thank you for your consideration on this matter.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits, 1592.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
My name is Claire Bridge.
I'm the parent of a Panorama Heights resident
and the grandparent of a kindergartner
attending Arroyo Elementary
in the Tustin Unified School District
on an inter-district transfer.
I urge the State Board of Education
to uphold the California Department
of Education recommendation
and the County Committee approval of the proposal
to transfer territory from the Orange Unified School District
to the Tustin Unified School District.
I'd like to add that I find it offensive
to suggest that the motivation of these engaged
and concerned parents is socioeconomically motivated.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Thank you for your time today.
My name is Ashley Pedroza
and I serve as an administrator
at Santiago Charter Middle School
within the Orange Unified School District.
I'm calling it opposition
of rezoning the Panorama Heights community.
Santiago Charter Middle School
over the last five years has been recognized
as a California democracy school,
a P-21 exemplar school where WASCA credited
and a California civic learning school of distinction.
Many of these distinctions have been accompanied
by visits from people across the state.
The feedback from all of these committees
is always Santiago and OUSD do an exemplary job
of valuing diversity, inclusivity,
and providing programs to students unseen anywhere else.
Our programs and offerings would be dramatically different
and depleted if the families of Panorama Heights
were rezoned to test in Unified.
These are and have always been Orange families
and we are proud to be their school.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
How are you?
Hi, this is Joe Irvin, executive director.
Hello, this is Joe Irvin, executive director
of innovation and excellence
with the Orange Unified School District.
Public comment cards were reviewed.
The comment cards sent to SBE email
represent 48 individuals.
Of those email comments,
38 are verbatim cut and paste comments
and individuals did not identify as parents
of school age students in OUSD
or test in Unified School District.
These are residents in the proposed transfer area
who have been asked to send in comments
with a cut and paste email.
Only four email comments were from OUSD families,
three who support the transfer and one that does not.
Four other email comments were from
test in Unified School District parents
who are in a district transfers approved
by Orange Unified School District.
This is significant as the majority of those
who are commenting are not parents with children in schools
but residents who have other motives.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits, six, two, six, one.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Moving on to the next caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits, seven, two, zero, four.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
My name is Sandra Presciato, Principal
at Almedina High School.
It is truly unfortunate that the Panorama territory
transfer may be approved by SBE, creating greater
disparity in racial and socioeconomic status
at Panorama in Jordan Elementary,
Santiago Middle School, and Almedina High School.
The CDE mistakenly makes comparisons
to district-wide data and not the impact
in the attendance area, therefore stating
the territory transfer is insignificant.
The CDE and SBE may not be aware of the rich history
of the Almedina community which fought for desegregation
of schools in Orange County.
This petition takes us backwards in the fight
for equity and access and does not honor and nor uphold
what plaintiff Lorenza Ramirez fought for in West
Minister versus Board of Education case.
Please do not approve the transfer of territory.
None of the education code criteria for proposal
was transfer was met and OC County committee
made no findings because the petition was approved
for reasons of personal identity preference
of a limited number of families and not in the best
interest of the edification process of our community.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
My name is Sue Guilford. I'm calling for OUSC.
I've lived in Orange since 1976.
Our sons graduated from Santiago and Santiago
Middle School and Almedina High School.
I was active with Boy Scouts PTA and Grad Night.
I continue to watch the school board
and the school district while I'm more active
with legal women voters.
I learned about this proposal from a friend
who will be affected.
My first thought was that this is about property values
which since I've since learned that over 80 percent
of the students in the area attend OUSC
seems to be the case.
Property value does not justify this change.
Furthermore we have always valued the cultural
diversity of our Orange Unified community
and I'm concerned that this proposal could change
that important and healthy feature.
Please deny this petition. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello. My name is Darshawn Smallwood
and I come to you as a concerned citizen
and a parent of three OUSC students.
One who is currently at Almedina.
We live adjacent to the area in question
and also shop and have played sports
and test and much like petitioners.
I'm concerned by the petitioner's statement
that they identify with TUSD and I have to wonder
if it's because the demographics look a little bit
more like their neighborhood.
I noticed on the map that they didn't take
the less affluent neighborhoods with them
and you have to consider and ask yourself why.
I think this is a terrible thing.
I'm so grateful for my children's inclusive
and diverse educational experience.
One last thing.
I see a lot of these numbers on how
this is going to impact our district as a whole.
However I think you need to think you need
to know how this will impact our community
specifically the three schools affected.
Almedina is a school that I see on the precipice
and we are losing affluent students
before they even get to campus.
This will exacerbate the problem.
I ask I've asked that you allow all
the Almedina area to vote on a transfer
if you do choose to deny the petition.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Lynn Marie Srediani.
I'm a graduate of Orange Unified School District
as well as a proud parent of four OUSD graduates.
And even though my children have currently graduated
I continue to be an active volunteer
within the OUSD community.
I attended the Orange County Department
of Education County Committee meeting
for school district reorganization hearing in 2017
in order to speak about how this
could create a segregated division.
However, when I attended the meeting
I was shocked by what I witnessed.
I thought it would be a hearing where the voting members
would be neutral parties listening to information
regarding this potential transfer.
Instead I saw links from the dais
from then testing unified trustee Francine Cento
directed at the petitioners after they spoke.
It also appeared that other committee members
were voting on issues that were voting on the issues
were familiar with the petitioners.
At the end of the meeting I then witnessed
the committee members meeting with the petitioners
out in the parking lot with one of the committee members
even giving a petitioner a ride home
because they both lived in the same
North Tustin area neighborhood.
This is not okay.
This was not a fair or unbiased decision that was made.
I ask you to please reverse the decision
of taking Orange Unified's property
and giving it to Tustin Unified.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Yes my name is Karen.
I my kids attended Orange Unified elementary schools
before my family moved overseas for a couple of years
and upon return in 2013 my kids were ready
to start seventh and ninth grade.
I investigated both Tustin and Orange Unified schools
as I live close to the border of the district.
I called the Orange Unified district office
to inquire about the inter district transfer process
and it was explained to me so I knew I had the option
of enrolling my kids in Tustin Unified.
We visited El Medina, Santiago and Orange
and Foothill and Hughes in Tustin
and decided to stay in Orange.
Both my girls will be graduating from college this summer.
My oldest already holds a civil engineering degree
from UCLA and hopes to get her master's
in coastal engineering in June.
And my youngest will receive her bachelor of science
degree from Cal State Maritime Academy.
And I want to thank Orange Unified schools
for all the opportunities that set them up for success
and I'm happy with the decision
that we stayed in Orange Unified.
But it's good to know there's options
and inter district transfers are available for everybody.
So thank you and please refer the decision.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits, 9835.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Hi, my name's Angela Casaza-Stanfield.
I am a librarian at Panorama Elementary.
Additionally, I am a parent of a Panorama third grader
and eighth grader at Santiago Middle School.
I would like to say as a parent in this community,
I choose to send my children to Panorama and Santiago.
I am concerned about the impact this transfer would have
on the schools, teachers and programs offered.
I am also concerned that a decrease in student enrollment
would lead to teachers losing their jobs
and the programs being removed from Panorama and Santiago.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits, 3336.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Hi, thank you.
My name's Steve Allman.
I'm a long-term resident of City of Orange.
My family moved here in 1970.
I've had a long relationship
with the Orange Unified School District
as a student, a parent and a community member.
I also graduated from El Medina High School.
I've also been a realtor working in the community
for the last 10 years
and I've closely followed the petition for several years.
I know for a fact that there are realtors
who are highly motivated in having this petition pass
and they have been aggressively communicating
to the homeowners that its passage
will result in increased property values.
Let's be clear, this has nothing to do with the children.
It's all about the main purpose of this petition
is to raise the value of the personal properties
of the homeowners in that community.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Liz Bridge.
I'm a resident of North Tustin
and a mother of two school-aged children.
I'm calling to petition for the approval
to transfer territory from the Orange Unified School District
to the Tustin Unified School District.
There is a reason that the locals consider
our neighborhood as North Tustin.
For many years Panorama Heights has been a part
of the Tustin community.
When my children are asked where they are from
they reply with Tustin not Orange.
Our neighborhood shares the same zip code
with the greater part of North Tustin.
Our home is at the drawing line of the two districts.
Our neighbors across the street are a part
of Tustin Unified School District.
We can even hear the school bells ring
from the two Tustin schools right down
the street from our homes.
We just wish to be granted the liberty
of attending the school we feel that we belong
in without having to go through obstacles
in order for Orange Unified to release us.
Orange Unified states that they don't force anyone
to stay within their school.
Thank you.
Yet they make it extremely difficult
to obtain a permit.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits 0634 you are live.
Please start your public comment.
Hi my name is Brian Alcarez.
I'm a homeowner that lives on 12282 Manuta Panorama.
The reason for my statement today is for the concern
regarding the school district location for our two kids.
We have lived in North Tustin for the past 12 years
and all of our activities American Youth Soccer
Association SoCal Swim and Tustin Western Little League
have been in and close to the Tustin locations.
This is the area in which my kids are comfortable
where we feel the closest to and where their friends
will be going to school either Foothill or Hughes.
At the end of the day I just want the best for our kids.
We would appreciate your consideration in this matter.
I'm extremely happy that the California Department
of Education recommends to affirm the transfer
from OUSD to TUSD. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller ending with the last four digits 9260 you are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Good afternoon I'm Carl Cohn Professor Emeritus
and Senior Research Fellow at Claremont Graduate University.
I'm very concerned about the CDE recommendation
to the state board on this matter.
As you wade through the 30 plus pages of Attachment 1 analysis
of the administrative record the CDE seems to be saying
that even though they don't find the petitioners reasons
compelling enough to support the transfer
the department is recommending approval out of deference
to local control.
I do not think this is the type of message that the CDE
or the state board should be sending at a time
when many districts in the state are experiencing
declining enrollment.
I'm a huge fan of local control under the right circumstances
having served on the state board during the launch
of Governor Brown's historic initiative.
Given how circumstances have changed in the intervening years
I do not think this is the right message
for state leadership to send at this time.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits 9193 you are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Hi my name is Maureen Better.
I've lived up on Panorama Hill for a number of years.
My kids were transferred to Hughes and Foothill
but the transfers were not easy.
Each year the rules change depending on whether
the schools are impacted grades correct them etc.
And many of the other neighbors that are up here
on Panorama are unsuccessful getting transferred
which is probably why you're showing the low percentage
rate of 20 percent.
And finally I want to make a note that this hill
is a mountain you there's only one way in one way out
you get down the mountain and across the street
is Tustin the Tustin school homes.
Those are the homes where my friends live
and their kids go to school at Tustin.
In order to get over to the other area of Orange
you have to cross a busy street busy Chapman.
And the other point I wanted to mention real quick
is that saying that at the bottom of the hill
they're not affluent neighborhoods.
Those are in Orange it's just a cut off
it's not part of the transfer there they are the city of Orange.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now.
Yes I do want to emphasize that there's a lot of OUSD
and the public interest are the people that do live on this hill.
I'm a 22 year resident of Panorama Heights
there's not a lot of homes that sell around this area
because it is a gem and I am a mother of four children.
My two oldest children attended Foothill High School
and Tustin Unified School District
on a transfer petition from Orange Unified.
Our decision to request this transfer was due to the proximity
of Foothill to our home which was only a half mile away
which was the safe walking distance from the school
and a practical choice for my two children
and who had working parents
and are deeper to Tyson North Tustin.
We're an integral part of this community.
I have a child with cancer now
that I have had to send to a private school
because of the anxiety that I've had to feel
and to transfer them to from Orange
and Orange every year has told me it is not guaranteed.
I want my children to attend schools in Tustin Unified.
Thank you so much.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time starts now.
Hi my name is Jennifer Burecki
and I am a resident of the affected area
and I am for affirming the approval.
I myself am an alumna of Houston Foothill
and my husband and I moved back here
we wanted our son to have the same experience.
There is so much diversity of activities and experiences
and I'm so appreciative of that elevation
that allowed me to be fortunate enough to move back here.
My son is already entrenched in Tustin
extracurricular activities, swim class, music class, library
every Saturday for story time
and by the time he enters kindergarten
he will have five years of this community
with kids that are going to Tustin Unified school districts.
The stress and anxiety that we've heard
over interest or transfers is not something
that I'm looking forward to.
Every single night we walk our neighborhood
and there's a spot on our hill which you can see
Foothill and Hughes campuses.
We always say how grateful we are to live in North Tustin
and we'd love our address to match our school district
as the residents that live in the affected area today
have said versus the employees of OUSD
that are here on the call today
or do not have children affected by this decision.
My family lives a couple blocks away.
They are in the TUSD and I see my neighbors
with their kids walking to school
and I want that for my son.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Hi, how's it going?
This is Casey Bowden.
I'm a resident of North Tustin.
I have children right now that are attending Panorama
and we are pro the transfer of territory.
So just a couple comments here.
The the unfounded comments on the restricted
or limited funding to the Orange Unified Schools.
People are just saying that.
That's not what was actually founded
when people did the research on this.
The original school district boundary lines
were drawn in 1953.
Tustin is a newer school district that was open in 72
as the area was developed and grown up.
I think we have to let the people
who are directly impacted be heard.
It's really cool that Orange Unified
has a great arm and a lot of contacts
that they could get people to call in
but you guys aren't going to be directly impacted.
This is a Panorama Heights neighborhood
that we're looking to get relocated to North Tustin
so that we can align with our communities.
My kids go to swim.
We go to soccer.
All of these great organizations all in Tustin.
We want to be reunited with our friends, our churches,
Foothill Community Association,
boundaries affect us as well.
Thank you very much.
Please approve the transfer.
Next caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello.
My name is Karen Adams.
I am the parent of one current OUSD student
and one recent graduate.
I live in Orange Park Acres,
which is part of Orange Unified
and next to the area in question.
We share many of the same traits
as we both are part of unincorporated areas
and are served by county sheriffs, EMS,
and various utilities.
Unlike the general area outlined by the petitioners,
we are an actual designated community
with a general plan and a specific identity
as an equestrian community.
My concern is that if the Panorama Heights area
is allowed to leave Orange Unified,
they will only be the first of the affluent areas
adjacent to follow.
Orange Park Acres would likely be second.
To avoid a slippery slope of affluent areas
leaving OUSD, you should deny petitioners' request.
Thank you.
Next caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
My name is Lisa Adre.
And I am currently serving on the Santiago Charter
Board of Directors.
Our board is against the rezoning of the area
known as Panorama Heights
to the Tustin Unified School District.
We currently have 17 students
who live in the Panorama Heights area
that attend our school.
These students and their families are happy
and thriving at Santiago.
If they were rezoned and required to attend Tustin USD,
that would force them to leave their classmates,
current programs, and be uprooted educationally.
This would also have a negative fiscal impact on Santiago
as we would be looking at approximately
180,000 reduction in budget,
which would result in Santiago having to reduce our staff
by two full-time teachers and or slash programs.
The students who currently live in the Panorama Heights area
have an option to attend Tustin Unified if they so choose.
But rezoning everyone would cause undue challenges
on many families and the schools involved.
The Santiago Charter Board requests that the State Board
of Education deny the request for the rezoning
of the Panorama Heights area to Tustin Unified School District.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
My name is Jody Christensen.
As a parent of four children in Orange Unified
who currently attend Panorama Elementary,
Santiago Charter Middle School, and El Medina High School,
I strongly oppose redefining the boundaries
between Tustin Unified and Orange.
Taking a large percentage of Panorama's elementaries
would have a detrimental impact for all students
at Panorama Elementary and subsequent schools,
not just those who live in the immediate area.
I have children who participate in sporting programs
in Tustin as well as church activities
and do not feel it is at all needed
to transfer the school district boundaries
to accommodate those community relationships.
We choose to attend Panorama Elementary
because of the high quality of education
and family-friendly community.
Santiago Charter has been a phenomenal experience
as well as El Medina.
Not only is the boundary change unnecessary,
it is not worth the risk of damaging the strong community
that can already be found within Orange Unified
and its current boundaries.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, this is Lisa Green, Executive Director
at Orange Unified School District.
There is no valid reason why Panorama Elementary School's
enrollment should be slashed while Arroyo Elementary School
with 512 students stands to gain an additional 57 students.
In fact, Arroyo does not currently offer any TK program
according to Tustin's website.
As such, TK students from the proposed transfer area
will need to go elsewhere in Tustin Unified
farther away from Panorama Elementary School.
At the county committee meeting in 2017,
at least three county committee members
expressed their belief that Orange Unified
would need to consider Panorama Elementary
as a result of the transfer of students to Tustin.
There is no discussion in the staff report
about the ability of Arroyo
to absorb an additional 57 students.
Nor is there any discussion about the environmental impact
of transporting 105 students to and from the schools
in Tustin Unified.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits, 7, 6, 8, 4.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Okay, moving on.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits, 9, 3, 7, 6.
You are live.
My name is Brian Kerr.
I'm a parent of two kids who are currently at Panorama
within the affected area.
I just want to say this is really about
basically being as part of our community
and essentially having schools
that are within walking distance.
I'm kind of offended that people talk about
that it's about money
or anything related to the quality of the schools.
We just really want to stay aligned
with essentially what's close to us
and the people that we deal with.
As far as the public comment here,
I'm a little bit disappointed to hear
that so many people in opposition to this
aren't the people in the area.
They're basically employees of the district
and people who live in Orange
or basically had kids or went to Orange Unified
that are not in the affected area.
And I think it's really important
to listen to the parents and the families
within the affected area
to allow us to remain with our community.
In fact, I was at a meeting at our elementary school
and about the 10 families there,
I'd say nine out of the 10 of them,
really wanted to see this transfer go through
just so we could effectively stay with our community.
So I really urge the board
to allow the community to stay together
and to allow our kids basically safe,
walking distance schools to enjoy
and then also be at school with friends
that they have in activities outside of school
so they're not bifurcated.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits 7684,
you are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Okay, looks like they might have had a connection problem.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Why are you hanging me up?
Hello?
You are live.
Please start your public comment.
Oh, hi.
I'm so sorry.
I disconnected three different times.
My name is Anna Lamikas.
I am a 36-year resident of Panorama Heights.
I've grown up here.
Now I'm raising my daughter up here.
She's a current student at Panorama Elementary.
She's in fifth grade.
I am greatly concerned about this rezoning.
I do not agree with it.
I believe that Panorama Heights should remain with OUSD.
I find that I've been wanting to have her go
to Santiago Middle School and that my concern
that she's now going to be almost forced to go to Hughes
where she has no friends.
She has no identity with Tustin.
All of our identity has always been with Orange.
Growing up here, my whole life,
I've always identified myself as part of Orange,
not part of Tustin.
North Tustin has been a very new thing in the last so many years
based on my experience and my time frame here.
Also, I have been approached in 2017 by neighbors
about this petition and that concludes public comment
for item number 10.
Thank you very much to all the callers who have called in
and at this moment, I'm going to close the public hearing
at 4.50 p.m.
and we will begin board discussion.
My computer is about to run out of juice
in one second moment, so plug it in.
There we go.
So we can continue, there we go.
Let's start off with Member Escobedo who is our liaison
if you'd like to make some initial comments
and then we'll go into board discussion.
Surely, I would like to first thank all the presenters
who testified, the members of the public who phoned in
and all those who wrote letters about the item
very much appreciate the thoughtful input
and also appreciate CDE and all the work
in doing those nine requirements.
It was a painstaking task, I'm sure, in reviewing them.
I just want to share that I know that these
district reorganization proposals are very emotional
and raise some real tough issues for school districts
and what is community identity?
And I think we heard from both sides many strong views.
I do understand that the county committee complied
with the requirements of the local territory
transfer process and determined that all nine
minimum threshold conditions in Ed code
were substantially met and CDE showed us the evidence.
However, I'm still concerned with the issues raised
by Orange Unified regarding the impact of the transfer
and I'm also concerned about the long-term effects
on culture and the precedent it would set.
I heard that there were two other areas
that could transfer as well.
So those are my initial thoughts and I look forward
to having more discussion and thoughts about this item.
Thank you so much.
With that, we're going to open up board discussion.
So if you have a comment or a question,
please raise your hand.
I do want to say before we start board discussion
that for those who are panelists,
if a board member has a question for you,
you will be recognized and unmuted so you can respond.
But please do not raise your hand during the board's
deliberation or seek to engage unless you're called upon.
With that, I'm going to start with member Orozco Gonzalez.
I want to.
I think I concur with what member Orozco Gonzalez said.
I think that the CDE did an excellent job
in doing an analysis.
And I know that they're trying to go with more local control
but I am concerned of the fiscal impact
this will have on Orange County,
Orange Unified School District.
And also, I understand that it could be a very tedious
process to fill out the necessary paperwork
for the intra-district permits.
But this is a choice that we're making as a family
when they purchased their property
and they decided that they wanted to live there,
it was in Orange Unified School District territory.
So I just, I'm so concerned over the fiscal impact
and that the students that are currently going
to Orange County, Orange Unified School District,
schools have to now apply to move,
to stay with their own schools.
So I think I still have a lot of concern over that.
So it's more of a comment than it is a question.
Thank you.
And member Lewis.
Okay, thank you.
First of all, thank you to the CDE
and to the two districts for their presentation
and for all of the parents and staff members
who called in in public comment.
I do agree or have some of the same concerns
expressed by my two colleagues.
I do have a couple of questions.
For the CDE staff, during the presentation,
you seem very convinced that other territories
left in the Tustin area would not follow suit
and also try to remove themselves
from the Orange Unified School District.
I just need, what do you base that on?
If you could just elaborate on that a little bit more.
It was a quick comment and then moved on,
but what do you base that on?
Yeah, it's, for those of you that have been on the board
for a while, that's a big concern for us,
has always been in territory transfers,
is a concern that this kind of starts
the cascading effect for others,
other territories that meet the same circumstances.
Certainly there's a potential for that,
but we based our recommendation, our findings,
on the fact that if we look at those areas that remain
that have similar circumstances
in terms of being part of North Tustin,
the North Tustin area, there really aren't that many left.
So the ultimate impact would not be really great.
We're not saying certainly that those areas wouldn't go,
it's just that if they do, it's not,
there are limited numbers of homes and students
that are left in the North Tustin area
that are still part of Orange Unified.
Okay, thank you.
The other question was, we talked a lot about
the 2012 transfer of Rocking Horse.
What was the 2002 transfer?
What was the circumstances behind that?
Yeah, it was an area that was very close
to the Rocking Horse Ridge transfer.
Again, it was an area that the county committee approved
and no one, none of the districts opposed.
It had some geographic circumstances, I believe,
that probably prompted the local actions.
It's kind of separated from the rest of Orange Unified
by a reservoir and a very preserve-like area.
So I'm not that familiar with it,
but if I were looking at it,
I would assume that there were some geographic concerns
or geographic issues that were raised
that prompted the county committee to approve it
and prompted both school districts to remain neutral.
Thank you.
I just have one more question for
the Orange Unified School District
regarding the IT process.
I'm familiar with the process and I know
that a determining factor of whether or not
students get a transfer to the school of choice
is if the school that they're going to,
the enrollment is already impacted,
they can transfer for educational programs.
There were several comments
about the process being difficult.
Could you just succinctly just explain
if your process is any different
than the normal process and reasons for transfer?
I believe that's for me to be unmuted.
Thank you.
Thank you for the question.
In Orange Unified School District,
we follow the education code on inter-district transfers.
So there are some that are automatic
based on parent work, child care, educational programs.
And we have 401, as was mentioned,
that are on inter-district transfer to Tustin.
And then we don't think our process at all is difficult
because there's no questions asked
if they meet the education code
and the criteria to transfer.
However, if they are in our district,
we do take time to ask them,
would you like to visit our schools?
And we have an internal process to discuss,
would you still like to visit El Medina?
Would you like to visit Santiago?
But it's certainly not difficult.
In that attendance area, like was stated,
there are 21 students that are on inter-district process.
The petitioners who spoke here today
are on ongoing continuous,
which is part of the education code as well, transfers.
There's no questions asked.
The issue is on the side of Tustin
that I believe like seven or eight years ago,
they may have closed for enrollment,
but that has nothing to do with us.
And they certainly are embracing.
Right now, Tustin has embracing,
because of declining enrollment,
which was one of the aspects that we talked about,
they certainly are embracing any student,
and there's no problem for any of these families
if they'd like to transfer to Tustin Unified.
We would certainly support that.
Thank you.
I'm going to call on Member Olken
and then Vice President Glover-Woods.
Member Olken.
Thank you so much.
I just want to also thank all of you who presented today
and all of the public who called in.
I, you hear a lot of, we heard a lot of emotion
and a lot of emotion about this item.
And I think schools feel very personal.
And in fact, I think the very best schools
feel really personal.
And so there's something about what we heard that
to me is a sign of strong communities
in all of these schools.
And that said, I do, just one comment,
and then I have some questions for our CDE colleague.
Just a general approach or belief that I have
is that the schools belong to the public.
Instead of the other way around, the public,
so the schools belong to the public
instead of the other way around.
And that the public belongs to any particular school.
And I just want to put that out there for us
as we're thinking about this because,
because I think that's an important philosophical approach.
And that said, all of the public comment
and the assertions from Orange about the impact
on the diversity of the schools
and perhaps the motivation for this proposal,
I think, weigh on all of us heavily.
And so my questions are really trying to get back
to the data that we saw about
what the potential impact would be.
So I was wondering if sort of,
I think I have three questions.
One is just a reminder of the number of students
that would be impacted by the territory transfer
and then how that relates to the overall size
of the two districts in question.
And then the third question is just a refresher
because it was a long time ago
before the public comment on why CD does not believe
that the territory transfer would have a significant impact
on the diversity of the schools involved.
So I'm just hoping to see that data one more time.
So Larry, I think we are asking for you to pop up again
and provide that data.
I'm working backwards from the presentation.
Thank you.
This is the socioeconomic indicators that we look at.
At the district level,
there really isn't a whole lot of difference.
But the Orange Unified's concern is more at the school level
and at the schools that serve the area,
and Orange Unified or the schools in Tustin Unified
that would serve the area,
there is quite a bit of difference.
And again, as been alluded to,
I think in a lot of the comments,
the North Tustin unincorporated area
is considered one of the more affluent areas
of Orange County.
And these are the schools that,
these Tustin Unified schools
are the schools that would serve that area.
So it kind of reflects the demographics of North Tustin.
Can I ask a clarifying question on that?
Just to make sure I understand what I'm looking at.
Thank you.
So I just want to make sure I understand.
So the way I read this to take, for example,
eligibility for free and reduced price meal program,
students who the overall percentage of eligibility
at Panorama is 20% or 19.9.
And then the school that students,
if this territory transfer takes place,
the school that those students would, in essence,
be reassigned to is Arroyo Elementary,
where the free and reduced price meal program eligibility
is 7.2%.
Is that my understanding that correctly?
Yes, you are.
Okay, thank you.
And maybe just while we have that slide up to note,
the English learner population is smaller at Tustin
and the students with socioeconomically disadvantaged
student population is disparate as well.
So we're all reading the same lines on the graph.
Yeah.
And so while the first chart you showed us...
About racial?
No, so just the districts as a whole are relatively similar,
but the particular neighborhoods or the schools
that would serve the kids in the particular transfer area
have the discrepancies or the differences
that you just showed us on the last slide.
Correct.
You know, as I think I mentioned earlier,
if you look at Tustin Unified, certainly those,
the elementary and the middle and the high school...
Let's just look at the high school,
because I pointed out some of the differences
at the other high schools in Tustin Unified.
Foothill High School, as I mentioned,
was relatively equal.
We're going to move to the racial ethnic composition.
Foothill High is relatively equivalent
in terms of the two major racial ethnic groups,
Hispanic, Latino, and white, about 45% a piece.
But if you look at the other two high schools
in Tustin Unified, Tustin High School,
which is, I think, if I recall, 82% Hispanic
and less than 8% white, and then Beckman High School,
which is 20% for both Hispanic, Latino students
and white students, but is 40% Asian.
The composition of those three high schools in Tustin
are very different, and that's what we're looking at here,
just the area that serves the North Tustin community,
but when you aggregate the populations
of the three high schools,
they reflect the district-wide comparisons.
Gotcha, and this may be more detailed
than you are prepared to answer,
but do you know if these districts...
Does Tustin have neighborhood schools
up through high school?
And if you don't know, yes.
It has elementary, middle, and high schools,
just like Orange Unified does.
That last slide showed them,
showed the feeder patterns.
Okay, thank you.
Just wanted to confirm.
Thank you.
All right, Vice President Glover-Woods
and then Member Yoshimoto-Tari.
Just one question for CDE
and two questions for Orange Unified.
Just to clarify, can you share with us
when you were looking again at the data
and the ethnic composition,
the rationale of looking at all of the Tustin high schools
in total for the ethnic breakdown,
for the demographic breakdown,
as opposed to looking at the high schools
and the middle school that would be
in the feeder pattern of the actual area in question?
And let me say before you answer, sir,
I understand that if you were to look at the districts in full,
that the demographic percentages are very similar.
I'm looking more so for an understanding
on why that would be utilized as part of the rationale
as opposed to looking at the schools
that would be actually the homeschools, if you will,
for this section in question.
Right.
The whole point of this condition,
of whether or not the proposed transfer
would have negative effects on the district
or a school's ability to offer an educational,
to educate students in an integrated environment,
that's what we're looking at when we look at the schools.
We only showed Panorama Elementary
because the effects would be big,
would be largest on Panorama Elementary
because of the size of the school,
about fewer than 400 students,
and it's got more grade levels
than a middle school or a high school,
so the number of schools in the transfer area would be greater.
So pulling at 50, it was about 14%, I believe,
the indicated of the students out of Panorama Elementary
based on the racial ethnic percentages of the students
in the Panorama Heights area would change things very little.
It would move the percentage of Hispanic or Latino students
at the school from 35.4% to 35.8%.
It would move the percentage of white students at the school
from 46.1% to 47.3%.
So given that effect, and that's what we're looking at,
what's the effect of the transfer on the ability
to all have an integrated environment?
We didn't see one.
Okay, and am I correct in understanding
that the percentage difference
for the middle school and the high school were minimal?
Yeah, and again, the middle school and the high school is larger
in terms of student populations relative to the elementary school.
Additionally, the grade levels that are affected are fewer.
You have three grade levels at a middle school,
four grade levels at a high school
versus the six grade levels
that you would have at an elementary school.
So the numbers of students that would transfer
from a middle school or the high school are smaller,
and the enrollments are larger at those schools.
So the effects of instead of one or two percentage points shift,
it would be in the tenths of a percentage point.
Thank you. That helps to clarify.
And my two questions for the representative from Orange Unified.
One, can you share with us the number of inter-district requests,
inter-district permit requests to test in Unified
that have not been honored?
And so I'll start with that question,
and then I have one last question for the district reps.
We have absolutely no inter-district transfers
that have been denied on appeal,
which is the process to the county.
Zero for testing.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
My last question is in relation to the concern,
the impact that has been communicated by the district
on removal of the students from the Panorama Heights area.
I noticed that one of the concerns
was that there would be reduced parental participation
at Panorama Elementary School.
Can you share with us the rationale for believing
that there would be reduced parental participation
if the students in Panorama Heights were removed?
Well, Panorama Elementary is the community school
closest to the proposed transfer area.
Their attendance area would be cut in half.
The school that they would go to
if the transfer went to Tustin is Arroyo.
It is farther away.
We would lose 57 parents at that school
that are highly involved, highly engaged,
and you heard some of them speak this evening.
So it is the community school for Panorama Heights.
It has the name Panorama Elementary,
and it is also a very, very small school.
So 57 students is a huge impact in losing the families
that are right across Crawford Canyon.
Losing all of those families that are engaged
in your school is a significant issue.
Does that, are you, any other questions,
Vice President Clover Woods?
Member Yoshimaru Tari.
Thank you, Board President.
I recognize that these decisions are very difficult.
There are many factors.
It's very personal, and the process takes years.
So thank you to everybody who spoke today
and to CDE for preparing the report
and those involved at the local level.
I did want to make a comment.
I'm appreciative of a process
that doesn't have complete deference
to the previous level of appeal,
not due to any lack of trust to the previous level,
but I think the system and the process is stronger
when there are checks and balances in place.
And particularly in a case like this
where there's, we're talking about redistricting,
one particular motion may have one effect,
but looking over time and over decades,
several redistricting efforts
could significantly increase community isolation
and reduce opportunities for integration and diversity.
And this morning, our student leaders spoke
of that importance for them in their work,
and the idea of modeling the inclusivity and community,
and sometimes helping it be healthy
to go to school with people
that you don't spend time with outside of school,
to have richer dialogue
and have opportunities to see different perspectives
can be, can have a great benefit.
That being said, I think that
the declining enrollment argument
is a difficult one for me because it,
Testen actually had a larger percent
of declining enrollment than Orange did.
And the racial diversity is somewhat,
there are no thresholds set in Ed code,
so there's some shifts in racial diversity,
but one could argue that it's not significant.
Where I do see more cause for concern
is in the economic diversity proposed in the move.
I think it was the previous slide, Larry,
where we were looking at the percent of free
and reduced lunch that was much more significant to me
than the racial diversity component.
And if you look at the school level,
it's even more acute.
It's more acute at the school level
than it is at the district level.
And I did want to mention that.
And I also wanted to ask a question.
I don't know if this is directed perhaps to Orange first,
and then perhaps to somebody representing Testen,
but one of the public comments
were made about the timelines for requesting
inter-district permits.
And can somebody speak to that?
If someone, I think one of the comments said that
by the time you know if you're in to the others,
because of the appeal process,
I'm wondering if that's what the comment was about.
I think part of it has to do with Testen Unified
has moved up their timelines.
They have a whole website dedicated
to inter-district transfers,
and they actually start as early as January.
And that's very, very early to start accepting.
It's not that we're trying to block or hold anybody back,
but our process usually starts with,
we're an open enrollment district.
We allow students to move throughout the district.
So we coincide that with our open enrollment process
and inter-district transfer at the same time.
So we ensure that we have an equitable process.
And so ours is usually late February.
So it's not that we're trying to in any way block anybody,
but Testen does have a more aggressive,
they have a website that explains how to do it.
And it starts very early that they accept
inter-district transfers very early in January.
Regardless of the outcome of this today's motion,
I think that might be something to take a look at locally.
Just for the parents' sake,
regardless of the vote,
it would be to think about the timing of the process,
because it can be very stressful for parents too.
We'd be happy to do that.
Thank you.
Would I be able to jump in on that
and explain it from the test in the parent perspective?
Sure.
Okay.
So my students have been on transfer since kindergarten
and they're now in sixth grade.
So this process has taken a good amount of time.
But when we first started the process,
the test does have what's called an early transfer period
that does open in January.
And initially the process aligned with
when the release forms were available from Orange Unified.
We could apply for our release forms from Orange
and submit in time to comply with Tustin's early decision.
We didn't get a decision back from Tustin
until later in the spring, maybe March or April.
But we were allowed to submit that request early
and we were able to get released from Orange at that time.
Unfortunately, and the timing was exceptionally horrible
because of the pandemic,
in 2021, all of a sudden the release form
wasn't available by Orange.
We couldn't even get a release form to submit to Tustin
until after February when their period had closed.
And that was the first time that that transition had taken place
and that shift in timeframe and that has continued ever since.
So it's forced the families again,
the anxiety and that stress and that annual process,
you know, to have to submit to Tustin
and basically, you know, beg them to hold a spot
pending getting that release form in time
for their decision process.
Tustin is also an open enrollment district.
They allow their students to participate
to select which school they prefer to go to,
whether it's their neighborhood school
or the one across town based on those programs.
So they have the exact same situation that Orange,
but they have kept their process consistent.
And again, right in the middle of the pandemic,
in January of 2021, we were hit with this shift
and misalignment in the transfer period or transfer dates.
And I can't even tell you how many people,
you know, just the emotional well-being of the kids,
especially in that vulnerable time
has just been astronomical and seriously detrimental.
And to counter the superintendent's comments,
I know dozens of families personally
who have had appeals or requests for transfers denied
with no reasons given just simply parents choice
is not acceptable.
And, you know, those parents were forced to find other
either private schools or, you know,
go through the appeal process,
which again, is very stressful.
Superintendent Hanson, but you did mention that
after the appeal process, there haven't been any denied.
That is correct.
We do have an internal process where we ask our families
to visit our schools, meet with principals,
explore our educational programs,
because we are very proud of them.
But at the end of the day,
we never deny an appeal to the Orange County School Board.
We allow our parents to transfer.
That's why we have 401 students in Tustin
that we wish were with us.
But, you know, that's what we do.
We've always allowed our families to go.
We can adjust the timelines.
We're happy to look at that to make it easier
so that families don't have stress.
But Tustin, I'm looking at their website right now.
Their transfer application period is a very short window.
It's only January 9th through the 27th.
It doesn't give us time to manage all our open enrollments.
And we have several, over 400 ongoing continuing transfers
that we continue to.
Vice President Glover-Woods, it sounds like,
looks like you want to come back in.
Is that right?
I do.
Just one follow-up question.
In hearing Superintendent Hanson's response,
it led me to believe maybe I didn't ask
my original question appropriately.
When I was asking about the number
of inter-district permits that were denied,
I know you mentioned that none have been denied after appeal.
Prior to appeal, how many have been denied?
None of them have been denied.
What we share with our parents is we have a process.
We say, please look at our schools.
And then our executive directors take them
to visit our principals and the programs.
And then they meet with the executive director.
And if they still are not satisfied,
they are not denied, they're allowed to go.
So none have been denied internally.
If they would like to move,
they are allowed to move and transfer.
So do they have to appeal?
And I don't mean to beat this,
but I'm trying to get clarification.
There is a process where they would ask to speak
with the executive director for their special circumstances.
And there have been special circumstances
which have been mentioned here,
the mental health and the stress
and the health of their children.
And that's an automatic.
They're allowed to go.
They're allowed to transfer.
I'm not sure I'm getting a clear answer,
but it's okay.
Thank you so much.
I think we're wondering about the people
who are not automatic.
That's what we're wondering about.
I think we're going to go ahead
and move into a decision-making discussion
probably at this point.
I'd just like to share my thanks as well
to all the folks who have called in.
I understand parents' concerns
about knowing from year to year
whether children will go to school
and the value of being able to walk up the street
to your school and all of those things.
I also, however, have the concerns
that many of us have already raised.
The slide that is up before us now
demonstrates the very dramatic
differentials of the school level
for socioeconomically disadvantaged students
and free and reduced price lunch student proportions
if we were to approve this transfer of territory.
So I think that's a very important part
of the integration goal
that is part of what we need to be looking at.
So I just want to share that concern.
And I also understand
that one of the criteria is
that it should not be primarily about real estate values.
And I certainly understand
that many parents are really looking for
close proximity to their homes for their students.
But we also heard testimony
that there are real estate values at stake here
that are driving some of the discussion in the community.
So that is another concern that I have
as the basis for approving this.
I don't know if anybody else
who has not had a chance to share their views
wants to do so before we seek a motion.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes, I just want to say that as I'm reading a lot of this,
I'm remembering 1976 East Palo Alto
and how eventually the city was left without a high school.
And as I'm reading everything
and listening to both the petitioners and the appellants,
I keep thinking about that.
And I really haven't found a substantial claim
for this reorganization.
And I do also want to thank everyone,
the CTE for all of their work on this.
But those are my concerns.
Thank you.
Member Petillo-Bronson.
Yeah, I also find this slide pretty troubling.
The disparities in terms of the different school districts
and school sites are not terribly subtle.
And I think the language that's actually in the CTE motion
effectively that there's no compelling reason
to transfer the territory,
but no compelling reason enough
to reverse the county committee's approval
of the territory transfer.
I think the slide actually offers an alternative vision
of what might be compelling enough to reverse.
And then we'll be just last thing I'll lift up is,
I think Carl Cohn during the public comment,
I think raised the specter of what this means
in terms of precedent
and also how future boundary changes might be viewed.
And I think that is significant
and something we have to keep in mind as well.
I thank you for that.
And I guess as I seek a motion,
I want to also agree with member Yoshimoto-Towery
that it sounds like aligning and smoothing
the transfer processes may be more helpful
than transferring this territory
from one district to another.
Member Rodriguez, are you wanting to raise your hand again
or is it still up from before?
I was being handy.
Okay.
So I'd like to see if there is a motion.
Hearing the sense of the board,
we may want a motion to deny the transfer.
But if we have a different motion,
I would take whichever one you want to offer.
I wonder, Dr. Hammond,
what would the wording be if we deny this transfer
so that we can follow the legal parameters
on these type of transfers?
I think I'm going to ask our executive director,
but no findings are needed.
So I think all we would need to say
is that we do not affirm the actions
of the county committee to approve the proposal.
But let me ask executive director Brooks Allen
if he or our chief counsel, Judy Sias,
if they would want to word it a particularly different way.
So with the caveat that I'm waiting for Ms. Shari
to correct me if I'm wrong is I understand
the motion would be to deny the transfer.
Well, the actions that the education code
gives the state board decided to affirm the actions,
which is what we've listed here as our recommendation.
The motion would be to reverse the actions.
So that's the wording that we need.
And you wouldn't have an electionary issue
because if you reverse the actions,
there will be no election.
Okay, member Escobedo, does that answer your question?
Yes, it does.
And I would like to move to reverse the actions
of the county committee to approve the proposal
to transfer territory from Orange USD to Tustin USD.
And do I have a second on that proposal?
Thank you.
We have second, third, and fourth,
but I think I saw member Rodriguez first.
Is there any further discussion of the motion?
Okay, then I'll ask Brooks Allen to call the roll for the vote.
President Darling-Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Aye.
Member Olken.
Yes.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Aye.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Porter.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Yoshimoto-Taurin.
The motion carries unanimously.
Thank you.
That was a long and important discussion
and, you know, I think we want to reaffirm
both the intentions of the board
and the desire that the transfer process be smooth
and unstressful for parents who need it,
but also that we retain the orders of the district as they stand.
I am going to postpone until tomorrow.
I want to thank Larry for all of your diligent work
and for your presentation.
I'm going to postpone reopening item one until tomorrow
since we are already at 530
and we've had some very meaty conversations today.
I do want to go ahead and take the moment now for public comment
because if there are any public commenters waiting,
they are expecting that to happen today.
So if you could put the public comment slide up.
For general public comment,
this is invited on any matter not included on the printed agenda.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item
may do so by calling the number shown on the public comment slide,
state your name and affiliation for the record,
remember to turn down the volume on your computer.
If you're following the live feed,
speakers will be limited to one minute each.
And so we'll give a little bit of wait time
to see if there is anyone queuing up for public comment.
Take a moment and breathe.
Do we have any public comment?
We do have one caller in the queue.
I will open up the phone line now.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Thank you.
Caller with the last four digits 7684,
you are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Okay.
Hearing none, that concludes public comment
for general public comment.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Tomorrow morning, the state board will meet in closed session
to discuss and or take action on the following legal matter,
MSC versus state.
I hereby continue the meeting and end today's session
at 5 34 p.m.
And look forward to seeing you tomorrow.
Have a good evening.
All right, everyone.
Night.